WELCOME TO THE JOINT OVERSIGHT
HEARING OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS I'M
GOING TO CALL HIS MEETING TO
ORDER IT IS AT TEN FIFTEEN AM I
DO TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT
HOME WATER WE ARE PARTISAN
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM ARE AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK ONE CAN BE PROVIDED
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE- WHEN WE
REACH THE PUBLIC PORTION. OF
THE IDENTITY OF THE AGENDA OUT
US THAT ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM TO
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. AND PLEASE
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCING AS
YOU MOVE AROUND THE ROOM. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
REFRAIN FROM NOT TOUCHING THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
PROVIDING YOUR COMMENT OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING THE ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSONNEL TIME. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME PANELISTS AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
MAKING USE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND A REMOTE TESTIMONY.
STATIONS LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THESE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASK. THEM
QUESTIONS WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. ACCESS CODE
IS. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
AND ON YOUR TV SCREEN. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE TO PROVIDE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
WE MAY NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG
EACH PERSON HAS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AS WE WILL NEED
TO EXIT THIS HEARING ROOM
BEFORE TWELVE THIRTY AND TIME.
FOR CLEANING PRIOR TO THE NEXT
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE NOW
MOVING ON TO OUR HEARING. AT
TODAY WE WILL BE DISCUSSING THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
AND THE AUDIT REPORT RELEASED
JUST LAST MONTH. TITLED
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL THE STATE'S
POOR MANAGEMENT OF THE EXIDE
CLEANUP PROJECT HAS LEFT
CALIFORNIANS. AT CONTINUED RISK
OF LEAD POISONING. AFTER THE
PRESENTATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING THIS AUDIT WE WILL
HAVE A BRIEF FOLLOW UP ON THE
STATUS OF RECOMMENDATIONS. MADE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IN A REPORT FROM LAST
YEAR. FIRST I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO FOR
REQUESTING THIS ON IT REGARDING
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE EXITE
CLEAN UP. IT'S CERTAINLY
UNDERSTANDABLE WHY THIS TOPIC
ABOUT IT ARE SO IMPORTANT TO
YOU AND SO MANY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS NOT TO
MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
AND ADVERSELY IMPACTED. EXIDE
TECHNOLOGIES FIFTEEN ACRE
FACILITY IN VERNON. PROCESS TO
LEAD ACID BATTERIES AND OTHER
LEAD BEARING MATERIALS TO
RECOVER LAD AND OTHER MATERIALS
UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN. ROSS IS
ABOU ELEVEN MILLION USED TO
LEAD ACID BATTERIES EACH YEAR.
IN THE PROCESS EXIDE
CONTAMINATED THE AIR AND SOIL
IN AND AROUND THE CITY OF
VERNON. ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVE IN THE
CONTAMINATED AREA AND ARE AT
RISK OF EXPOSURE TO LEAD
CONTAMINATED SOIL. AS WE KNOW
EXPOSURE TO LEAD CAN CAUSE
SERIOUS HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING
BRAIN DAMAGE MEMORY LOSS.
REPRODUCTIVE DISORDERS AND
OTHER CONDITIONS INCLUDING
DEATH. SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC. SUBSTANCE
CONTROL HAS BEEN WORKING TO
IDENTIFY LEAD CONTAMINATION AND
WORDS PRESENT TO REMOVE IT FROM
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES CHILD
CARE CENTERS PARKS AND SCHOOLS.
NOT A REPORT CERTAINLY RAISES
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
REGARDING THE CLEAN UP OF THE
LAD INCLUDING WHITE CHILD WHY
CHILD CARE CENTERS PARKS
SCHOOLS HAVE NOT BEEN
CONSISTENTLY PRIORITIZED
WHETHER WILL CLEAN UP THE
PROPERTIES WITHIN THE TIME
FRAME IT'S SET AS ITS GOAL. AND
THE INCREASING COST OF THE
CLEANUP. ALTHOUGH NOT DIRECTLY
COVERED IN THE ON REPORT I'M
SURE THE RECENT BANKRUPTCY OF
EXCITED CAN ONLY ADD TO THE
FRUSTRATION. COMPLEXITY AND THE
COST OF THE CLEANUP. OF TODAY'S
HEARING WILL PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A LITTLE
CLARITY TO THESE ISSUES. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO ASK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRKTHE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL-SAFETY OF TOXICS MATERIALS TO
SEE IF HE HAS ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. AND THEN JUST DUE TO
THE TIME CONSTRAINT US THE
MEMBERS IF THEY WANT TO- THEY
WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT TO
INCLUDE THAT IN THEIR QUESTIONS
SINCE WE NEED TO BE OUT OF THE
ROOM BY TWELVE THIRTY SURE.
MISTER CORK. THANK YOU. FOR IN
READING THE ALRIGHT REPORT-
QUITE A BIT OF A BILLS WITH THE
FACT THAT. HELLO TIME IT TOOK A
LOT MORE TIME AND MONEY I THINK
PARTLY THAT WAS BECAUSE ONE OF
CONTRACTORS REALLY JUST DIDN'T
PERFORM. BOB BUT WHAT THE-
RIGHT ONE OF TOXIC MATERIALS-
THE SIZE OF THEIR RESPONSES-
THEY ARE PARTICULARLY DURING
ALL OF THE THINGS NOW THAT. THE
COMMITTEE HAD THAT ADDED TO
THEM OUR SUGGESTED INCLUDING
LOWER PRIORITIZE AND- THE US
DAYCARE CENTERS SARAH- BUT I
ALSO WANT TO SAY I'VE DONE
DIFFICULT PROJECTS MYSELF AND
YOU ALWAYS. DEL KNOW WHAT THE
TIME SCALE WILL BUILD. GO GO
AHEAD OF US- BURKE I THINK
WE'RE WORKING ON AUDIO TO
FORGET JUST HAVE THE AUDIENCE
MEMBERS NOT SPEAK SO LOUDLY TO
INTERRUPT THE HEARING THANK YOU.
WORLD. I'LL TRY AND SPEAK
LOUDER WELL THAT HELPS ALL
RIGHT. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THE ONE YOU'RE STARTING A
PROJECT WHICH NO ONE HAS DONE
BEFORE NO ONE'S DONE SOMETHING
THIS MASSIVE IT'S VERY HARD TO
GO TO BED AT NIGHT ON TIME. LOS
I THINK THEY HAVE SLOWED DOWN
LONG. BUT I DON'T ROOM. I DON'T
TOTALLY BLAME THEM FOR NOT
GETTING IT RIGHT GETTING THAT
THAT OFTEN HAPPENS THE MAIN
THING I HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT NOW
IS WHAT WE DO IN THE FUTURE ARE
THAT WE HAVE MORE REALISTIC
ESTIMATES OF TIME AND COST.
EFFECTIVE THANK YOU RISK WORK
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO A PANEL. TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
OUR FIRST PANEL THE OVERVIEW OF
THE AUDIT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TAX- SUBSTANCE CONTROL WITH US
WE HAVE- MISS. ELAINE HOW ARE
CALIFORNIA'S STATE AUDITOR AND
MISTER- BOB HERE'S PRINCE
WATER. WE CAN MOVE TO OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
PLEASE. HOW DO I KNOW THAT.
OKAY SO GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
FOR THE RECORD MY NAME'S ELAINE
HOWELL CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
AND I'M GOING TO PRESENT AN
OVERVIEW OF THE AUDIT REPORT
THAT WE ISSUE AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A SALAS INDICATED JUST
RECENTLY ON THE- EXCITE A TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CLEAN UP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE TWO KEY
ISSUES IN THE AUDIT REPORT. ONE
RELATED TO THE CASE OF THE
CLEAN. ARE OCCURRING AT THE-
VERY SITES AND THE COST OF THE
CLEANUP SO I'M GONNA START WITH
THE CLEAN UP OUR SCHEDULE AND
WHAT WE CONCLUDED IN THE AUDIT
REPORT IS A CLEAN UP OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION- IS BEHIND
SCHEDULE- THE- WHAT KIND OF
TACTICS. CONTROL ESTIMATED THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO CLEAN UP
TO THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PROPERTIES WHICH THAT WERE THE
MOST CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES-
BY JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BUT BASED ON THEIR
PACE THUS FAR- AND THE NUMBER
OF SITES THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CLEAN UP THE DAY WILL NOT
ACCOMPLISH OUR CLEANING ALL
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PROPERTIES
BY JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THEN AS THE CHAIRMAN
INDICATED THERE WERE SOME
PROPERTIES- FIFTY PROPERTIES
THAT HAD SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
LEAD. CONTAMINATION THAT WE
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
HAVE PRIORITIZED IN THESE
INCLUDED SCHOOLS CHILD CARE
CENTERS AND PARKS. AND WHAT WE
FOUND WHEN WE CONDUCTED THE
AUDIT EARLIER THIS YEAR. THERE
WERE THIRTY ONE OF THOSE FIFTY
PROPERTIES THAT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN CLEANED UP- MOST OF THEM
BEING CHILD CARE CENTERS TWENTY
SIX CHILD CARE CENTERS THREE
PARKS. AND TWO SCHOOLS ALSO
THOSE FACILITIES ARE THOSE
SITES ACTUALLY ARE STILL NEED
TO BE CLEANED UP. AND THE LEAD
CONTAMINATION TO BE REMOVED AND
AS YOU ARE YOU KNOW CONCERNED
EYES. THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT RISK
TO. NOT ONLY ADULTS BUT
CHILDREN WHO FREQUENTLY CHILD
CARE CENTERS AND THE PARKS AND
CERTAINLY THE SCHOOLS ARE WHEN
KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL- THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T YOU KNOW THE
REASON THEY'RE BEHIND I
APOLOGIZE FOR MY MASK PLAYING.
UP THE REASON THEY'RE BEHIND IN.
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED SITES TO
GETTING THOSE CLEANED UP BY
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEY
ACTUALLY HAD ESTIMATED THE PACE
OF CLEANUP WOULD BE. BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY FIVE
PROPERTIES PER WEEK AND THEY
HAVE NOT ACCOMPLISHED THAT THEY
HIREDTO CONTRACTORS- AND
NEITHER OF THOSE CONTRACTORS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MEET THAT
CASE OF CLEANUP. AND EIGHT ONE
OF THE CONTRACTORS THEY
ACTUALLY- DECIDED TO HAVE THAT
CONTRACTOR STOP CLEANING UP
PROPERTIES BECAUSE THEY THEY
COST OVERRUNS WERE JUST TOO
SIGNIFICANT FOR THEM. I TO
CONTINUE TO USE THAT
CONTRACTORS SO THE PACE HAS HAS
DIMINISHED SIGNIFICANTLY- EVEN
THOUGH THEY ESTIMATED THE PACE
TO BE TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY
FIVE. WE LOOKED AT A TIME FRAME
PRIOR TO COPE IT BECAUSE
CERTAINLY COVERED HAS HAD AN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON THE ABILITY
TO CLEAN PROPERTIES BUT WE
LOOKED AT A TIME FRAME OF MARCH
TWENTY NINETEEN TWO FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY. TO SEE WHAT THE
PACE WISE AND THE PACE WAS
ACTUALLY ABOUT TWENTY
PROPERTIES PER WEEK SO
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN THE
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE
PROPERTIES THEY WERE EXPECTING
WOULD BE CLEANED UP. DURING THE
COURSE OF THIS. CLEAN UP
PROJECT AT THE PACE OF TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE THEY
THOUGHT THEY'D HAVE A CLEANED
UP BY- DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT THAT IS- WELL
ACTUALLY BY JUNE SO IF THEY
STICK WITH THE TWENTY
PROPERTIES PER WEEK. THEY WILL
HAVE EVERYTHING CLEANED UP OF
THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED BY
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BUT BECAUSE THEY- HAD A CEASE
AND DESIST BASICALLY WOULD WANT
TO CONTRACTORS THE PACE NOW IS
EVEN DROP DOWN EVEN FURTHER
IT'S ABOUT SIXTEEN PROPERTIES.
PER WEEK AND NOW THAT PUSHES
THE CLEAN UP COMPLETION OF THE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PROPERTIES
OUT TO. TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO
THINGS ARE GETTING PUSHED OUT
FURTHER AND FURTHER BECAUSE OF
THE PACE- JUST NOT
ACCOMPLISHING WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAD ORIGINALLY
EXPECTED WHEN THEY- THEY ARE
IDENTIFIED. ALL THE PROPERTIES
THAT NEEDED TO BE CLEANED UP.
SO THAT'S A SIX. COMES NOW WHY
IS THIS HAPPENING I MENTION ONE
THING WHERE- THEY HAD TO HAVE
ONE CONTRACTOR BASICALLY CEASE
AND DESIST WORK. ON THE OTHER
ISSUE IS THEY DIDN'T. ENFORCE
CERTAIN PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
THAT WERE IN THE CONTRACTS AS
FAR AS PASTE. UP FOR CLEAN UP.
SO THAT THOSE WERE A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS THAT WE IDENTIFIED-
THAT SINGS OF THE DEPARTMENT
COULD HAVE. AND PERHAPS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DOING. THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE CLEAN UP THAT'S
BEEN OCCURRING THUS FAR. WE
ALSO IDENTIFIED IN THE
DEPARTMENT KNOWS THIS THERE'S
FORTY SIX HUNDRED. ADDITIONAL
PROPERTIES. ARE THAT NEED TO BE
CLEANED UP THEY'RE NOT AS
CONTAMINATED AS A THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED BUT THEY STILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONTAMINATION- AND
THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT HAVE A
STRATEGY OR A TIMELINE FOR
THERE'S FORTY SIX HUNDRED
PROPERTIES. SO THAT AGAIN.
SKEWS ME THAT'S- THAT'S
INFORMATION THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
WELL ONCE WE GET THE THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED CLEANED UP. DO WE HAVE
A STRATEGY OR TIMELINE FOR
THESE OTHER FORTY SIX HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THAT CONTAIN
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION. SO WE MADE A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
THE SCHEDULING. FIRST WE FELT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT NEED TO
IMMEDIATELY SOLICITA CONTRACTOR
TO WORK ON THOSE THIRTY ONE
PROPERTIES DOES CHILD CARE
CENTERS THE SCHOOLS AND THOSE
PARKS THEY NEED TO GET THOSE-
SITES CLEANED UP AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND THERE IS A- A
PROCESS THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN
USE. IT'S CALLED TIME CRITICAL
REMOVAL ACTION TO CRA AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY AN EXPEDITED
PROCESS THE DEPARTMENT COULD
USE. TO GET THOSE THIRTY ONE
SITES CLEANED UP- MORE MORE
QUICKLY THAN THAN HAS HAPPENED
IN THE PAST SO THAT'S ONE
RECOMMENDATION. ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION IS OF COURSE
THEY NEED TO IMMEDIATELY
SOLICIT ADDITIONAL CONTRACTORS
TO ASSIST IN THE CLEANUP
BECAUSE ONE CONTRACTOR IS JUST
NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH THAT
PUSHES THE TIMELINE WAY TOO FAR
OUT AND CONTINUES TO EXPOSE
PEOPLE TO RISK OF LEAD
POISONING. SO THEY NEED TO ACT
TO GET ADDITIONAL CONTRACTORS
ON BOARD AND THEN ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN THEY DO INCLUDED
THEY SHOULD INCLUDE PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS IN THOSE CONTRACTS.
THEY HOLD THE CONTRACTORS TO
THOSE STANDARDS. AND THEN THE
LAST- RECOMMENDATION RELATED
TO. THE PACE OF CLEANUP WOULD
BE BY SPRING OF NEXT YEAR TO
REALLY GET TOGETHER
INFORMATION. RELATED TO THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED BUT ALSO THE FORTY SIX
HUNDRED AND GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. CERTAINLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE NEXT STEPS
AND WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS AS
FAR AS CLEANING UP. THE
CONTAMINATED SITES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS INFORMATION
NEEDS TO BE POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE AND WE BELIEVE IT
SHOULD BE UPDATED AT A MINIMUM
EVERY SIX MONTHS FOR THE PUBLIC
AND AGAINST THE LEGISLATURE.
THE SECOND MAIN SECTION OF THE
ART REPORT IS RELATED TO COST-
AS MEMBERS ARE I'M SURE WELL
AWARE THE LEGISLATURE. ARE
PROVIDED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT. TO CLEAN UP WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT SOUGHT THEY
WOULD ACCOMPLISH WOULD BE ABLE
TO CLEAN UP THOSE THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED SITES WITH THAT TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
HOWEVER IN LOOKING AT THE COST
US FAR AND HOW MUCH THEY'RE
EXPANDING TO CLEAN SITES ARE
THAT TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS GOING TO FALL SHORT.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE
A- TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE OUT
OF THOSE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THAT WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO GET CLEAN WAS AT TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION. WE
ESTIMATE THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS
AT LEAST ANOTHER TWENTY ONE
MILLION. JUST FINISHED JUST
THOSE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
PROPERTY SO THAT'S THE AT THE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED. NOW AS- AS
I MENTIONED THERE ARE FORTY SIX
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES
THAT NEED TO BE CLEANED. THEY
HAVE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS LEFT.
ON CONTAMINATION ON THEM SO. WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TOXIC SUBSTANCES BASED ON YOU
KNOW PAST. HISTORY OF THE
ESTIMATES FOR CLEANING
PROPERTIES WILL NEED ANOTHER
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS SO THE TOTAL
COST. TO CLEAN UP ALL OF THE
CONTAMINATED SITES- DUE TO THE
EXACT. UP THE EGGS I'D LET LET
YOU KNOW CONTAMINATION AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA VERNON
AREA- WILL BE A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- WHY WERE SOME OF THESE
THESE ESTIMATES ARE TOO LOW- WE
FEEL THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TACTICS THERE WERE CERTAIN
ELEMENTS CERTAINLY THAT ARE OUT
OF THEIR CONTROL- BUT THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE
DEFINITELY WITHIN THEIR CONTROL
WHEN THEY WERE PUTTING THE
ESTIMATES TOGETHER. FOR EXAMPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ANY
CONTRACT WHEN YOU'RE
CONTRACTING WITH SOMEONE TO DO
THIS TYPE OF WORK. YOU HAVE TO
CONSIDER PREVAILING WAGE YOU
KNOW THIS PROJECT IS GOING TO
TAKE MULTIPLE YEARS TO
COMPLETE. SO YOU SHOULD HAVE
INCLUDED A FACTOR FOR
INFLATION. AND THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF THINGS THAT WE DID NOT
SEE- AND THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATES
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT WAS COMING UP WITH
AN ESTIMATED COST OF ABOUT
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
PROPERTY. RIGHT NOW WE ESTIMATE
IT'S ARE ON AVERAGE ABOUT SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
PROPERTY SO THERE CERTAINLY ARE
THINGS THAT WERE NOT IN THEIR
CONTROL WHETHER IT'S CETERA BUT
THERE WERE THINGS LIKE
PREVAILING WAGE AND INFLATION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT COULD HAVE
CONSIDERED WHEN IT CAME UP WITH
THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATES. ON THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT WE HAD. WITH
THE DEPARTMENT IS AS I
MENTIONED THERE WAS THAT ONE
CONTRACTOR. THAT THE
DEPARTMENT- ESSENTIALLY YOU
KNOW ORDERED THEM TO STOP
CONDUCTING WORK- AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF SIGNIFICANT COST
OVERRUNS WILL THAT CONTRACT.
WAS FOR TIME AND MATERIALS
RATHER THAN A FIXED PRICE
CONTRACT. IT WAS TIME AND
MATERIAL SO THAT CONTRACTOR
WENT OVER BUDGET BY ABOUT
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT BASICALLY
TOLD THEM TO STOP WORKING- SO
WE THINK THAT YOU KNOW OF
COURSE OF BEST PRACTICE IS A
FIXED PRICE CONTRACT. IF YOU
CAN'T DO THAT AT LEAST PERHAPS
A HYBRID CONTRACT WERE CERTAIN
COSTS ARE FIXED LIKE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. FOR
EXAMPLE WE MENTION THAT NO
REPORT. SO THERE ARE THINGS
THAT DEPARTMENT CAN DO AND
SHOULD DO ARE MOVING FORWARD SO
WE HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THAT.
IN THE FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS
IDENTIFYING THE FULL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING. THAT THE DEPARTMENT
NEEDS TO COMPLETE THE THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED HAS AYE SAID WE
ESTIMATE THEY NEED ANOTHER
TWENTY ONE MILLION. BUT ALSO
THEY NEED TO COME UP WITH AN
ESTIMATE FOR THOSE REMAINING
FORTY SIX HUNDRED PROPERTIES
BECAUSE AGAIN THOSE HAVE. A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION AS WELL. WE
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
SUBMIT A REQUEST FOR FUNDING.
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
SPRING BUDGET DISCUSSIONS- AND
IT NEEDS TO INCLUDE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY HIT OUR
ECONOMY SIGNIFICANTLY- SO THEY
NEED TO INCLUDE A RANGE OF
OPTIONS FOR. FUNDING FOR FULL
CLEAN P OR TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE THE PROPERTIES BASED
ON THE AMOUNT OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION. BASED ON THE
EXPOSURE- TO THAT THE RESIDENTS
OF THAT COMMUNITY. ALSO THERE
THERE NEED TO BE OPTIONS
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE ARE
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ARE GOING FORWARD.
I'M ALSO WE NEED WE RECOMMEND
THAT THEY REVISED THEIR COST
ESTIMATION METHODS TO ENCOMPASS
THOSE FACTORS LIKE I. DISCUSSED
YOU'VE GOT TO CONSIDER
INFLATION YOU'VE GOT TO
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT YOU YOU
HAVE TO PAY PREVAILING WAGES
ALL SORTS OF THINGS. AND THEN
AS I AS I RECENTLY INDICATED.
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY- PUT
TOGETHER CONTRACTS HOPEFULLY
GET SOME ADDITIONAL CONTRACTORS
TO ASSIST WITH THE CLEANUP.
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE CONTRACTS
ARE EITHER FIXED PRICE OR IF
NOT FIXED PRICE. OUR HYBRID
TYPE CONTRACT WHERE YOU HAVE
SOME COSTS THAT ARE FIXED LIKE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS- AND THEN
PERHAPS OTHER COSTS ARE NOT FIX
THEIR MORE VARIABLE. BUT AT
LEAST IT'S A WAY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO CONTROL THE
COSTS A LITTLE BIT MORE
EFFICIENTLY. OUR THAN WE HAVE
DONE THUS FAR. SO THOSE. ARE
HIGH LEVEL FINDINGS KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS I WILL OPEN IT
UP TO QUESTIONS BOB HARRIS IS
HERE MISTER HARRIS WAS THE
AUDIT MANAGER THE PROJECT
MANAGER ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT. A HE HAS THE DETAILS
AND HOPEFULLY. HE'LL BE ABLE TO
A SYSTEM I HAVE NO DOUBT AND
ANSWERING MANY OF THE QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HALF. SO WITH THAT
MISTER CHERYL TURN IT BACK TO
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU MATTER
MONITOR WE APPRECIATE THE
OVERVIEW AND LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK THERE I SHOULD-
INFORM EVERYONE TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT. WE DO HAVE- MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING WEARING MASKS I LIKE
TO THINK- NOT ONLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK. CHAIRMAN
YES YEP FOR BEING HERE BUT SOME
ARE MORE LOCK. SOMEONE MEMBER
SANTIAGO ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA
WHOSE PRESENCE. AND WE ALSO
HAVE PARTICIPATING- REMOTELY
MEMBERS FROM THE SENATE AND
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. IN A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- WITH THAT MADAM.
AUDITOR LET ME JUST MAKE SURE I
GOT MY NOTES RIGHT. SO THERE'S
SEVEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
PROPERTIES OF THE SEVEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
PROPERTIES THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED.
RIGHT IN A FIGHT AS MOST
CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES WHICH
THE LEGISLATURE SET ASIDE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
TO CLEAN UP BUT BY YOUR
ESTIMATES. THAT TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS WILL COME
UP SHORT- BY APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
GET TO THE LAST TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE PROPERTIES- BUT
OVERALL. YOUR ESTIMATES ALSO
THINK IN ORDER TO CLEAN UP THE
ENTIRE SEVEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED PROPERTIES WE NEED AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION MORE DOLLARS. TO
CLEAN UP THE REMAINING FORTY
SIX HUNDRED PROPERTIES OUTSIDE
OF THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED MOST
CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES. THAT'S
CORRECT I GET THAT RIGHT. YES
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. GOT IT. AND
THEN- AND YOU'VE IDENTIFIED A
DIFFERENT THINGS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- HAS THE DEPARTMENT
AND RECEPTIVE THUS FAR RIGHT
NOW WE START TO DO THE CHECK
INS BUT HAVE THEY BEEN
RECEPTIVE SO FAR OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OUTLINED IN
YOUR AUDIT REPORT. YES THEY
THEY THEY ABSOLUTELY. HAVE SAID
THAT THEY WILL IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK THE AS
I MENTIONED THERE WERE. CERTAIN
FACTORS- THAT THEY BELIEVE WERE
OUT OF THEIR CONTOL CERTAINLY
WHETHER OR THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS BUT- WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE WERE OTHER FACTORS. AND
THE EXPERTISE OF THE DEPARTMENT
WHERE THEY COULD HAVE DONE A
BETTER JOB OF COMING UP WITH
THEIR ESTIMATES. AGAIN BY
INCLUDING PREVAILING WAGE AND
INFLATION THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
BUT OVERALL. THE DEPARTMENT
AGREES WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND INTENDS TO UP FULLY
IMPLEMENT THEM. GREAT THANK YOU
BETTER WATER LET ME ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS HERE ON THE DYESS-
SENATOR MORE LOCK AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES- HELLO GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. I AM JUST CURIOUS IF
YOU COULD START FROM THE
BEGINNING A LITTLE BIT JUST TO
BUILD THE WHOLE CASE OF THE
CITY OF VERNON I HAVE ONLY HAS
THREE HUNDRED AND ONE RESIDENTS
AND- IT DOES NOT PROBABLY HAVE
THE FINANCIAL WHEREWITHAL TO.
REPAIR ALL THE HOMES AND
PROPERTIES IN THE VICINITY- I'M
JUST CURIOUS- ABOUT THE
PROCESS. THE LEGISLATURE MUST
HAVE SAID OKAY WE'LL TAKE CARE
OF IT BECAUSE VERNON CANNOT THE
NEIGHBORING CITIES CANNOT. AND
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
CANNOT SO THERE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE CARE OF
IT SO A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ONE
IS- SINCE THE STATE IS TAKING
ON THIS OBLIGATION HOW DOES IT
SOBRE GATOR GET REIMBURSED. AND
IF IT KIND OF FELL IN THE
STATE'S LAP. THEN WHAT ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR URGENCY AND
WHO'S PUSHING US AND HOW'S-
THIS GOING TO GET RESOLVED. AND
THEN I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
AFTER MAYBE THAT BIG BROAD
INTRODUCTION. SEARCHERS JR
COURT- MY NAME'S BOB HARRIS
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
AS THE STATE AUDITOR INDICATED
EARLIER I WAS THE PROJECT
MANAGER ON ASSIGNED IT SO LET
ME LET ME TRY AND- DO THAT
BACKING UPAND- EXPLAIN KIND OF
HOW WE GOT STARTED IN AND-
TAKING A STAB COMING UP THESE
PROPERTIES- SEVERAL ACCURATE
YOU'RE CORRECT THAT. THERE IS
THERE WAS THE EXPECTATION THAT
WHEN THE STATE BEGAN CLEAN UP
ACTIVITIES IN THE RESIDENTIAL
AREAS AROUND THE EXIT FACILITY.
THAT THERE WOULD BE
REIMBURSEMENT FROM EXCITED
ACTUALLY- WHILE IT WAS PURSUING
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES DGSE WAS
ALSO PURSUING ACTIONS AGAINST
EXIDE TO HOLD THEM RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE CONTAMINATION. AND
EVENTUALLY TO- GET FINANCIAL
COMPENSATION FOR THE CLEAN UP
RIGHT TO MAKE THEM FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE- THE STATE MADE IT
A PRIORITY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE RESIDENTIAL CLEAN. UP WHILE
THAT PROCESS WAS ON GOING. AND
DID APPRPRIATE AND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE DOLLAR. TO THAT AT.
NOW AS CHAIR INICATED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING THAT
HAS BEEN THROWN INTO- SOME
QUESTION NOW THAT EXACT HAS
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY THE
BANKRUPTCY COURT HAS APPROVED A
BANKRUPTCY SETTLEMENT THAT DOES
NOT. COMPENSATE CALIFORNIA FOR
THE CLEAN UP COSTS AND OF THE
STATE INTENDS ON APPEALING THAT
DECISION BUT OUR CONCLUSION IS
MOSTLY AFTER OUR AUDIT WAS
ALREADY OVER THAT THAT ALL THAT
HAPPENED BUT OUR CONCLUSION IS
THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS NOW ABOUT WHETHER THE
STATE WILL. SUCCESSFULLY RECOUP
ITS COSTS- FOR CLEANING UP
THESE RESIDENTIAL SITES. SO
THEN- WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE TAKING
ON THIS CASE VOLUNTARILY AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND SO THEN
WHERE DOES THE BUCK STOPS HOW
DOES THE LEGISLATURE. OTHER
THAN AT AN AUDIT OF THIS NATURE
HOW DOES THE LEGISLATOR
INSERTED ITSELF TO SAY HEY
DEPARTMENT. YOU KNOW STAY ON
SCHEDULE OR WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GET MORE
FUNDING. PUT OUT MORE BIDS. YOU
KNOW WHO WHAT WHY. WHY ARE WE
HERE WHO WHAT IS THE BUCK STOP
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR TELLING
HIS DEPARTMENT TO STAY ON TRACK
AND WHY DO WE HAVE TO GET
REPORTS LIKE THIS. M. AND M'S
HOW KNOWS I'VE ASKED THIS
BEFORE BUT IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW
EVERY TIME YOU GUYS PUT OUT A
REPORT YOU JUST WANT TO CRY IT.
HOW THE STATE'S BEING MANAGED
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS. THERE IT
IS IT IS WHAT'S A LEGISLATIVE
HEARING AND I DO TO HELP GET
THIS DONE. WELL CERTAINLY.
HEARINGS CAN HELP HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE DEPARTMENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR-
RESPECTIVE ACTIONS IN THIS CASE
THE CHASSIS AND THE CLEAN UP
EFFORT. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD EXPLORE
IS THAT WE DO NOW DTS IS IN
NEED OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO
COMPLETE THE CLEANUP EFFORT.
THAT FUNDING DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
ALL IN ONE FELL SWOOP AND THEN
FIND OUT A COUPLE YEARS FROM
NOW THAT IT STILL WASN'T
ENOUGH- WE RECOMMEND THAT. DGSE
PRESENT THE LEGISLATURE WITH A
DIFFERENT A RANGE OF OPTIONS
FOR WHAT FUTURE FUNDING COULD
LOOK LIKE ONE OF THOSE OPTIONS
FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S
PERSPECTIVE COULD BE A SHORTER
TIME FRAME NOT NOT TO SAY THAT.
LEGISLATORS RENEGING ON ITS
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN THESE
PROPERTIES BUT JUST TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THE DEPARTMENT
THAT'S MANAGING THE CLEAN UP
EFFORT THERE THE- THE LENGTH OF
TIME THE FUNDING IS EXPECTED TO
LAST FOR WOULD BE A SHORTER
AMOUNT OF TIME PERHAPS ONLY. AN
ADDITIONAL FISCAL YEAR PASSED
WITH THEIR CURRENT
APPROPRIATION- CARRIED OUT THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO-
HAVE MORE FREQUENT
CONVERSATIONS WITH DGSE ABOUT
HOW THE CLEAN UP EFFORT IS
GOING. WHAT'S BEING DONE WITH
THAT FUNDING AND WHETHER
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS NECESSARY
AND WHY IF ANY NEW CONDITIONS
OF INTRODUCED THEMSELVES. THAT
MAKES THE COST ESTIMATES THAT
WERE ORIGINALLY PRESENTED NO
LONGER VIABLE SO- THAT IS ONE
POTENTIAL OVERSIGHT MECHANISM
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AT ITS
DISPOSAL. IN THIS HOUSE
MENTIONED- TO CRITIC ACT COULD
YOU REPEAT THE TITLE OF THAT.
SURE AT THE TIME CRITICAL
REMOVAL ACTION INTEGRA- WHICH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN SPEAK
PROBABLY MORE ELOQUENTLY TO THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF WHY BUT IS
AN EXPEDITED- CLEAN UP EFFORT-
THAT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT TO
TREAT EACH EYE SIGHT AS AN
INDIVIDUAL PROJECT- AND
STREAMLINE SOME OF THE EFFORTS
TO CLEAN THOSE- RESIDENTIAL
SITES. CONTROL JUST INTERRUPT
WHAT SECRETARY DOES THIS
DEPARTMENT REPORT TO. I DON'T
RECALL OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
I APOLOGIZE I DON'T RECALL.
OKAY AND THEN THAT SECRETARY
REPORTS OF THE GOVERNOR. OKAY
IT'S- THE SECRETARY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION. THANK
YOU CALIFIA AND YES THAT WOULD
BE A DIRECT REPORT TO THE
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU MR HURST
THANK YOU MISTER RIGHT THANK
CENTER MORLOCK- LET ME JUST
REMIND MEMBERS WE NEED TO BE
OUT OF THE ROOM BY TWELVE
THIRTY I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE PERMIT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL WITH
THAT LET'S MOVE TO. SOME MEMBER
SANTIAGO. I. I APPRECIATE THAT
MR JOURNAL BE AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE GIVEN THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS- I MEAN THERE'S A
DEEP LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION IS AS
YOU KNOW WHEN WE REQUESTED THE
AUDIT- AND I PURCHASED IT THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ACTUALLY
TAKING IT UP AND MAKE A STRONG
CASE FOR IT TO HAPPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- IS MORE LIKE
AN OTHERS WHO SUPPORTED ON THE
COMMITTEE- BUT THERE'S A
THERE'S A- I WANT ANSWER QUICK
QUESTION THAT YOU HAD ASKED
ABOUT YOUR WORLD COULD BE RE.
RE- A RECOUP THE DOLLARS AND-
WHAT WHEN THE DOLLARS ARE FIRST
SET UP- BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THERE WAS ALSO- IN
THEIR LANGUAGE. THAT ROUTE THA
SAID THAT WE WOULD GO AFTER ALL
RESPONSIBLE PARTY SO THAT'S
JUST A- PUT A PIN ON THAT. THAT
THERE ARE BUT MAYBE OR MAYBE
OTHER RESPONSIBLE PARTIES TO
CONTAMINATION- THAT WE WOULD
SEEK A REFUND FROM NOT JUST IN
ADDITION TO EXCITE. EXCITE HAS
ITS OWN UNIQUE. SITUATION GOING
THROUGH A BANKRUPTCY COURT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT MAY
LIMIT OUR ABILITY BUT CERTAINLY
WE HAVE EVERY LEGAL TOOL
POSSIBLE- TO CONTINUE. FIGHTING
EXCITED HOLDING THOSE
ACCOUNTABLE POLLUTER
COMMUNITIES. BUT BUT HAVING
SAID THAT- YEAH WE'VE NOW SEEN
PROBLEMS WITH THE T. S. C. R.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND I
THINK IT IN NON. BUT I THINK.
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE WOULD
THAT WE SHOULD BE ASKING IS
WHAT. WHAT ADDITIONAL AUDITS
WOULD WE NOT ASK- I THINK THE
HEARING DOES CITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE BECAUSE
NOW WE KNOW IN WRITING FOR THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE. WHAT
WE'VE WHAT WE'VE- ALLEGED IN
THE PAST OF DTS YOU WORKING TOO
SLOW TO CLEAN UP THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD- AND WE HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE CAN WE
CAN IMPLEMENT. BUT BUT YOU KNOW
THE QUESTION HAS TO ARISE-
BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT THAT WE'VE KNOWN THE TAX
YES HE HAS KIND OF DRAGGED ITS
FEET ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE HAVING AN INTERN
PERMIT BAKER FOR OVER THIRTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE YEARS- BEFORE
BEFORE IT WAS SHUT DOWN- IS A
BIG PROBLEM. SO THE QUESTION
HAS TO RISER IN INCOMPETENCE IN
THE AGENCY- YOU HAVE TO ASK
THAT RATED THAT THAT YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED THIS MAY
BE A QUESTION THAT THE AUDITOR
MAIL PINE ON- IS HERE WITH
THEIR NEGLIGENCE- OR IS A
CULTURAL- BECAUSE IF I'VE BEEN
IN THE LEGISLATURE- ALL RIGHT
WHEN I WAS GETTING THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE GONE OUT TO
THREE. EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS. I
DO BUT CERTAINLY WE CAN MAKE A
LIST OF THOSE BEFORE I CAME TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND WE'VE SEEN
THE SAME PROBLEMS TO PERSIST.
OVER AND OVER. FOR SOME POINT
TIME WE'VE GOT TO ASK IS IT. IS
IT COMPETENCE- IS A CULTURAL.
OR NEGLIGENCE CAN WE POINT THE
FINGER TO. THE TIME TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE OF IT. I
DON'T WANT TO BE HERE SIX
MONTHS FROM NOW A YEAR FROM NOW
I CONTINUE IN THAT THE ASSETS
IN QUESTION NOT GRANTED I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. ALSO IT'S NOT FAIR TO
LAY- ALL THOSE QUESTIONS-
BEFORE THAT PERSON BUT WE MIGHT.
BUT DO YOU HAVE A HINT- WHAT
THAT WHAT WHAT YOU WOULD POINT
THAT IF YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK IF
YOU ARE ANSWERING THE QUESTION.
SO CERTAINLY WE WERE REGIONAL.
COMPETENCY OR OR- INTEGRITY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MANAGING THE
PROJECT AND WHATEVER THEY WERE
DOING SO IN GOOD FAITH- OR WITH
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF EXPERTISE-
WE'RE POINTING TO CRITICAL
DEFICIENCIES IN THE PLANNING OF
THE PROJECT AND THEN THE
MONITORING OF THE PROJECT THE
PLANNING WITH RESPECT TO THE
COST ESTIMATES AND EXPECT. HOW
FAST THE CLEANUP WOULD PROGRESS
AND THEN THE MONITORING TO
ENSURE THAT THINGS WERE
ACTUALLY GOING AT THAT COST AND
GOING AT THAT SPEED OF CLEAN UP
SO THOSE THOSE PROJECT
MANAGEMENT- AREAS IF THE
DEPARTMENT PAYS ATTENTION TO
THOSE NOW- STAYS ON TOP OF
DEVELOPING A SOUND COST
ESTIMATE MAKING SURE THAT IT
HAS SUFFICIENT CONTRACTED STAFF
IN THE FIELD TO CONDUCT CLEAN
UP ACTIVITIES AT THE RIGHT PACE
AT THE EXPECTED PACE. THEN THIS
PROJECT WILL PROGRESS- OR IN
LINE WITH EXPECTATIONS IN THE
FUTURE THAN IT HAS UP TO THIS
POINT MISTER CHAIRMAN PHILIP.
PLACEMENT SANTIAGO FOR. AND I
WAS IN MEANING TOWARDS A PERSON
COULD BE UNFAIR FOR ME TO ASK
IF THERE WAS A PERSON WHO YOU
THOUGHT ANY OF THOSE THREE.
ATTRIBUTES AND CAROLINE WITH I
WAS MORE MENTIONING AS AN
AGENCY- BECAUSE IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO UNDERSTAND- BUT I LOOK AT
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITY I'M NOT
THE ONLY ONE I DON'T KNOW- MY
COLLEAGUE ALSO REPRESENT TO
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES ALSO
IMPACTED- BUT WE'VE GOT TO ASK
THE QUESTION BECAUSE WE WANT
OUR- BECAUSE- WE HAVE. WE SET
SOME MONEY ASIDE. WE WANT TO
CLEAN UP. AND IT'S NOT AN
ACADEMIC EXERCISE HERE YOU'LL
PEOPLE'S HEALTH ARE AT RISK.
PEOPLE COULD DIE. IT IS
ABSOLUTELY SERIOUS AND. WE
SHOULD- IS ALARMING. THE STATE
TO SETTLE THE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT NOW WITH THAT THAT THAT
THIS DEPARTMENT NOT FUMBLED THE
CLEAN UP OF THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
AND HAVE NOT TAKEN BASIC
UNDERSTANDINGS YOU'VE YOU'VE
GOT ASK A QUESTION. YOU'VE GOT
TO ASK THE QUESTION IS IT CAN.
WHAT WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO GET
THE DEPARTMENT TO DO THIS
BESIDES AGREED TO SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS COULD WE CAN'T
SIT HERE SIX MONTHS FROM NOW OR
A YEAR FROM NOW WILL THE SAME
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER. AND I
REALIZE YOU'RE NOT THE HEAD OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE QUESTION
MAY BE UNFAIR BUT BUT I'D LIKE
TO HEAR AN OPINION FROM YOU OR
THE STATE AUDITOR. RIGHT AGAIN
AND- WE MAKE NO CONCLUSIONS
ABOUT. THE CULTURE OF THE
DEPARTMENT BEING THE CAUSE FOR
THAT THE CLEANUP EFFORTS TO
FISH THAT WE OBSERVED I
CERTAINLY. IN A SYMPATHIZER
STAND WHY- WE DON'T WANT TO BE
ASKING THE SAME SET OF
QUESTIONS A YEAR FROM NOW TWO
YEARS FROM NOW. ABOUT THE SAME
KINDS OF PROBLEMS AGAIN. TO THE
PREVIOUS QUESTION ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW TO HOLD
THE DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTABLE I
THINK. I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
IS WELL POSITIONED TO DO SO
THAT THERE IS NOT ANOTHER LONG
PERIOD OF TIME ANOTHER LONG
STRETCH OF TIME DURING WHICH
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES ARE NOT
PROGRESSING. THE WAY THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO CERTAINLY THE
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
REGULAR FREQUENT CHECK INS WE
WILL ALSO BE FOLLOWING UP-
THROUGH OUR REGULAR PROCESS ON.
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE'VE MADE AND SHARING THAT
INFORMATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE PUBLIC- AS
TO WHETHER THIS CORRECTIVE
ACTION IN FACT OCCURRING. THE
FIRST ONE WILL BE DO- IN ABOUT
A MONTH. GREAT THANK YOU AND
THAT SUMMER SANTIAGO I KNOW A
LOT OF US HERE'S YOUR
FRUSTRATIONS ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE SET ASIDE
FUNDING ALREADY TO CLEAN UP THE
SITES OF THE HERE THAT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN PRIORITIZE FOR
CLEAN UP. BUT THAT'S I THINK
THE VALUE OF HAVING THESE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND THEN
THAT THROUGH PROGRESS INTO THE
NEXT YEAR ARE BUDGET SUB
HEARINGS WITH THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL. WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLY IT WILL
THEN- GARCIA. THANK YOU HAVE A
TO A QUICK QUESTION. THE ESTá.
BECAUSE RIPPING UP IN. THE
THIRTY ONE. I HAVE. CITED CHRIS.
PARKS AND- I. IN THE AUDIT OR
IS THAT. IN ADDITION COST. THEY
ARE INCLUDED. THANK YOU THAT'S
ALL. THANK YOU SO MOVEMENT
GARCIA WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR REMOTE
SITES AND AT A REMOTE SITE A NO
SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ HAS A
QUESTION AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN I REBEKAH MAYOR
QUE HAN SO IF WE CAN MOVE TO A
REMOTE SITE WITH SENATOR
GONZALEZ PLEASE. THANK YOU SURE
SALAS THANK YOU. GERMAN COURT
AS WELL HAVING- COMMITTEE
HEARING VERY IMPORTANT DON'T
MANY OF OUR WHICH CONSTITUENTS
FASCISM. GARCIA AND- SENATOR
GRASSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER. US ON.
YASSER TOOK ITS TO FIND EVENT
VERY. SO I'M JUST GLAD WERE
ADDING ATTENTION IN THE TOWN OF
HERE- THE- I HAVE IS ON- PAGE
TWO OF THE ORDER. JUST QUICK I
KNOW WE HAVE LOT FOR DTS. ASIDE
FROM THIS I DON'T THE STATE
AUDITOR OR OF DUE TO YOU CAN.
BUT IT'S STATES HERE THAT THE
TNC BELIEVES IT HAS PROP MORE.
THANK KALRA. YOU KNOW WATCH.
WHAT ARE THOSE COME. YOU KNOW
FRAUD THAT DTS BELIEVE. IT IS
THAT SAME PACE ACT. SO A LOT OF.
SHARE MORE. BUT IT SURE WITH US
FOR- TOWARDS END OF OUR PRIDE.
A COMPARISON TO OF OUT OR FOUR
OTHER CLEAN UP- THE- YEAH.
THERE WAS ONE OF THE IT WAS MY
SICK. AND SO THE WERE. ARGUABLY
QUITE AS- WITH RICK TO SIGN-
AND DATA IT SURE WITH US WHICH
IT WE DID NOT HAVE AN- TO
VALLEY- SO WE'RE NOT STANDING
BEHIND IT BUT IT DID PURPORT TO
SHOW THAT THE TSC IN THE
EARLIER YEARS OF THE CLEAN UP
PROJECT. THIS PARTICULAR EXACT
CLEANUP PROJECT HAS PROGRESSED
FASTER THAN THOSE OTHER CLEANUP
PROJECTS HAD- AGAIN. WE'RE
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO VALIDATE THAT
THAT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WE
LOOK LOOK AT DURING THE AUDIT
AND IT WAS PRESENTED TO US
RELATIVELY LATE. I WOULD LIKE
TO DEPART SPEAKING SO. TO THAT
QUESTION. MISTER CHAIRMAN HAVE
JUST ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP AS
WELL I THINK WE'LL LEAVE THIS
TO THE NEXT BUT I JUST WANT TO
BE SURE THAT THE SAME SENTENCE
THAT MENTIONS- DIDN'T IN. AS
WELL BACK THAT SLOW ITS RATE
PROGRESS SO JUST TO BE
MESSAGING SEEMS TO BE. GROWING
IT FEELS THAT SEEMS LIKE DGSE
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS ALL PART IT
ALSO INTO OF. CAUSES AN ISSUE
THAT HAVE SLOWED DWN- HAVE YOU
CAN LEAVE BUT THIS PART OF THE
IS ONE OF THE- THANK YOU. TO UP
I'LL LET THE AGAIN SPEAK THAT
AT MORE SPECIFIC I KNOW THAT
THEY FOR. CERTAIN CERTAIN
FACTOR WERE- COULD NOT BE
ANTICIPATED THAT AFFECTED THE
OF CLAY UP- FOR OUR FIRST.
THOSE FACTORS SUCH AS WHETHER
OR A SCHEDULING DIFFICULTIES
THAT THEY MAY HAVE HAD WITH-
THE OWNERS OF THOSE PROPERTIES
THOSE WERE WELL NOT IN THE- AT
THE MICRO LEVEL AT THE SITE BY
SITE LEVEL ANTICIPATED- KEEP
COULD BE ANTICIPATED. GENERAL
FACTORS THAT SHOULD GENERALLY
AFFECT THE OVERALL PACE AT
WHICH YOU CAN PROGRESS WHICH
SHOULD BE KNOWABLE IN ADVANCE
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT WEATHER
AND SCHEDULING DIFFICULTIES OR
THE TYPE OF TERRAIN THAT YOU
MIGHT ENCOUNTER AT A SITE.
AGAIN YOU MAY NOT KNOW FOR A
PARTICULAR SITE HOW MANY TREES
ARE PLANTED ON THAT PIECE OF
pYOU THEN HAVE TO WHAT WHICH
MIGHT SLOW YOU DOWN BUT YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO NOW. FROM A
GENERALIZED PERSPECTIVE. THAT
THERE ARE FACTORS WHICH WILL
AFFECT THE OVERALL PACE SO THEY
DON'T AMOUNT TO US. TO BE
REASONABLE EXPLANATIONS FOR
WHY. BERMAN COULD NOT MEET IT'S
EXPECTED PACE OF CLEAN UP
BECAUSE THOSE THINGS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FACTORED IN AT THE
BEGINNING WHEN THE ESTIMATE WAS
CREATED. RIGHT ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANKS FOR THAT ANSWER AND
I BELIEVE THAT WAS A CENTER
GONZALO'S LAST QUESTION WHAT
THAT WAS GOING TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REBEKAH BEAR QUE%
HAN AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO
CENTER DRAWS- IS JOINING US.
THERE ARE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. THAT MISS BAKER THEY
ARE QUE HAND PLACE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THIS
HEARING IS OBVIOUSLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK WE'VE COVERED
ALREADY. I HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE PAYING A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO THE COST OVER
RUNS THE LENGTH OF TIME THIS IS
TAKE AND MORE- BUT I WANT TO
TOUCH ON SOMETHING THAT I WAS
HOW OLD WAIT OUT. WHICH I THINK
I WANT MORE CLARIFICATION ON
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THE
IMPACT ON CHILDREN OF THIS
CONTAMINATION IS SIGNIFICANT.
AND I WANT UNDERSTANDS MORE
FROM YOU MISTER HARRIS HOW THEY
POSSIBLY COULD HAVE MISSED
THOSE THIRTY ONE CHILD CARE
CENTRE PARKS AND SCHOOL SITES
WHERE WE KNOW CHILDREN ARE
GONNA BE EXPOSED EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY IT SEEMS LIKE A
HUGE OVERSIGHT AND SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING OUT
AND- ASKING REALLY. GOOD
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THAT COULD
HAPPEN AND HOW WE STOP THAT
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE AS
WE MUST BE PROTECTING THOSE
CHILDREN FOR THIS
CONTAMINATION. EVERYTHING. IS
GOING TO. HE WANTS THE- YOU
KNOW THE AMERICAN. STRONG I
THINK EUROPEAN. SO SIR THAT ONE
OF THE THAT WE DID ONCE WE HAD
THAT THESE PROPERTIES HAD BEEN
CLEANED YET THIS FIGURE OUT TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHY IT TOOK FROM
THE DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE I
THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE OF KEY
FACTORS THAT AFFECTED THIS ONE
IS THE IDENTIFICATION OF SOME
OF THESE PROPERTIES AS
PUBLICLY. OWNED NOW THAT THAT
IS TRUE FOR SOME OF THEM BUT
NOT TRUE FOR ALL OF THE
PROPERTIES THAT THE DEPARTMENT-
INITIALLY BELIEVED SO BAD
INITIALLY OVER IDENTIFIED THE
NUMBER THAT WERE PUBLICLY
OWNED. THE REASON THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN PUBLICLY ON
A PRIVATELY OWNED IS. IF IT'S A
PUBLICLY OWNED PROPERTY IT
COULD CONSTITUTE A PUBLIC WORK
UNDER STATE LAW. WHICH MEANS
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS
CONTRACTORS WOULD NEED TO BE
BONDED AT A CERTAIN LEVEL AND
IN A CERTAIN WAY. IN THE
DEPARTMENT HAS EXPRESSED TO US
THAT IT HAD DIFFICULTY. FINDING
CONTRACTORS WHO WERE ABLE TO
SATISFY THOSE REQUIREMENTS-
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY IMPACT
DELAY THEIR PROGRESS ON
CLEANING THOSE PROPERTIES. THAT
BEING SAID AS I MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO THEY HAD
MISIDENTIFIED AS SOME OF THESE
PROPERTIES AS PUBLICLY ON WHEN
IN FACT THEY WERE PRIVATELY
OWNED- AND- THEY IDENTIFIED.
TWENTY FOUR OF THE CHILD CARE
CENTERS WERE ACTUALLY PRIVATE
RESIDENTIAL CHILDCARE CENTERS
WHEN THEY HAD PREVIOUSLY
BELIEVED THEY WERE PUBLICLY
OWNED AND I'VE SENT TO SIGN
THOSE TO. ONE OF THEIR
CONTRACTORS TO CLEAN. BUT IT SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FACTORS AND WHY
THERE WAS A DELAY IN CLEANING
THESE PROPERTIES CERTAINLY THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. HIGH PRIORITY-
TO CLEAN WHICH IS WHY WE POINT
OUT THAT THERE WERE OTHER
PROCESSES THE DEPARTMENT COULD
YOU SUCH AS THE TECH WRECK TO
EXPEDITE THE CLEAN UP OF THOSE
PROPERTIES. ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP
SO ARE THEY DO WE KNOW IF THE
DEPARTMENT AYE WE CAST
APARTMENT THIS I GUESS IS IN
THE PROCESS OF USING TO GRANT
TO GET THOSE FACILITIES CLEANED
UP AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. SO
EXPRESSED TO. US ABOUT IT THAT
THEY ARE NOW MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT AND I'LL LET THEM
KIND OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER HARRIS. THANK YOU WOMAN
WITH THAT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
SENATOR TO RAZA. THANK YOU. CAN
YOU SEE ME OR MY. NO BUT- I CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
WAIT A MINUTE. THAT HELP OKAY.
THANK YOU I DON'T WANT DENTURES
US SALAS AND WORK AND THE
COMMUNITY AND EVERYBODY WHO'S
PARTICIPATING PUTTING THIS-
THIS HEARING TOGETHER I JUST
GOT ELECTED TO THE AREA WHERE
THE IMPACT IS BEING FELT ON THE
RESIDENTIAL AREA SO I WONDER
YEAH I THINK THE EFFORT THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GARCIA AND SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS- EASY ROWING OF JUST
PUSHING AND PUSHING AND
PUSHING. WHAT I AM AMAZED THAT
IS THAT THESE ISSUES WHAT THIS
DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN GOING ON
FOR DECADES. AND I KNOW TODAY
WERE TRYING TO DO A SLICE OUT A
PIECE OF HOW THEY HANDLED THE
EXIDE. CLEANUP IN ALL THE
ISSUES THERE BUT THIS IS A
DEPARTMENT THAT. THAT THIS IS
THEIR EXPERTISE. THIS IS WHAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN HANDLING
FOR DECADES AND NOW- WE'RE
FINDING THROUGH YOUR AUDIT THAT
THINGS AS SIMPLE AS HAVING ONLY
ONE CONTRACTOR INSTEAD OF
HIRING SEVERAL. THAT THAT THEN
IMPACTS THE TIMING OF IT JUST
SEEMS OUTRAGEOUS YEAH IT'S MIND
BOGGLING UP BECAUSE THEY'RE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THESE IN THIS COMMUNITY OF
COLOR. THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED WITH HEALTH ISSUES
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THIS AUDIT OUGHT
TO. AT THE SAME TIME THAT YOU
IDENTIFY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE VERY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT TO DO
AND HOW TO MOVE FORWARD WE HAVE
TO PUT THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF
HOW MASSIVE. THE MPACT AND THE
DAMAGE AND THE SUFFERING ON
THESE COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN
INCLUDING THE MOST RECENT
CLEANUP OR LACK OF CLEAN UP
WORK SLOW CLEANUP OF EXCITED
SO. I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE
GET THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS WE ALSO GIVE
THE PUBLIC AN UNDERSTANDING. OF
THE DEVASTATION THAT THIS IS
CAUSING CONTINUES TO CAUSE AS
PART OF THE AUDIT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE IT APPEARS TO BE.
THESE WERE STEPS THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN TAKEN. THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN TAKEN AND NOW WE HAVE A
PROMISE TO TAKE THEM. AND
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH I DON'T
MEAN THAT'S NOT A GOOD ENOUGH
FOR THE AUDIT BUT IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH. FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HEAR IT IN THOSE
TERMS. AND I AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO THAT
WE HAVE TO HAVE A MUCH DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF EVERYTHING
THAT IS WRONG WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT. THAT HAS LED TO
THIS DAMAGE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND I THINK THAT WE- WE DO A
DISSERVICE WHEN WE LEAVE THAT
OUT OF THE STORY AND THE
NEGATIVE. AND THE NARRATIVE AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS SO- YOU
KNOW I'VE THAT MAY SOUND A
LITTLE BIT DRAMATIC TO SOME
PEOPLE BUT- I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE GET WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
AND NOTE FOR US TO GET THE
RESURFACES JERRY I MEAN LOOK AT
THIS THE FEDERAL. YOU KNOW TO
ALLOW THIS COMPANY TO WALK AWAY
WITH NO REPERCUSSIONS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO FIGHT
BACK AS CALIFORNIANS I WANT TO
THANK THE AUDITORS FOR ALL YOUR
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAW A I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION BECAUSE
EVERY PROPERTY THAT IS NOT
CLEANED UP AT THE FAMILY- THAT
ARE BEING IMPACTED AND WE'VE
ALL SEEN THE MEDIA ACCOUNTS IN
THE ACCOUNTS OF. THE FAMILIES
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED WITH
CANCER- BECAUSE OF THE
POLLUTION AT THE SITE AND THE
AGREEMENTS MADE WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE LEVEL FOR EXCITEMENT
AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
WE NEED TO. PRIORITIZE THOSE
FAMILIES AS PROPERTIES AND TO
DO ALL WE CAN TO. MITIGATE THE
SITUATION WITH THAT HEARING
NUMBER QUESTIONS ON THE FIRST
PANEL WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS COMMENTS IN
RESPONSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL- WITH
US WE HAVE- MEREDITH WILLIAMS
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR. OF DGSE.
FRANCISCA NEGRA- CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. GRANT COPE WITH
DEBBIE DIRECTOR- IN IF WE COULD
JUST START WITH MISS WILLIAMS
PLACE. I BELIEVE THE DIRECTOR
IS JOINING US VIA THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOMS OF THE
SWITCH BACK OVER TO THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM PLACE.
THE MORNING ARE YOU READY FOR
ME. PLEASE PROCEED. WARNING MY
NAME IS MEREDITH WILLIAMS AND I
AM THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT OUR WORK ON THE
OUTSIDE RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
AUDITOR AND HER STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK WITH US. WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FOR A LONG TIME FROM
RESIDENTS ABOUT HOW THIS. THIS
PROJECT IMPACTS THEIR DAILY
LIVES AND THEIR HEALTH. AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO THEM. THAT
THE PROJECT GET DONE AND GET
DONE RIGHT. THEY HAVE VERY
MOVING STORIES AND THAT GIVES
US A SENSE OF URGENCY ABOUT
THIS WORK. THIS IS THE LARGEST
MOST COMPLEX MOST LOGISTICALLY
COMPLEX CLEAN UP OF ITS KIND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
IT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST CLEAN
UPS OF THIS TYPE IN THE NATION.
WE LEARNED A GREAT DEAL AS
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THE CLEAN UP.
AND IT'S NOT BUT THAT'S NO
COMFORT TO THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING THE FACILITY THAT
HAVE HAD TO LOOK. WILL LIVE
WITH THE CONTAMINATION WELL WE
LEARNED AS WE WENT. AND WE HAVE
LEARNED A GREAT DEAL AND WHAT
WE LEARNED IS EVIDENT IN THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE IN SPITE OF
OUR CHALLENGES. WE'VE COMPLETED
CLEANUP OF TWO THOUSAND NINETY
SIX RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES WITH
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD.
THIS AUDIT GIVES US ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN. IT SHINES
A LIGHT ON WHAT WE CAN IMPROVE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I WILL
BRIEFLY DISCUSS. THE SPECIFIC
RESPONSES TO THE ORDERS
RECOMMENDATIONS SOME OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE PUT IN PLACE
WITH CURRENT RESOURCES. TO
PROTECT AGAINST SIMILAR
SITUATIONS IN THE FUTURE AND
WHAT WE MIGHT LEARN TO
STRENGTHEN THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE WAKE OF EXCISE. WITH
RESPECT TO THE ORDERS
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT CHILD
CARE SCHOOLS DATE AND PART DAY
CARE CENTERS. WE HAVE TAKEN
IMMEDIATE ACTIONS TO CONTINUE
CLEAN UP AT THIS FACILITY. I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY ONE POINT WITH
RESPECT TO THE TIME CRITICAL
REMOVAL ACTIONS ARE TECH CROSS.
THE DEPARTMENT DID DO SOME
INITIAL WORK RELATED TO TAKE
ROSE TO REMOVE THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF LEAD AT THESE
FACILITIES AND PUT BARRIERS IN
PLACE TO PROTECT PEOPLE TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM EXPOSURE.
THAT SAID WE KNOW THERE ARE
THERE WERE FIFTY FIVE DAY CARES
THAT HAVE BEEN SAMPLED. TWENTY
ONE OF THOSE HAVE BEEN CLEANED.
AND ELEVEN DO NOT REQUIRE ANY
CLEAN UP OR ARE NO LONGER
OPERATING IS DAY CARE
FACILITIES. THERE ARE TWENTY
THREE DAY CARE FACILITIES THAT
DO REMAIN TO BE CLEANED. DGSE
HAS SAMPLED EACH OF THEM AND
FOURTEEN ARE SCHEDULED TO BE
CLEAN UP BY TWO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IT'S A VERY DYNAMIC
SITUATION I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
ACTUALLY ARE ALL CLOSE TO
SCHEDULING ANOTHER TWO OR THREE
PROPERTIES- EVEN THIS WEEK.
UNFORTUNATELY THREE OF THE DAY
CARE FACILITIES HAVE DECLINED
TO CLEAN UP. AND IT IS OUR
INTENT TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS AND
TO PURSUE ORDERS OR WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE TO CLEAN
UP- THOSE PROPERTIES. I WILL
SAY THAT THE DAY CARE
FACILITIES OPENING CLOSE
REGULARLY AND FIVE DAY CARE
CENTERS RECENTLY OPENED AND
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD TO GET
THESE PROPERTIES IN OUR QUEUE.
OUR CLEAN UP OF THE THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
WITH THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD
WAS THE SUBJECT OF THE ORDERS
SECOND RECOMMENDATION. OF
COURSE THE DEPARTMENT IS
COMMITTED TO CLEANING UP THESE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PARCELS THAT
POSE THE GREATEST RISK. OF
EXPOSURE AS QUICKLY AND AS COST
EFFICIENTLY AS WE CAN. WE ARE
WORKING TO CLEAN UP THESE
PROPERTIES WITH THE SCHEDULE AS
AGGRESSIVE AS COVERT ALLOWS. WE
RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY OF THIS
PROJECT WE'RE ON PACE TO
COMPLETE MORE THAN 90% OF THE
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED CLEAN UPS
AND WE'RE PROUD OF THE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE. OVER DE TNCS FIRST SIX
YEARS WE ARE VERGE TWENTY ONE
PROPERTIES PER MONTH. AND I
WILL COMPARE THAT TO THE CLEAN
UP THAT THE ORDER REFERENCED
THAT MISTER HARRIS REFERENCE
THAT CLEAN UP WAS IN OMAHA
NEBRASKA IT TOOK I BELIEVE IT
TOOK SEVENTEEN YEARS. IN THE
FIRST SIX YEARS OF THAT CLEANUP
THEY AVERAGED ABOUT NINE
PROPERTIES MONTHS WE'RE MUCH
CLOSER TO TWENTY ONE PROPERTIES
A MONTH. SO AND EVEN BY THE END
OF LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO
CLEAN UP NINETY PROPERTIES A
MONTH WEATHER PERMITTING AND
EVEN IN COOKING UNDER COVERT
CONDITIONS WE'RE GETTING CLOSE
TO SEVENTY PROPERTIES A MONTH.
WHEN THINGS LINE UP. THERE ARE
SEVERAL BARRIERS THAT MAY STAND
IN THE WAY OF US ATTAINING OUR
GOAL. BUT SCHEDULING PROPERTIES
IS ONE OF THE GREATEST LIMITING
FACTORS. COBIT HAS MADE
RESIDENTS VERY RELUCTANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN. IT IS A PAIN IN
THE CLEAN UP PROCESS. SO WE'VE
INCREASED OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS
TO ENSURE THAT WE DO HAVE A
HIGH ENOUGH FOR A NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES IN THE QUEUE AT ALL
TIMES. TO CONTINUE THE UP THE
GAME THOSE EFFICIENCIES AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE CLEAN UP IS
CONTINUOUS. THE CURRENT
APPROPRIATION WILL NOT AS THE
AUDITOR POINTED OUT BEACH
SUFFICIENT TO CLEAN THE FULL
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED PARCELS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. TO SECURE THE
FUNDING NEEDED FOR THIS
CRITICAL WORK. THE EXACT NUMBER
OF PARCELS THEY CAN BE CLEANED
UP WITH OUR CURRENT
APPROPRIATION WILL DEPEND ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING.
SIZE AND CONFIGURATION OF THE
PROPERTY COVERT NINETEEN AND
OTHER LIMITATIONS THAT- WE ARE
HARD TO PREDICT IN IN ADVANCE.
WE ARE SEEING ARE ALSO SEEING
INCREASED IMPACTS FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE WE HAVE EXCESSIVE HEAT
DAYS TO CONSIDER. WE'RE NOW
EXPERIENCING DAYS WHERE WE HAVE
TO SEND OUR CREWS HOME BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING EXPOSED TO
WILDFIRE SMOKE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT PART OF
THE PROCESS REALLY ON. AND OF
COURSE RAIN TO GET REMAINS
UNPREDICTABLE. THE TOPICS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THREE AND FOUR
ARE PLANNING AND FUNDING OF
ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES BEYOND
THOSE FOR WHICH WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FUNDS. IT HAD ALWAYS BEEN
OUR INTENT TO HOLD EXCITED
COUNTABLE FOR THIS CLEAN UP BUT
WITH THEIR MOST RECENT
BANKRUPTCY WE ARE REGROUPING.
WE ALWAYS HAVE WE ALWAYS HAVE
BEEN AND REMAIN COMMITTED TO
THIS CLEAN UP. FROM THE INITIAL
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S INJECTION OF AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT. UPON TAKING
OFFICE. UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A
TIME OF GREAT A GREAT DEAL OF
UNCERTAINTY. IF THE PAN GIVEN
THE PANDEMIC SO WE CAN'T BE
SURE WHERE THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL SITUATION WILL BE. AS
WE MOVE INTO THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. AND OF COURSE A NEW
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ADDS
ADDITIONAL UNCERTAINTY. SO WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES WILL
IMPACT OUR ROADS OUR STATE SO
CALIFORNIA'S FISCAL STATUS IS
QUITE UNCERTAIN AND AS A RESULT
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO COMMIT TO
SPECIFICS OF A PROPOSAL RIGHT
NOW. FOR NEXT SPRING. YOUR LAST
RECOMMENDATION WAS THAT WE
INCORPORATE FIXED PRICE
ELEMENTS IN ANY FUTURE CLEAN UP
CONTRACTS. AS I NOTED THE
DEPARTMENT ANIL CONTRACTORS
HAVE LEARNED A LOT OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS PROJECT
UNPRECEDENTED CLEANUP. THE
NATURE OF THE CONTRACTS IS THAT
THERE ARE IS A LOT OF RISK AND
UNCERTAINTY AND BECAUSE OF THIS
IT WAS EVEN CHALLENGING TO GET
MULTIPLE CONTRACTORS TO BID ON
THIS PROJECT. BUT EACH PROPERTY
IS UNIQUE WITH SIZE AND
CONFIGURATION AND- SOMETIMES WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW ME- THE
SPECIFICS UNTIL WE BEGIN
WORKING FOR INSTANCE ON
COVERAGE OF BURIED UTILITY
LINES. WE ARE LEARNING FROM
THESE AND WE ARE BETTER ABLE TO
ANTICIPATE THOSE IN SCHEDULING.
AND I THINK WE CONSTANTLY
REVISIT OUR ENGINEERS ESTIMATES
IN OUR SCHEDULING ESTIMATES AND
ARE MUCH MORE REALISTIC ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN ATTAIN IT THIS TIME.
AND AS I MENTIONED OTHER
FACTORS COME IN PEOPLE HAVE TO
CHANGE THEIR SCHEDULES. WE HAVE
OTHER FACTORS RELATED TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO THINGS DO
REMAIN UNPREDICTABLE. IN THE
MEANTIME WE HAVE INCORPORATED A
NUMBER OF GUARD RAILS TO
CONTROL COSTS IN OUR CURRENT
CONTRACTOR IS OPERATING UNDER A
CONTRACT THAT DOES HAVE THIS
FIXED PRICE ELEMENTS. BEFORE I
CONCLUDE I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
EXCITING IN THE LARGER CONTEXT
OF DGSE. AS I SAID WE'VE
LEARNED A GREAT DEAL NOT ONLY
FROM THIS CLEAN UP BUT ALSO
FROM EXCITED BANKRUPTCY. WE'VE
BEEN APPLYING WHAT WE LEARNED
TO HOW WE'VE RIGHT INSPECT AND
ENFORCE OUR PERMITS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE UP TO DATE
PERMITS IN PLACE THAT MAKE IT
CLEAR TO AN OPERATOR WHAT THEIR
OBLIGATIONS ARE AND THAT MEANS
EXPECT THEM TO MEET THOSE
OBLIGATIONS AND WE WILL HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE. WE
ALSO NOTE THAT EXCITES
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE WAS
INADEQUATE. IN RESPONSE TO SB
SIX SEVENTY THREE WE'VE ALREADY
PUT TOGETHER STRICTER.
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE TESTS AND
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE. AND
WE'RE REVIEWING FINANCIAL
ASSURANCE MECHANISMS. MORE
FREQUENTLY FOR PERMITTED
FACILITIES BUT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GO EVEN
FURTHER IN STRENGTHENING
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE WE BEGAN TO
PURSUE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING SOME OF
THE OUTCOMES OF THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH THAT SIDE HAS MADE US A
BETTER ORGANIZATION. EXIDE
BANKRUPTCY SYMBOLIZES A MUCH
LARGER PROBLEM FOR CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED THAT THERE
ARE WITH BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CONTAMINATED SITES
ACROSS THE STATE MANY WITHOUT
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES. IT IS TIME
FOR THE STATE TO COME TO TERMS
WITH THAT AND TO BE REALISTIC
ABOUT THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE LUCK TOXIC LEGACY
OF THE LAST CENTURY AND EVEN
THE TOXICS WE USE IN OUR
EVERYDAY LIFESTYLES. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION. DGSE APPRECIATES THE
INSIGHTS GAINED. FROM
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ORDER
STAFF AND FROM THE AUDIT
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON OUR
PROCESS. YOU BELIEVE THE
PROCESS HAS PROVIDED WITH DGSE
WITH INFORMATION WE WILL USE TO
BETTER SERVE THE PUBLIC. WHO
LIVE AROUND THE FACILITY ARE
IMPACTED IN THEIR HEALTH AND
THEIR LIVES FROM EXPECT
OPERATIONS WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I
HAVE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FRANCESCA NEDRY HERE TODAY AND
ALSO OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
SITE MITIGATION AND READING
MEDIATION GRANT CULT. THANK
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THOSE US
MONEY AND I DON'T KNOW IF- I
KNOW YOU SAID YOU HAD- MISS NAY
GRAY AND- MISTER COPE BUT I'M
ASSUMING THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT.
TO ASSIST YOU BUT NOT TO HAVE A
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME
CORRECT. ALL WILL KNOW IT JUST
ANSWER ANY. IF NEEDED FANTASTIC.
IT WOULD BE GOOD START
QUESTIONING AND I KNOW WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS THAT WANT
TO ASK QUESTIONS TO AND I KNOW
OF THE REASONS FOR- PROBABLY A
SLOW RESPONSE JUST DEALING WITH
THINGS THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF YOUR
CONTROL LIKE PANDEMIC IN THE
WILDFIRES. BUT LET ME JUST ASK
NGUYEN TO THE PROPERTY START
WONDER THE PROPERTY CLEAN UP
START AND BEGIN. WE CAN'T UP
PROPERTY IN TWENTY OH. IT THE
CHECKERS WERE IN TWENTY. SIX
SEVEN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHERE THE
RESULT OF THE OF THE DAY CARES
THE SCHOOLS ETCETERA THE
RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP STARTED IN
TWENTY. EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
SERVICE OPRY PANDEMICS WE
STARTED AND LAY THE GROUNDWORK
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN YOU BEGAN
CLEANING PROPERTIES AT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT GOT IT AND IF
YOU CAN JUST ADDRESS IN TERMS
OF THE PRIORITIZATION WE HEARD
FROM THE AUDITOR AND FROM A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS THE
FRUSTRATION OF NOT PRIORITIZING
THE CHILD CARE CENTERS A PARKS
THE SCHOOLS- WHY WASN'T THAT
DONE IS THAT BEING ADDRESSED
NOW AND FOR THOSE. REMAINING
CHILD CARE CENTERS ARE ARE WE
CHILD CARE CENTERS PARKS AND
SCHOOLS ARE YOU LOOKING AT THAT
TIME CRITICAL REMOVAL ACTION TO
CAN EXPEDITE THE CLEANUP OF
THOSE PROPERTIES. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION YES WE ARE
DOUBLING DOWN ON OUR EFFORTS TO
GET THOSE PROPERTIES CLEANED WE
WILL USE TIME CRITICAL REMOVAL
ACTIONS WHEN WE NEED TO THERE
MAY BE SOME PROPERTIES. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO RESORT TO THAT WE
CAN JUST GET THEM IN THE QUEUE
AND KEEP THINGS MOVING. ON WE
HAVE A CONTRACTOR IN PLACE TO
DO THOSE CLEANUPS AND IT LOOKS
LIKE THE BOTH OF THOSE WILL BE
CLEANED BY. MARCH OF NEXT YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO GET THE
REMAINING FACILITIES THOSE
REMAINING DAY CARES IN THE
QUEUE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND BEGINTHOSE THOSE CLEANUPS
AS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN. GOT IT
AND- ACCORDING TO MY NOTES HERE
THERE'S- FIFTY PROPERTIES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED AS HIGH RISK TO
CHILDREN. BUT SO FAR ONLY
NINETEEN OF THOSE FIFTY HAVE
BEEN CLEANED UP SO CAN WE
EXPECT THE REMAINING OF THOSE
TO BE. CLEANED UP BY MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. YES ACTUALLY
SINCE THE TIME OF THE REPORT
WE'VE ALREADY. CLEANED
ADDITIONAL PROPERTY SO TWENTY
THREE HAVE NOW BEEN CLEANED UP.
AND WE AGAIN WE HAVE FOUR WE
ALREADY HAVE ACCESS AGREEMENTS
HANNAH YEAH JULES IN PLACE WITH
PROPERTY OWNERS. AND WE ARE
WORKING TO GET AS MANY OF THOSE
CLEANED UP BY SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS WE CAN. GOT IT
AND IN ORDER TO HELP EXPEDITE
SOME OF THE- THE CLEAN UP SHE
ALSO MENTIONED- THE
CONTRACTORS. UNLESS I WANT TO
ASK IS THE DEPARTMENT LOOKING
AT SECURING ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTORS AND I KNOW THE
AUDITOR ALSO MENTIONED- HAVING
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR THOSE
CONTRACTORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING OUR DEADLINES AND
TIMELINES. TO CLEAN UP THESE
PROPERTIES WHAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT DOING TO HELP- CLEAN
UP THESE PROPERTIES- QUICKER IF
YOU IF YOU MAY. SO I THINK THE
CONTRACT WE HAVE IN PLACE ANY
C. HAS- THEY THERE ARE SMALL.
BUT THEY REALLY AND THEN CELLS
IN TERMS THEIR ABILITY TO GET
THE PROPERTIES CLEANED. IN A
TIMELY FASHION AND STAY WITHIN
OUR COST REQUIREMENTS. AND SO
WE'RE VERY SATISFIED WITH THEM
WE ARE LIKELY TO SUBCONTRACT.
AND HAVE THEM USES OVERSEE A
SUBCONTRACTOR TO ADD
ADDITIONAL. OUR CREWS OUT IN
THE FIELD AND INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY. FOR CLEAN UP AND
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BEST COURSE
OF ACTION. ENTERING INTO NEW
CAR IS EXTREMELY COMPLICATED
AND TIME CONSUMING AND GIVEN
THE MOMENTUM WE HAVE WITH THE
CURRENT CONTRACTOR. WE FEEL THE
BEST INVESTMENT IS TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THAT CONTRACTOR. I
DO WANT TO SAY ONE THING WHICH
IS THAT IN THIS. IT I HAVE BEEN
CITY'S NEIGHBORHOODS AND IT
SEEMS IT TAKES TO GET THE CLEAN
UPS DONE SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
RESORT FOR INSTANCE TO HAND
EXCAVATION WE CAN'T USE LARGE
MACHINERY TO DO THE JOB. AND
IT'S THE LOGISTICS ARE VERY
COMPLEX AND SO WE EVEN HAVE
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE WE CAN'T
ADD ADDITIONAL CREWS BECAUSE
THE IMPACTS TO PARKING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WOULD BE. I JUST
COMPLETELY UNMANAGEABLE SO
THERE WILL BE A LIMIT ON HOW
MUCH CLEAN UP WE CAN GET DONE.
JUST BASED ON THE LOGISTICAL
CONSIDERATIONS. CATTERTON JUST
LOGISTICALLY WE BECAUSE OF THE
MAP I SAW LOOKS LIKE YOU CAN'T
YOU'RE MITIGATING IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AREAS ALL ON ALL
SIDES OF EXCITED TO PLAY- THE
ORIGINAL PROPERTY. I MEAN WHY
WOULD IN A CONTRACT TO BE ABLE
TO WORK ON SAY THE EAST SIDE
AND THE WEST SIDE YET TO
CONTRACTORS ARE THREE IN THE
NORTH AND SOUTH. AND WE DIDN'T
TAKE LONG APPROACH WHEN WE
STARTED THE PROJECT. ARE YOU
JUST A LOT OF MOVING PARTS TO
THIS WHICH IS TO SAY THAT. WE
STILL. DO FOR USE THAN THINK
ABOUT THE GEOGRAPHIC THE
GEOGRAPHY A LOT- AND AGAIN IF
WE HAD A SECOND CONTRACTOR WE
WOULD THINK ABOUT THOSE.
SITUATIONS RIGHT NOW OUR INTENT
IS NOT TO HAVE MOVED TO A
SECOND CONTRACT. AND OF THE
POTENTIAL TO. AND DIFFICULT
GETTING ANOTHER SET CONTRACTOR
ON BOARD. WELL THAT SAID- WE DO
NEED TO WORK AGAIN IN A LARGE
AND ON A LARGER OF PLACES
SIMPLY THE SAKE OF MANAGING THE
LOGISTICAL. COMPLICATIONS
UNDERSTOOD YEAH I WOULD THINK
WHETHER IT'S- ONE CONTRACTOR TO
CONTRACTORS OR SUBCONTRACTORS I
KNOW FOR THE RESIDENTS OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY JUST WANT
PROPERTIES CLEANED. AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE- I DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT I KNOW
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS WILL GO
HEAD TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
THAN SENATOR MORLOCK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COURT PLACE. ON COULD
YOU DESCRIBE. WHAT A TYPICAL
CLEANUP OR WHAT EXACTLY DO YOU
DO WITH THE GRAVEL YOU TAKE
AWAY- TO GET INVOLVED IN THE
HOMES OR JUST THE YARD SO WHAT
IS A TYPICAL CLEAN UP LIFE.
THIS TYPICAL CLEAN INVOICE
FIRST INFORM SAMPE THE PRO WE
NOW SEEM ALL OF THE PER IN THAT
ONE POINTS MILE RADIUS OR THE
FACILITY LEAST ALL THE
PROPERTIES WHERE THEY GAVE US
ACCESS TO GO ON AND DO SAMPLING.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A LEMASTER LIST
OF THOSE PROPERTIES THAT SORTED
BY THE LEVEL OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION WE DO OUR REACH
TO GET THOSE PROPERTIES IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE A PROPERTY COMES UP
TO THE TOP OF THE QUEUE WE NEED
WITH THE RESIDENT WE INSPECT
THE PROPERTY WE EXPLAINED THE
PROCESS TO THEM THERE ARE
MULTIPLE POINTS OF ENGAGEMENT
WITH A PROPERTY RESIDENTS. TO
MAKE SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS THEY NEED TO PICK FOR
INSTANCE THE FINISHES THE
LANDSCAPING FINISHES THAT WOULD
BE USED. IN THEIR IN THEIR-
CLEAN UP AND SO WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE EXPLAIN
IT TO THEM THEN OF COURSE ONCE
THE TIME BEGINS TO BEGIN THE
CLEAN UP TO CLEAN UP GOES ON IT
TAKES TYPICALLY A WEEK TO DO
THAT CLEAN UP SOMETIMES MORE
SOMETIMES LESS DEPENDING ON. OF
COURSE THE CONFIGURATION. AND
THEN ONCE WE'RE DONE WITH ME-
WE AND WE GO OUT AND INSPECT
THAT WORK AND- THEN THE
PROPERTY OWNER. IS WE MEET WITH
THE PROPERTY OWNER TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING IS SATISFACTORY
AND CLOSE OUT THE PROJECT. ON
FOR A GIVEN PROPERTY IN THE
MEANTIME WE HAVE WE REVIEW ALL
OF THE INVOICES THAT COME IN WE
GO OVER IT IN A GREAT DEAL OF
IN FAN OF DETAIL TO ENSURE THAT
ALL OF THE CHARGES ARE
APPROPRIATE AND. MANAGE THAT
VERY TIGHTLY. SO IS IT JUST
OUTSIDE OF THE HOUSE BUT GETS
CLEANED UP. WE CLEAN UP THE
OUTSIDE WE MAKE IT OUR WE MAKE
AN OFFER TO RESIDENTS THAT IF
THEY SHOULD WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
THE INTERIOR OF THEIR HOUSE.
CLEAN DUSTED GET TO REMOVE ANY
LEAD THAT WAS GENERATOR KICKED
UP DURING THE CLEAN UP PROCESS.
WE DO THAT IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THAT DONE IN THE
MEANTIME THE COUNTY OF LA HAS
FUNDS FOR LEAD PAINT ABATEMENT
AND HAS BEEN DOING THAT WORK-
IN THE SAME AREA. WHERE DOES
THE SOIL YOU PICKED UP WHERE
DOES IT END. SH WE DO WE
DEPENDING ON THE LEAD
CONTAMINATION OF ASSOCIATED
WITH THE SOIL IT THAT WILL
DETERMINE WHICH LAND WHICH TYPE
OF LANDFILL IT WOULD GO TO.
THANK YOU SOME OF IT WILL END
UP IN A HAZARDOUS WASTE
LANDFILL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KIRK MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO THEN SENATOR
MORE LOCKED IN ASSEMBLYWOMAN
GARCIA. I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIRS FOR HAVING THIS HERE
AND- I THINK YOU MISS WILL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY I AYE SIR SEE
AS AN HOUR TO ONE CLEAN THE UP
ON A THANK YOU- FOR TWO. THE
HELM OF THE DTS- RECENTLY- IT'S
NO SMALL TASK IT IS YOU KNOW
NO- BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT WHAT
I'VE LEARNED IN IN GOVERNMENT
AND POLITICS IS ON IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHEN THE PROBLEM WHEN
THE- MILKER THE COFFEE SPILLED
NOW THAT YOU'RE SITTING THERE
YOU. YOU'VE GOT TO CLEAN IT UP.
AND- BUT I WANT TO SAY THAT-
THAT I RECOGNIZE. THAT THAT IT
WASN'T YOUR LEADERSHIP FOR
THIRTY THREE TO THIRTY FIVE
YEARS WHEN I WASN'T IN TERM
PERMIT- OR SOME OF THE FAILURES
THAT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- OVER AND OVER. BUT
WE DO HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS. AND
I'M GONNA ASK THE SAME QUESTION
THAT I'M ASKING YOU CAN ANSWER
NOW YOU CAN ANSWER LATER BUT-
IT WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK BACK AT
THE DEPARTMENT YOU'VE GOT TO
ASK A QUESTION. IT IS A
CULTURAL ISSUE AT THE
DEPARTMENT- WHAT IT CAN GET
AXED RATE ISN'T NEGLIGENCE OR
OR SHEER INCOMPETENCE IN SOME
CASES RIGHT BECAUSE- WHEN YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THIRTY ONE
PROPERTIES THAT WERE MISSED- IT
WASN'T LIKE WE MISSED YOU KNOW
WE MAY SHUFFLE THE PIECE OF
PAPER WE- WE DID A PERMIT
WRONG. IT WAS THIRTY ONE
PROPERTIES. SOMEBODY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN. SCREAMING AT THE TOP
OF THEIR LUNGS- TO A DIRECTOR
AT THE TSC. WHO SHOULD BE
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE
ASKING HEY I'VE GOT A PROBLEM
HERE THIRTY ONE. PROPERTIES OF
THESE OF THE LAWS THAT PREVENT
ME FROM CLEANING IT UP. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE CHANGE LAWS. YOU
KNOW IT IF WE NEEDED TO CLEAN
IT UP WE CAN CHANGE THAT LAW-
BUT TO HAVE IT FOUND OUT THERE
WERE NOT IT IS. I WOULD. YOU
KNOW BY BORA PROFESSIONAL
SETTINGS I WON'T SAY WHAT I
WANT TO SAY BUT IT'S- IT'S
DISHEARTENING. TO FIND OUT THE
TOOK A NOT AT THE FIND OUT THAT
THERE WAS THIRTY ONE-
PROPERTIES THAT WERE NOT
CLEANED. WE COULD CHANGE THOSE
LAWS- ASSEMBLY- EVEN NIGHT I
THINK WE I COULD HAVE A- AN
URGENT CLAUSE TO OF THOSE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT PROPER
CLEANED OR AT LEAST WE WERE
HAVE TRIED. SOMEONE JUST PUT
THAT THERE AT THAT DAY YOU HAVE
YOUR ABILITY- TO COME TO THE-
SAY THIS IS WHAT'S PREVENTING-
THE ABILITY FOR ME TO GETTING
THIS STUFF DONE. LET'S LET'S
WORK TOGETHER ON CHANGING
WHATEVER IT IS WHATEVER
OBSTACLE THERE IS THAT IS AT
YOUR DISPOSAL AND WE WOULD WANT
TO DO THAT BECAUSE IT'S IN OUR
INTEREST TO DO THAT- THAT'S
BEEN SET NOW- YEAH BUT BUT WHEN
YOU TALK TO THE GENERAL GENERAL
PUBLIC OR AT LEAST MY
CONSTITUENTS IF I WERE TO GO TO
THEM AND SAY HERE'S ALL THE
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY WE
COULDN'T CLEAN UP THE
PROPERTIES- THEY WOULDN'T
HESITATE BUT BUT TO TRY TO FIND
SOMEBODY NEW. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
FACING IT IS TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT. HOW WE NOT ONLY IMPLEMENT
ALL THE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
MAYBE OR COMPLETE OVERHAUL AND
REFORM OF THE T. T. S. C. SO
THAT ACTUALLY CAN FIX THE
PROBLEM THAT'S BEFORE US WHICH
IS CLEANING UP THE PROPERTIES
BECAUSE THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
PROPERTIES A LOT- EIGHT AND WE
ONLY HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
FUNDS. YOU KNOW I KNOW I'VE
I'VE I'VE SAID A COUPLE THINGS
THAT I FEEL VERY STRONGLY.
ABOUT BUT I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR
REACTION ON ON MAYBE- WHAT
TOOLS YOU NEED. HOW IS THIS
GOING TO CHANGE IN THE FUTURE
NOW THAT YOU. AND HOW WE GET
THESE CLEANED UP AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE YOU KNOW I
SAID BEFORE IN IN IN IT SOUNDS
ALARMING BUT IT'S VERY TRUE.
IT'S VERY TRUE PEOPLE'S LIVES
ARE AT STAKE. PEOPLE MAYBE HAVE
DIED HAVE DIED IN COULD DIE WE
HAVE KIDS WITH HIGH LEVELS OF
ASTHMA- WITHIN THE GENERAL
POPULACE WITH IN THE GENERAL
VICINITY MIND MINE INCLUDED- WE
HAVE A- BUT WE HAVE HIGH LEVELS
OF BIRTH DEFECTS AS YOU'VE
HEARD IN THE AREA. HIGH LEVELS
OF CANCER THE DISTRIBUTED TO
DIFFERENT REPORTS- WE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL OF WATER A POTENTIAL
BEING CONTAMINATED. AND YET
WE'RE NOT MOVING AT LIGHTNING
SPEED WITH WHAT A SENSE OF
URGENCY BREAKING DOWN EVERY
SINGLE PAYER BEFORE US- SO YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE PAIN
FRUSTRATION ANGER. I THAT THE
RESIDENTS COLIN- AS IS WITH. AS
THIS WITH WHAT I SAY I ALSO
FEEL THAT I LIVE IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD. WHEN CAN I GET
YOUR REACTION ABOUT WHAT SCHOOL
YOU KNOW HOW WE'VE DONE THIS
AUDIT. WHAT WE SEE THAT IS
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT THAT SETS
IN THAT SENSE OF URGENCY. THAT
THIS COMMUNITY MERITS DEMANDS
AND DESERVES. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I HAVE TO SAY
FIRST OF ALL WE DON'T HAVE TO
IMAGINE THE PAIN AND
FRUSTRATION WE HEAR IT DIRECTLY
FROM THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS. AS YOU
KNOW THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCESS THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
PUBLIC HEARINGS AND WE HEARD.
JUST HOW IMPACTFUL THIS HAS
BEEN THOSE STORIES WERE REALLY
TOUGH TO LISTEN TO AND IT'S
REALLY- AGAIN IT DOES GIVE US A
SENSE OF URGENCY. I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
WILLINGNESS TO DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO GET THIS CLEAN UP DONE
AND TO HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE. AND
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE DGSE HAS
VERY GOOD AUTHORITIES WE HAVE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES WE HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO USE THE TECH
REPRISE SAYS AND THIS REALLY
COMES DOWN TO USING THOSE WITH
AUTHORITIES USING THEM WISELY
AND USING THEM STRATEGICALLY
AND MAKE SURE THINGS GET DONE
AND GET DONE QUICKLY. AND WE'VE
BEEN HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT AND ARE MOVING VERY
AGGRESSIVELY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S THE CASE. IF YOU WERE TO
GO ON OUR WEBSITE TODAY YOU
WOULD EASILY BE ABLE TO FIND
THE NUMBER OF HOMES THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPERTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP AND WE TRACK OUR
PROGRESS ON THE WEBSITE. WE
WILL BE TRACKING THE SPECIFICS
AROUND THE DAY CARES AND
SCHOOLS ON THE WEBSITE ALSO
THAT'LL BE UP AND RUNNING
SHORTLY- AND THAT'S ONE WAY TO
WEAR IT IF YOU SEE US GOING OFF
TRACK. WITH WHAT I SAID TODAY
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES WE HAVE LINED UP TO
CLEAN BEFORE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I EXPECT TO BE BACK
BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEES I EXPECT
YOU TO ASK US WHAT WENT WRONG.
BUT AS I SAID AND I TAKE DEEP
PERSONAL PRIDE IN THIS WE ARE A
LEARNING ORGANIZATION AND WE
HAVE WORKED. AND SO YES
MISTAKES HAVE BEEN MADE BUT WE
ARE NOT. UP TEN PROPERTIES A
MONTH WE'RE CLEANING UP SEVENTY
PROPERTIES A MONTH WE ARE
MOVING QUICKLY. AND WE DO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COURSE CORRECT.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS OF THESE THE LARGER IS
THERE SOMETHING WRONG WITH YOU
TNC AND I'D SAY. WE ARE
REGULATORS IT IS OUR JOB TO
REGULATE AND PART OF THAT MEANS
THAT WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAKING DECISIONS. AND ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BREAKDOWNS THAT
CAME WITH RESPECT TO EXCITE WAS
THE FACT THAT THAT INTERIM
STATUS. PERMANENT A DECISION
WASN'T MADE EITHER ON THAT ARE
NOT IN A ROOM STATUS OF.
SITUATION BUT IMPORTANTLY ON
THE AT THE APPLE. THAT THEY SO.
TO BE A PER FOR. AND THAT
PERMIT WAS VERY LOW. AND YET
THE DEPARTMENT DIDN'T MAKE THE
DECISION IN A TIMELY FASHION.
SO FIRST OF ALL WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY OTHER SITES ON MONITORING
STATUS INTERM STATUS IS ONLY
FOR NEW SITES THAT COME ON
BOARD AND ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
APPLYING FOR A PERMIT AND
WAITING FOR A PERMIT DECISION
SO. THERE ARE NO OFFICE WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE A SOME KIND OF
PERMIT IN PLACE THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO ENFORCE TO TAKE ACTION-
FOR WE DO HAVE WHAT WE CALL
CONTINUED PERMITS THOSE ARE
PERMITS THAT EXPIRED BUT ARE.
ARE STILL ENFORCEABLE AND THIS
IS WHERE I RETURNED TO THE
DECISION ISSUE. UNLESS THERE
ARE UP TO DATE PERMITS IN PLACE
THEY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT MODERN
BEST PRACTICES. FOR MANAGING
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHAT IT TAKES TO
INSPECT AND ENFORCE A FACILITY.
WE RUN THE RISK OF OTHER ACTS
ACTS. BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
MAKING DECISIONS AND TO MOVING
THINGS FORWARD AND TO PUTTING
THOSE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. NEXT
EXCITEMENT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
HAPPEN. AND I'M I AM VERY
PLEASED WITH THE PROGRESS I'M
SEEING FROM OUR STAFF AND I
WILL TURN THIS BACK WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN DO. A LOT OF WHAT THE WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS THE DIRECT RESULT
OF. EITHER CHANGES IN
REQUIREMENTS AS A FOR INSTANCE
WITH SB SIX SEVENTY THREE
PUTTING THE VIOLATIONS SCORING
PROCEDURE IN PLACE FOR
INCREASED INANCIAL ASSURANCE.
OR GIVING US THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THE RESOURCES TO
STRENGTHEN AND ACCELERATE. OR
PERMIT DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
PLEASE I KNOW WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE VERY QUICK ON THIS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A TIME CONSTRAINT SIZE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ASK A QUESTION. I WILL SAY THIS
TO YOUR CREDIT. IT IS
REFRESHING FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SINCE I WAS A STAFFER- FOR THE
PREVIOUS NUMBER IN OUR DISTRICT
INSTANCES SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN A
LEGISLATURE- THAT. ANY ONE
PERSON- IN LEADERSHIP AT THE
TNC. HAS IT MADE ANY ANY SORT
OF THE STATE BY THE AGENCY. YOU
KNOW YOU LEARN WHEN YOU'RE A
LITTLE KID THAT THAT IF YOU
COULD ADMIT THAT SOMETHING WAS
WRONG THEN YOU CAN ADMIT THE
FIXING IT. AND PART OF THE
PROBLEM WITH THE EASY THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR I'VE EVER
TALKED IS NOTHING CAN EVER
GOLD. EXCUSE AFTER EXCUSE AFTER
EXCUSE. SO IT IS A BIT
ENCOURAGING DOESN'T TAKE AWAY
THE PAIN DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THE-
THE HURT AND THE ANGER THAT I
FEEL- INSTEAD IS THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS FEEL. AND IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THE FIERCE-
AND THE FIGHT THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
CLEANED UP. BUT AT LEAST
ADMITTING. THAT THAT DECISION
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MADE. AND IT
WASN'T. ALLOWS US TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE FUTURE DECISIONS HAVE
TO BE MADE. AND A HALF TO
RESULT IN CLEANING UP OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT LITTLE BIT PIECE
AND I DIDN'T WANT THAT TO GO
TO. I DIDN'T WANT THAT TO BE
UNNOTICED BUT BUT I WILL SAY
THIS THOUGH. HI I WOULD EXPECT-
THAT IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER.
DECISIONS THAT NEED TO BE MADE
THAT THEY WOULD BE MADE
FORCEFULLY ON THIS SITE AND ANY
OTHER SIGHTINGS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT THERE ARE
IF THERE ARE OBSTACLES THAT
PREVENT YOU FROM CLEANING UP
EXCITE AND THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES DID THEY BE TOLD TO
US SO WE CAN ADDRESS. ON AND
CHANGE WHATEVER LAWS IT NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED BECAUSE I WOULD
IMAGINE AFTER AFTER THIS I
WOULD HAVE IF IT WAS ME I WOULD
BE OPERATING LIKE A WRECKING
BALL KNOCKING DOWN EVERY SINGLE
OBSTACLE EVERY SINGLE WALL AND
FIGHTING FIERCELY FOR EVERY
SINGLE HOUSE TO BE CLEAN AND I
EXPECT NOTHING LESS- FROM YOU
OR FROM ME- ON. SALAS I HOLD
THAT. I WANT TO BE A COMMIT
WITHOUT PUT. WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN FROM THIS
POINT FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT WILL MOVE TO
CENTER MORE TALK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MISS
WILLIAMS- AS YOU'RE REVIEWING
THE SAMPLES OF ALL THE
RESIDENCES IN THE AREA ARE YOU
NOTICING ANY TRENDS OR
DISTRIBUTION OR THEIR PLUMES OR
LIKE A LIKE BUTTON NATURAL-
OCEAN BREEZES THAT GO A CERTAIN
DIRECTION MOST OF THE TIME ARE
WE SAYING. WHAT WE SEEING FROM
THE EXITE. PLANT WHERE WHERE
WHERE MORE THE LEAD WEARS MORE
THE LEAD LOCATED. SO WE HAVE
SAMPLED ALL OVER THE ONE POINT
SEVEN MILE RADIUS THAT WE
CALLED THE PER KILOMETRE
INVESTIGATION AREA. AND BLOODY
IS A VERY I MEAN IT'S A HEAVY
SUBSTANCE AND AS A RESULT IT'S
NOT LIKE A VERY FINE WHITE
WHITE NOT VERY DENSE SUBSTANCE
BUT WHEN YOU PUT IT IN THE AIR
IT DISTRIBUTES ITSELF EVENLY
AND BLOWS AROUND. AND PUTTING
EVEN COATING WHEREVER IT LANDS
LET IS VERY DIFFERENT IT IT IT
DEPOSITING VERY LOCALIZED WAVES
YES THERE ARE SOME CAN AND SOME
RELATIONSHIPS TO PREVAILING
WINDS. BUT IT IS REMARKABLE HOW
YOU CAN FIND A HIGH LEAD LEVEL
IN ONE PROPERTY AND AN ADJACENT
PROPERTY YOU MAY NOT FIND THAT
SAME LEAD LEVEL AND THAT'S A
POINT OF CONFUSION AND
FRUSTRATION OF FOLKS BUT THAT
IS THE NATURE OF LAND AND HOW
IT DISTRIBUTES UP. THERE ARE
NO- IT'S NOT LIKE A GROUNDWATER
PLUME WHERE YOU FOLLOW THE CAN
MAN YOU YOU KNOW YOU CAN SEE
THE EXTENT OF THE
CONTAMINATION. THANK YOU IN-
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE YOU MAKE IT SOUND
LIKE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO.
HIRE NEW CONTRACTORS- SO I'M
JUST A LITTLE CURIOUS YOU KNOW
THAT WE'VE HAD THIS LONG TIME
LINE. AND IT SEEMS TO ME YOU
COULD HAVE SOMEHOW FIT IN A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ROSS THIS
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL- WHAT'S
WHAT'S REALLY HINDERING YOU BUT
WHAT IT HELP IF WE- DID NOT
HAVE A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
IS THAT HOLDING- BACK AT THE
AMOUNT OF POTENTIAL BIDDERS. OR
SHOULD WE BE LOOKING AT. NON
UNION CONTRACTORS AS WELL.
CERTAINLY NOT. SORRY IT IS-
STRAIGHT TO THAT BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE- ABOUT. THIS
PROJECT IS THAT PROJECT
AGREEMENTS THAT AGREEING.
ALLOWED US TO. THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY EXCITES
OPERATIONS ACTUALLY GET TO
BENEFITS IF YOU WANT TO CALL IT
THAT. FROM THE WORK THAT'S
GENERATED DOING THIS CLEAN UP
SO WE'D HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
COPD COHORTS GO THROUGH OUR
WORKS. TRAINING TO BECOME
ENVIRONMENTAL- AB BERMAN
TECHNICIANS WE HAVE A NUMBER
AND I'VE MET THEM- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A WHOLE FAMILY OF FOLKS
WHO ARE WORKING ON THIS CLEAN
UP. AND AND. HAVE FOUND
EMPLOYMENT. IN SOME CASES FOR
THE FIRST TIME ADULTS- ON THIS
AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT SOME LYFT
CHANGE IMPACT OF THAT SO. THE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT IS
AGAIN IT'S A STATE REQUIREMENT
ANYWAY TO GIVE PREVENT
PREVAILING WAGE SO WE'RE VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT AND WE BELIEVE
IN IT VERY MUCH. IN TERMS OF
OTHER THINGS WE CAN DO AGAIN AS
WE'VE BEEN ANSWERING KIND OF
THIS HOME STRETCH OF THE THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED. WE HAVE FELT THAT
IT'S MUCH MORE EFFICIENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HOW TO DO THIS
CLEAN UP NO MATTER IF WE
STARTED WITH ANOTHER CLEAN UP A
CONTRACTOR- NEXT MONTH OR IN IT
WOULD TAKE MONTHS TO GET THEM
UP TO SPEED AND GET THEM
ORIENTED. IT WOULD TAKE THEM AT
LEAST SIX EIGHT TEN MONTHS
BEFORE THEY EVEN APPROXIMATED
THE RATE OF CLEAN UP THAT WE
SEE WITH OUR CURRENT
CONTRACTOR. AND IF THE PRIORITY
IS TO GET AS MANY PROPERTIES
CLEANED UP AS FAST AS AS WE
CAN. WE FEEL THAT THE BEST
DECISION IS TO STICK WITH THE
CONTRACTOR WE HAVE USE
SUBCONTRACTORS TRACTORS AFTER
WE KNEW IF WE NEED TO. THAT
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO PUT
QUALITY CONTROL IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE FOLLOWING
ALL THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
HAVE. BEEN DEVELOPED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. SO JUST NOT
YOUR- IN MY CLOTHES AND THAT
IS- THE DMV FAILED TO RECOGNIZE
HELP SEVERE- THE NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS WOULD BE FOR REAL
ID. AND HAD A REAL MANPOWER
SHORTAGE AND SO. OUR OFFICES
GET TO HEAR ABOUT THAT SO MY
CONSTITUENTS DRIVE MARCH COUNTY
TO. PALM SPRINGS TO FIND A DMV
OFFICE THAT'S NOT GOING TO MAKE
HIM WAIT FOR FOUR OR FIVE
HOURS. AND THEN WE'VE HAD UP
THE LOCKDOWN- IN ITS AS IF THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WAS JUST REALLY
CAUGHT FLAT FOOTED- IT DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH STAFFING TO HANDLE
ALL THE REQUESTS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS OUR
OFFICES HAVE BEEN GOING. CRAZY
WITH THAT DEALING WITH THE
CASELOAD- SO. WHAT IF YOUR
CONTRACTOR DECIDED TO SAY HEY
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS PROJECT
ANYMORE. ARE WE SAYING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A YEAR TO GET A
REPLACEMENT CONTRACTOR I. I'M
I'M JUST GONNA JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW WE HANDLE MANPOWER
MANAGEMENT TO GET YOU KNOW THE
JOB DONE. AND IT IT ALWAYS
SEEMS AS IF WE'RE UNDERSTAFFED
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY
DEPARTMENT HEADS DON'T.
ANTICIPATE CERTAIN THINGS SAKE
I NEED MORE MONEY IF I COULD
HAVE A SECOND CONTRACTOR THEIR
CONTRACTOR. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GIVE ME THOSE RESOURCES
LET ME MOVE FORWARD. AND MAYBE
THAT'S MORE OF A SPEECH I MISS
WILLIAMS BUT- IT IS SORT OF A
LIMIT TO HAVE A OF WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON THE LINE. COUPLE YEARS
AND OFFICES. ON HOW DEPARTMENTS
ARE SOMEHOW STEPPING UP TO THE
MANPOWER. MANAGEMENT UP
COMPONENT OF WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. IF I MAY I WILL
SAY THIS. I WILL JUST SAY THAT
RESEARCH ARE DEPARTMENT THAT
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE UNDER RESOURCE- THERE THE
GOVERNOR DID PUT FORTH A
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS OUR STARK
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. AND TO PUT
ENOUGH RESOURCES IN PLACE SO
THAT WE COULD DO A GOOD JOB AND
DO THE JOB THAT WE NEED TO DO
AND IT CALIFORNIANS NEED US TO
DO- AND SO I TAKE YOUR COMMENTS
VERY. SERIOUSLY IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US. THAT ADEQUATE
RESOURCES BE IN PLACE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT- WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA GO TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA. THANK
YOU- WHEN I TRY TO BE SB AS-
THAT'S PART. WE KNOW TALKED
ABOUT THE. IF SOMEONE LESS OF
OTHER EMERGENCIES THAT MIGHT-
MOVE RESOURCES AROUND AND SO
FORTH. BUT WE'VE KNOWN SINCE
THE VERY BEGINNING WHEN WE DID
THE FIRST ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR LOAN
AND THE ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
FIVE. MILLION DOLLAR LOAN THREE
YEARS LATER THAT WE WERE NEVER
GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
CLEAN UP ALL THE HOMES THAT ARE
AFFECTED IT'S PREDICTABLE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AT LEAST
FORTY SIX HUNDRED HOMES THAT
ARE IN. THE TOP SIX DANGEROUS
LEVEL OF LEAD AND WE HAVE NO
PLAN TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO
CLEAN THEM UP. AND SAYS I'VE
BEEN GOING HOME ON A REGULAR
BASIS THAT THAT HAS BEEN THE
CONSTANT FRUSTRATION. BUT I'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING AT THE TELLING
FOLKS WE'RE NOT GOING TO LEAVE
ANYONE BEHIND THERE'S NO
WINNERS AND LOSERS SHOULD BE TO
MAKE SURE. EVERYTHING IS
CLEANED UP WITH THAT IN MIND WE
STARTED A BATTERY FEE FUND- IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT
STARTED TO COLLECT DOLLARS- AND
WE'VE DONE ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE IT- BUT
IT'S- IT'S BRINGING MEN.
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IN REVENUE.
ARE WE LOOKING AT POTENTIAL
PLANS OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
SEEN THAT. THOSE FUNDS MOVING
FORWARD. TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
PLAN TO CLEAN UP ALL THESE
HOMES- WHICH IS THE INTENT OF
THAT. ORIGINAL BATTERY FEET-
AND THAT'S HOW WE LOOK AT THE
PUT. OF BAR. AT THE MONEY US
THAT WE CAN CLEAN A BENEFIT.
PACE AND THEN PAYING IT BACKS
AND BETTER YOU YOU FIND. THANK
YOU IS. MEMBER WE ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO BEGIN TAPPING INTO THE
LEAD ACID BATTERY RECYCLING
FUND TO SUPPORT THE CLEAN UP WE
WILL USE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER ADDITIONAL-
STAFF. COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH A
PURPOSE CLEAN UP AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE LOOKING OF I'M-
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO USE THAT
FUND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
AND CAN- CONTINUE TO CLEAN UP
BUT YES THAT'S A GREAT SOURCE
OF FUNDING AND WE INTEND. THANK
YOU AND WILL WE IS THERE A
TIMELINE BY WHEN YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GIVE US MAYBE A MANY OF
PLANS FOR CLEANUP BASED ON I
KNOW THAT OUR BIGGEST OBSTACLES
AS DOLLARS. SO WILL THERE BE A
MANY OF IF THERE'S ONLY TEN
MILLION VERSUS SIX FIFTY
MILLION VERSUS IF SOMEHOW. WE
APPROPRIATE ATTENTION AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE
SURE WE- CLEAN UP THE SALAS
THESE HOUSES. IS THAT GOING TO
BE COMING AND PROVIDE OUR-
SEVEN POINT. WELL AS I
MENTIONED THERE'S A LOT OF
BUDGET UNCERTAINTY THIS YEAR
ESPECIALLY- AND THEN AS
EVERYONE KNOWS THE BUDGET
PROCESS CAN IS A DELIBERATIVE
PROCESS SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT BUT WE DO REVISIT OUR
ENGINEERS ESTIMATES ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND THAT'S THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH AN ONGOING PROCESS
NOW AND SO WHEN THE TIME COMES
WE'RE SURE THAT WE WILL HAVE
GOOD ESTIMATES AND CAN. GAIN
CAN TELL PEOPLE WHAT IT WILL
TAKE TO GET ADDITIONAL CLEAN UP
THE- YEAH I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO SPEAK TO. DURING
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS TO SAFE FOR
US TO DO X. AMOUNT OF HOMES IN
THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO WHICH
WOULD BE WITHIN OUR TARGET THE
SAID THE DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO NEED. I THINK HAVING
THAT BEFORE US ALLOWS US AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE. AND
HAVE FRANK DISCUSSIONS THAT
WOULD GET THEM GO HOME AND HAVE
FRANK DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. AS WELL AND
THEN FINALLY I WILL SAY THAT
I'VE I'VE- I'M EXHAUSTED WERE
BETTER I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS SINCE I GOT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMMUNITY
SIX ALSO BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON IT WAY LONGER THAN
I. THAN I HAVE. HI AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE MANY
MORE MEMBERS WHO ARE AREPART
OF THIS FIGHT NOW- AND THE
DEPARTMENT THAT I THINK IS
TRYING THAT UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP. TO GET IT RIGHT-
AND TO AND TO LEARN IT AND TO
MOVE FORWARD AND THEN TO ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANYMORE
EXCITES US. IN THE FUTURE- WE
WERE BORED AND SO. I DO HOPE
YOU LOOK AT THE TNC REFORM
WHILE AB NINE IF I WAS YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF PROGRESS THERE. THAT WE WILL
BE VISITING- NEXT YEAR
INCLUDING THE FINANCIALS
PRESSURE AND SAYS- TO ENSURE WE
HAVE A DEPARTMENT THAT. DOES
ITS JOB AND HELP. KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES HEALTHY.
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED FOR WAY TOO LONG THAT
HAPPEN TO BE A COLOR LINE COME-
THAT. THAT HAVEN'T. HAD JUSTICE
OF FOR A REALLY LONG TIME. IF I
MAY. THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT
FOR THOSE COMMENTS- AND- I. I
WILL SAY THIS THAT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ON A LOT
OF DIFFERENT LEVELS. NOT JUST
RELATED TO- WHERE THE SITE
SURFACED FOR. PERMITTED BUT
REALLY WITH RESPECT TO
ENFORCEMENT ACTION ISSUES- WE
DID MAKE A LOT OF AND-
PROGRESS. ON THE CONVERSATIONS
BOTH BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED. COMPREHENSIVE REFORM
AND THE SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE
IN NINE NINE FIVE. I THINK WE
DID LEARN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT-
WHAT WE LEARNED. FOR INSTANCE
WAS THERE MAY BE OTHER WAYS TO
GIVE MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. TO THE
PERMITTING PROCESS WE DID FIND
SOME OTHER AVENUES FOR
STRENGTHENING FINANCIAL
INSURANCE. AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO PURSUE ALL OF THOSE MEASURES.
THIRTY SECONDS. PLEASE AND
MOVIE BE ABLE TO GET A WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS FROM THE TNC- IN THE
NEAR FUTURE SO THAT'S ALSO PART
OF OUR BUDGET DISCUSSIONS YEAH
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE VERY EAGER TO
SHARE WITH YOU OR ANALYSIS OF
WHERE THE RESOURCES. IN THE D.
N. D. T. S. C. ARE GOING WHAT
WE'RE ABLE TO GET ON WITH OUR
CURRENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES
HAND. ON WHAT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET TO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION TO. TO HAVE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE TOUGH
DECISIONS ABOUT PRIORITIES AND
WITHOUT THAT INFORMATION IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS. YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
YOUR RESPONSE THANKS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- GARCIA I DO THINK THAT'S
A- AND YOU WERE CHAMPION OF
THE- THE BATTERY FEE TO HELP
SET ASIDE ANOTHER. FUNDING POT
ACTUALLY CLEAN UP THESE SITES I
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GOING TO
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND THEN AFTER BIRTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN WE WILL MOVE TO
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS.
MR HOLDEN PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE TO
YOUR BEING HERE AND BEING ABLE
TO BE TRANSPARENT AND
PRESENTATION AND ALSO.
RECEPTIVE TO NOT ONLY THE
QUESTIONS OF HOW. AND WHY BUT
THAT YOU RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE THE- THE CHALLENGES
THAT. OF THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED UNDER AND THE
LEADERSHIP THAT MY COLLEAGUES
ARE PROVIDING. AND THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO ESTABLISH WITH YOU- I WANTED
TO REALLY JUST TAKE A- QUICK
SECOND TO. ASK PROCESS QUESTION
ON TWO AREAS AND MY APOLOGIES
IF. THIS WAS BROUGHT UP IN YOUR
INITIAL PRESENTATION- BUT IN
THE REPORT THERE IS A
RECOGNITION THAT- SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. WAS SPENT MORE
OF THESE CONTRACTS DUE TO POOR
CONTRACT PROTECTIONS. AND I
WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS
OF HOW YOUR CONTRACTS ARE
NEGOTIATED IF THEY ARE STAFF.
NON LAWYERS NEGOTIATING OR
THESE CONTRACTS THAT ARE BEING
NEGOTIATED BY THE STATE BY
CONTRACT LAWYERS WHO ARE- VALUE
WAITING THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF WHAT NEEDS TO GO
INTO A CONTRACT TO ENSURE. THAT
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S BEST INTEREST
IS BEING PROTECTED SO THAT
WOULD BE THE FIRST QUESTION IN
TERMS OF. HOW WHAT IS THE
PROCESS FOR NEGOTIATING YOUR
CONTRACTS. THANK YOU- WE DO IN
FACT HAVE OF CONTRACT LOOK
ATTORNEYS ON STAFF AND THEY DO
SUPPORT US EXTENSIVELY AND HAVE
BEEN VERY IMPORTANT IN THIS
WORK BUT I AM GOING TO LET OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FRANCESCA
NAY GRIEF RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION IN DETAIL. CAN YOU
HEAR ME THIS. OUR I THANK YOU
FOR THE ARE TO BE HERE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AND- IS- DOCTOR WILLIAMS IS
INDICATED WE ARE A LEARNING
ORGANIZATION AND AT THE TIME
THAT WE- YOU KNOW WE WERE- A
LOAN TO THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAD HAD. A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
EXECUTING LARGE CONTRACTS- AS
TO A DOCTOR WHIMS ALSO
INDICATED WE DO HAVE ATTORNEYS
ON BOARD I'M HERE. HI THIS
ATTORNEYS- NO IN THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS ALSTER ARE
CONTRACTING PROGRAMS AND
PROCESSING SO YES A SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT- HOW WE EXECUTE
OR HELP WITH THE PROCESS OF
EXECUTING CONTRACTS WELL THE
FIRST TO SAY THAT THIS
INITIALLY THE LARGE CONTRACT-
FOR THIS PROJECT WAS EXECUTED
UNDER WHAT'S CALLED A TIME AND
MATERIALS CONTRACT AND I KNOW
THE AUTHOR. REFERENCES THAT AND
AT THE TIME THAT WE WENT INTO
THAT CONTRACT WE ACTUALLY TRY
TO GO OUT WITH A COMPETITIVE
BID WE- PARTNERED WITH OUR OWN
SHOW OUR FRIENDS OVER
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WHO HAVE EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA
AS WELL AS OTHER STATE AGENCIES
THAT HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE IN.
LARGE CONTRACTS THAT'S THIS IS
FUTURE AND BECAUSE WE HAD SO
MANY ELEMENTS OF THE PROJECT
THAT WERE UNKNOWN AT THAT TIME-
WE FIND IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET INTO CONTRACT UNDER- R. F.
P. PROCESSOR OTHER
COMPETITIVELY BID PROCESS SEES.
SO THE TIME ACCIONES CONTRACT
IS A IS A CONTACT MECHANISM
THAT IS USED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH OTHER STATE
GOVERNMENTS. WE'VE GOT ELEMENTS
OF A PROJECT THAT OR SHE ARE.
UNKNOWN OR UNDETERMINED. AS WE
PROGRESS THROUGH THE PROJECT WE
KNOW A LOT MORE TODAY THAN WE
KNEW WHEN WE FIRST ENTERED INTO
A CONTRACT. AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO WITH SUBSEQUENT CONTRACTS
AND I KNOW DOCTOR WILLIAMS
MENTIONED AND YOU SEE WHICH IS
OUR PRIME CONTRACTOR NOW WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO- GET INTO-
CONTRACTS THAT ARE HYBRIDS ARE
FIXED PRICE CONTRACTS SO THAT
WE CAN CONTROL THOSE COSTS.
THE- THE ORIGINAL TIME ANGELES
CONTRACT I THINK IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CONSIDER FOR THE CONTRACT
ACTIVITIES FOR THIS PROJECT
BECAUSE WE NOW KNOW MORE A. LOT
MORE THAN WE DID YEAH- THAT TO
MAKE SURE- AND ENTERED AND THIS
PART. I WANT TO ALSO SAY THAT
WE TAKE SOME STEPS VERY
PROACTIVE STEPS TO SORT OF
STOPS. YOUR CONTACT. YEAH DTS
ABOUT HALF OF THE MONTH AGO WE
HEARD. WHOSE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THE STATE PARKING PROCESS USED
TO GO TO ALL OF OUR CONTRACT
PROGRAMS AND PROCESS EASIER AND
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AND
STRENGTHEN THOSE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD. SO WE'RE MAKING WE
HAVE A- WE'VE YOU KNOW UPDATED
OUR BUSINESS PROCESSES ARE
MANUAL R. CHENEY- AND ALL THOSE
THINGS HAVE IMPROVED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS TO ENSURE THAT
FUTURE PROJECTS AND THIS
PROJECT. WILL ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CONTRACTING AND IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE. AND
GETTING THE BEST VALUE STATE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE OF THE- I
DO SO THAT. IT IS CLEARLY ONE
OF THOSE AREAS WHERE- WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT PROTECTIONS
ARE IN PLACE- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IS A
LOT OF MONEY ON ONE CONTRACT
SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU'RE
MOVING IN THE PLACE OF- REFORM
AND I THINK THAT'S APPRECIATED
THE LAST QUESTION THAT I HAD
AGAIN PROCESS. AS IT RELATES
TO- THE EXCITES OF BANKRUPTCY
WHAT ARE WHAT IS THE PROCESS
WOULD HAVE EFFORTS UNDERWAY TO
PROTECT THE STATE AND ENSURE
THAT WE DO GET REIMBURSED I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A QUESTION IN
THAT REGARD. BUT HOW DO WE
ESTABLISH A STRONG POSITION
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
REIMBURSED. FOR THE RESOURCES
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN PUT OUT
IN THIS- THEY WERE SEEKING TO
GET BACK FROM- FROM EXIDE. I
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
I'LL I'LL DEFER TO- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR GRANT COPE TO ANSWER
WITH GREATER SPECIFICITY BUT-
THE STATE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
AND WILL BE PURSUING ALL
AVENUES TO HOLD ALL RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES. ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
COST OF THIS PROJECT AND- WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OCCURS. NOW GO
AHEAD AND HAVE GRANT COPE
ANSWER ANY MORE SPECIFIC. ABOUT
THAT. CAN I ASK THIS THOUGH-
AND AGAIN JUST I KNOW WERE
UNDER- THE TIME HERE TO SORT OF
MOVE TO THE NEXT- ELEMENTS. OF
THE SITE HEARING BUT I WANTED
TO. UNDERSTAND JUST IN TERMS
OF. BECAUSE I'M JUST SORT OF MY
MOST RECENT BANKRUPTCY IS
DEALING WITH- PG&E. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PLAYED A
MAJOR ROLE IN THAT- ALONG WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT- TO
WHAT EXTENT. ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE'S. IT IS IT IS BEING-
PRESENTED IN THE MOST. AFFECTED
IN STRONG WAY BEFORE THE COURT-
AND SO I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW HOW INTIMATE PARK IS THE
STATE GOING TO BE WITH THE
COURT. AND ENSURING THAT WE ARE
PROTECTED. WHAT THE- THIS DOES
STATE WE IT WITH THIS
PARTICULAR ARM IN CASE THAT THE
STATE DID CONTACT WITH OUTSIDE
COUNSEL AND IS CLOSELY WORKING
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE'S INTEREST ARE ARE- BEING
ASSERTIVELY- REPRESENTED- TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
REPRESENTATION YEAH THIS IS
POSSIBLE SEE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDINGS ARE ARE CHALLENGING
IN PARTICULAR IN PARTICULAR
WITH RESPECT TO ENSURING THAT-
THESE TYPES OF. SITUATIONS ARE
ARE ADEQUATELY PROTECTED BUT
NEVERTHELESS- IN ADDITION TO.
YOU KNOW THE NGO WE HAVE
CONTRACT WITH OUTSIDE COUNSEL.
OKAY AND IS THERE. SOME
INTERACTION THAT IS CONTINUING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IS THERE ARE-
INTERACTION WITH- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WITH ACCOUNT
COMMITTEE THIS COMMITTEE OR
OTHERS TO TRY TO KEEP THE IS
HOW HOW DO WE STAY CONNECTED TO
THE PROGRESS. THAT'S TAKING
PLACE IN THIS THESE
NEGOTIATIONS AND WHAT THE COURT.
WELL I SAID I WILL SAY THAT YOU
KNOW AS AS COURT PROCEEDINGS
HAVE COME UP WE'VE BEEN IN
DIRECT COMMUNICATION WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO NOTIFY
THEIR MEMBERS OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT INTO
THE PROCESS WHEN APPROPRIATE.
SO I THINK WE'VE BEEN IN IN IN
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION WITH.
LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF THE
CURRENT PROGRESS AND STATUS.
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN R. LET ME
TURN TO YOU ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
IN TERMS OF THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU'RE GETTING AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BANKRUPTCY AND-
OUR CLARITY OF PARTICIPATION
AND FEEDBACK THAT IS. GIVING
YOU CONFIDENCE THAT THE STATE
IS. ENGAGING IN A VERY
AGGRESSIVE WAY ON BEHALF OF
THE- TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK RESTORED AND I KNOW THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS OUT
FOLLOWING THIS CASE AS WELL AS
A U. S. ATTORNEY AS WELL-
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WAS A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS- THAT EXCITED MUST
MEET. IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
PROCEED OUT FROM THOSE
PROCEEDINGS- COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO BUT NOW THAT THE BANKRUPTCY
IS HERE I KNOW THAT EACH OF THE
ATTORNEYS BUT THAT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THE STATE LEVEL
REEVALUATING. AND SO WERE-
TAKING THAT IN STRIDE AS WELL-
AND TAKING- TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ATTORNEYS
ARE GOING TO DO BECAUSE I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THOSE
CHARGED WITH FELONY CHARGES.
AND SOME OF THOSE CHARGES WERE
DROPPED- IN RESPONSE EXIDE
MITIGATING. SOME OF THESE
PROPERTIES IF THEY ARE UNABLE
TO MEET THEIR COMMITMENTS AND-
WE'LL SEE WHAT THAT MEANS THE
COURTS AS WELL AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WILL IN THIS CASE.
WHAT THE WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS I KNOW WE
HAVE SENATOR DRAWS OVER ONCE
ASK NUMBER OF QUESTIONS AS LONG
ALONG WITH US SENATOR ALAN. SO
LET'S FIRST BEGIN WITH SENATOR
DRAW SO PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR. I JUST WANNA ASK I
AND I APPRECIATE DR UP
WILLIAMS- REFERRING TO DECISION
MAKERS ARE DECISIONS THAT NEED
TO BE MADE BY THE- BY THE
DEPARTMENT- YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THIS SPECIFICALLY-
BUT I DO THINK THAT DECISION
MAKERS NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS AND I HOPE THAT
YOU HAVE MADE AN EVALUATION OF
WHO SHOULD STAY AND WHO SHOULD
NOT STAY. IN THAT DEPARTMENT AS
FAR AS DECISION MAKERS- I AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
WE JUST CAN'T KEEP LETTING THIS
GO ON AND ON AND ON SO ONE I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO THAT
AND MAKE THOSE CHANGES IN
MANAGEMENT- SECOND I KNOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA ASKED UP
A NUMBER OF SEPARATE- QUESTIONS
THAT WE COULD FOLLOW UP ON FROM
YOU- BUT I THINK OF THE-
AUDITOR OF MENTIONED- NOT
HAVING. A PLAN OR A STRATEGY TO
MOVE FORWARD ON DIFFERENT
ISSUES SUCH AS THE COSTS ON
PRIORITIES AND THE SCHEDULE SO
CAN WE EXPECT OUT OF NOT A
SERIES OF ANSWERS BUT ACTUALLY
A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN AS TO HOW
YOU MOVE FORWARD- FROM YOU AND
INCLUDED. IN THAT IS SOME. I
NOT FOR. THE BUDGET TO HEAR
BUDGET TO TELL YOU HERE'S A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY WE NEED
FROM YOU IS OPTIONS AND
POSSIBILITIES OF. THIS MUCH
MONEY WILL DO THIS IN CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME OR THIS OPTION
THIS IS ANOTHER OPTION SO I
WOULD NEED THAT AND EXPECT
THAT. FROM YOU TO PROVIDE THAT
AND THEN LAST RELATED TO THE-
BANKRUPTCY- I KNOW THAT SOME OF
US HAVE BEEN IN. VERY REGULAR
REPORTS BACK FROM THE AG THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON AND
THEY'VE BEEN VERY GOOD ABOUT-
PROVIDING UPDATES FOR US AND
YOU KEEPING US INVOLVED- BUT-
WITH REGARDS TO THAT- IN TERMS
OF THE CLEAN UP PROCESS HOW DO
YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING. WEAPON
REALLY APPOINTED- IT'S CALLED
EXIDE BRING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
RESPONSE TRUST AND THE TRUSTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU-
MISS WILLIAMS IF YOU WILL. WHO
ARE ONLY TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE
FIRST TWO PARTS OF HER OF-
DECEMBER MEMBERS QUESTIONS-
THAT IS TO SAY THAT WITH
RESPECT TO DECISION MAKERS ARE
YOU OUR ENTIRE EXECUTIVE TEAM
TALKS REGULARLY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING STRONG
TIMELY DECISIONS THAT ARE
PROTECTED AND A SPECIALLY
PROTECTED TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE. WITH RESPECT TO. THE AS
AND PLANNING FOR FUTURE
ADDITIONAL CLEAN UP I THINK
I'VE SPOKEN TO THAT YOU DO YOU
ESTIMATES WILL CONTINUE TO DO
ESTIMATES BUT AGAIN I DON'T
THINK WE'LL PUT YOU WE CAN
GUARANTEE A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
UNTIL WE HAVE. GIVEN A GREAT
DEGREE OF UNCERTAINTY IN THE
STATE RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF THE
FISCAL SITUATION BUT WE WILL
HAVE INFORMATION AS NEEDED- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. AND THEN- WITH
RESPECT TO THE TRUSTEE FROM THE
TRUSTEE ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE STATE WAS SO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE POSIBLE BANKRUPTCY
WHAT'S THAT. C. LAW ALLOWS
RESPONSIBLE TO ABANDON
PROPERTIES AND THEY CAN WALK
AWAY AND THE PROPERTY CAN BE
COMPLETELY. UNPROTECTED IT CAN
BE DIFFICULT TO MANAGE- TO KEEP
SAFE TO SELL IF BUT WHEN THE
MOMENT COMES. AND NOW THAT WE
HAVE A TRUSTEE IN PLACE- THAT
TRUSTEE HAS JUST PICKED UP ALL
OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
EXCITE HATS SO- THEY THEY HAVE
RESPONSIVE WE HAD. SOME
QUESTIONS WEEKEND TWO WEEKENDS
AGO AND EVER SINCE THE- VERY
RESPOND WELL AND THEY ARE USING
THE FINANCIAL ASSURANCE FUNDS
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. ON
THE CLEAN UP OF THE FACILITY
ITSELF. AND THE TO THE TRI-
ALSO ASKED THE TRUSTEE FOR HIS
PLAN FOR COMMUNICATING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND KEEPING YOU AND
TO THE COMMUNITY UP TO DATE ON
ANY- PROGRESS AT THE FACILITY.
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU- I DON'T
KNOW IF THOSE FOLLOW UPS FROM
SENATOR BROWSERS THAT WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO SENATOR
ALAN. HI THERE- THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS. I'M I GUESS I WANTED WHAT
I'D LIKE TO KNOW IS I KNOW I
KNOW THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
IDEA HERE BUT I'M INTERESTED IN
YOU KNOW THIS PRODUCT QUESTION
THAT YOU JUST RAISE WHICH IS
THAT YOU KNOW BASICALLY THE
BANKRUPTCY WE'RE WE'RE STUCK
HOLDING THE BAG HERE AND-
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK ON IT
LEGISLATION AND WE'RE GONNA
SPEND SOME TIME. LOOKING AT BUT
I'M- FORTUNATE WE- ARE CAN WE
JUST TALK- DO YOU HAVE ANSWERS
TO THE KINDS OF COSTS THE
STATE'S GOING TO LIKELY BE
STUCK WITH HERE. YOU KNOW BOTH
RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP IN THE
ACTUAL SITE CLEAN UP LIKE WE
HAVE. TO HAVE ESTIMATES AS TO
WHAT. AS TO WHAT COSTS- THE
STATE OR NOT IS NOW ON THE HOOK.
BOB FOR. YOU JUST HAVE TO THE
RESIDENTS PROPERTY THINK WE'VE
SPOKEN TO YOU TIMES BUT I AM
GOING TO LET DEPUTY DIRECTOR
GRANT CALLED TALK ABOUT THE
FACILITY CLEAN UP COSTS. YEAH.
I'M SO AN INSERT YOUR QUESTION
CENTER ALLEN WE'VE GOT TWENTY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN FINANCIAL ASSURANCE THAT WE
WILL USE TO BOTH CONTINUE WHAT
IS PHASE ONE OF CLOSURE THAT'S
WHERE YOU TAKE THE BUILDINGS
THAT ARE REGULATED UNDER
HAZARDOUS WASTE LAWS. AND
DEMOLISHES BRING THEM DOWN TO
GROUND LEVEL. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH THE VERNE
ENVIRONMENTAL TRUST TO DO OTHER
WORK ONSITE USING THAT
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE RISKS
THAT WE CAN USING THOSE FUNDS.
SO THINK ABOUT SPRING WATER TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT DOES DOESN'T
BELONG AROUND PAVING AREAS TO
MAKE CERTAIN THE DUST- IS MORE-
HELD IN A WAY THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO AUTOMATICALLY MAINTAIN
IT EVERY DAY. BUT THEN ALSO
WORKING WITH THE OTHER
BUILDINGS THAT CONTAIN LEAD. TO
CLOSE OUT. OR REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF LEAD THAT COULD LEAD FROM
THOSE BUILDINGS. WE'RE GONNA
USE EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE HAVE.
TO UNDERTAKE EVERY ACTIVITY
THAT'S NEEDED. TO ADDRESS AS
MANY OF THE MEDIA AS WE CAN.
OKAY I'M- SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
STARTING THAT PROCESS IS THAT
IS THAT UNDER WAY NOW. IT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR A WHILE EXIDE
DISCONTINUED CLOSURE OPERATIONS
WHEN PADDOCK KEPT. AB SO BACK
IN MARCH WE ORDERED THEM TO
RESTART ACTIVITIES BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T AGREE THAT THEY COULDN'T%
UNDERTAKE THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE
BEING UNDERTAKEN AT DIFFERENT
FACILITIES AROUND THE STATE.
EXIDE BASICALLY REFUSED TO
UNDERTAKE THOSE ACTIVITIES
UNTIL THEY WENT BANKRUPT NOW
WE'RE DOING IS WORKING WITH A
TRUST TO RESTART ALL THOSE
TYPES OF COMMUNITIES ON SITE.
OKAY AND YOU'RE AND YOU'RE ALSO.
IS THERE IS THERE IS THE CURING
PROCESS THAT DID YOU UNDERGO
NOW TO YOU. IN ADDITION A CLEAN
UP- SO SITE SECURITY.
SPECIFICALLY WELL JUST SECURING
WANTED TO. I GUESS THE STEPS
YOU HAVE TO TAKE TO JUST MAKE
SURE THERE'S NOT GONNA BE
ADDITIONAL DAMAGE TO THE LOCAL
NEIGHBORHOODS YEAH THE SAKE
ABSOLUTELY- WHAT THAT SO LET ME
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF THE
OTHER BUILDINGS ON SITE THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY PERMITTED
BUT THAT CONTAIN HIGH LEVELS.
OF HAZARDOUS WASTE. WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE'VE WORKED WITH THE
VERNE ENVIRONMENT TRUST THE
TRUSTEE. SPECIFICALLY TO SAY
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN. FOR
MITIGATING THE RISKS AND THOSE
BUILDINGS AND WE NEED IT NOW
AND IT IS PARTNER FIRST ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT BUDGET. SO
WE HAD TO GO BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD. INCLUDE THOSE
ACTIVITIES IN THE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY BUDGET. AND I RECEIVED
AN UPDATED DRAFT OF THAT THIS
MORNING AND PORTHLEVEN AT A
CHANCE TO REVIEW IT BUT WE'RE
WORKING WITH USEPA WHO'S
TECHNICALLY AGENCY STILL UNDER
THE BANKRUPTCY AGREEMENT. AND
THE RURAL AND OF THE FIRM AND
VIRAL TRUSTEE TO INCLUDE THOSE
TYPES OF ACTIONS THAT ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIATE RISKS. TO THE
EXTENT WE HAVE RESOURCES. OKAY
I'M- I THINK I'M MORE MORE
BROADLY DO YOU THINK WE'VE AND
NEEDS FOR YOUR FROM PARIS RIGHT
BUT OUR OUR WILL WHAT ARE WE
DOING I MEAN WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO MAKE SURE THIS KIND IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN I MEAN
WHAT WE KNOW WITHIN THE- WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT. YEAH. SO- I
HAVE A PHRASE THAT MY STAFF
GETS REALLY TIRED OF HEARING
ABOUT WHICH IS BAD NEWS IS GOOD
NEWS AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT IF YOU KNOW WHAT WENT
WRONG IT GIVES YOU THE ABILITY
TO FOCUS IN ON WHAT WENT WRONG
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO AVOID IN
THE FUTURE AND SO WE HAVE DONE
A LOT FOR POST MORTEM ON EXIDE.
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
LOOKED AT YOU KNOW WHAT WAS IT
ABOUT OUR CURRENT PROCESS THAT
DIDN'T ALLOW US TO MAKE THAT
PERMIT DECISION IF WE HAD HAD A
PERMANENT PLACE WHAT
PROTECTIONS WITHOUT PERMIT
NEEDED TO HAVE- WE NOW HAVE
WHAT WE CALL THE VIOLATIONS
SCORING PROCEDURE WHICH GIVES
EVERYONE THE VISIBILITY OF HOW
WELL FACILITIES AROUND THE
STATE PERMITTED FACILITIES ARE
COMPLYING WITH HAZARDOUS WASTE
LAWS WE ISSUE A SCORECARD EVERY
SEPTEMBER. AND THAT COULD BE
BASED ON THAT SCORE WE EITHER A
SIGN OF FACILITY AND
UNACCEPTABLE SCORE
CONDITIONALLY ACCEPTABLE SCORE
OR AN ACCEPTABLE SCORE AND THAT
MEANS THAT IF YOU FOR THEIR
ACCEPTABLE THEY CAN CONTINUE
OPERATIONS IF THEY'RE
CONDITIONALLY ACCEPTABLE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PUT ON
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS SO FOR
INSTANCE WE CAN SAY W'RE GOING
TO INSPECT THEM MORE FREQUENTLY
WE CAN REQUIRE THAT WE REVIEW
THEIR FINANCIAL ASSURANCE MORE
FREQUENTLY OR WHATEVER OTHER
CONDITIONS WE THINK WE NEED TO
PUT IN PLACE. IF SOMETIMES IF A
FACILITY IS IN THE-
UNACCEPTABLE TEAR WE BEGAN
AFTER THE DISPUTE PROCESS AND
ANY THERE'S A DISPUTE PROCESS
FOR INDIVIDUAL INSPECTION
SCORES AND THEN ON UP TO A
DISPUTE PROCESS FOR WHAT WE
CALL THE TIER ASSIGNMENT AND
ONCE THAT PROCESS IS THROUGH IT
PUTS US IN A POSITION TO BEGIN
REVOKING- REVOKING THE PERMIT
FOR ANY FACILITY THAT LANDS IN
pTHAT CATEGORY SO THIS IS A NEW
TOOL FOR US- AND BUT ULTIMATELY
I THINK THE PERMIT GETTING THE
PERMIT DECISIONS MADE. THAT
REFLECT. WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
CURRENT COPY RATIONS OF THE- WE
HAVE SOME- PERMITS AND- THE OF
THOSE. WERE WRITTEN IN A WAY
THAT MAY NOT RISK HOW THAT JUST.
ARE TODAY'S WE NEED TO KIND TO
GET. DECISIONS WE HAVE IN OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN- COMMITMENT TO
MAKE ALL OF OUR PERMIT
DECISIONS OR 90% OF OUR PERMIT
DECISIONS WITHIN TWO YEARS OF
RECEIPT OF AN ACCEPTABLE
PERMIT. SO ONCE THEY GIVE US A-
REPUBLICATION THAT'S COME
ADMINISTRATIVELY COMPLETE WE
COMMIT TO A TWO YEAR TIME WORK
TIME FRAME TO GETTING THAT
PERMIT DECISION MADE SO THAT
FACILITIES ARE OPERATING ON OUT
OF BASED ON HOW TO DATE
UNDERSTANDING. OF THOSE- OF HOW
THERE THEY WORK BUT THAT ALSO
THEN GIVES US VERY WERE MUCH
CLEARER AND HOW WE WRITE OUR
PERMIT WE'VE HAD A PERMIT
ENFORCEMENT OR PERMIT
ENHANCEMENT WORK PLAN. SO THAT
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL CHECKLISTS
WE HAVE WE'VE CHANGED OUR
INSPECTORS ARE TRAINED WE
ROTATE THEM THROUGH DIFFERENT
FACILITIES SO THAT THEY DON'T
GET STALE BY GOING. GOING TO A
FACILITY AND SEEING THE SAME
THINGS TIME AND WE MIX IT UP WE
CROSS TRAIN WE STRENGTHEN OUR
PRESS ONE FORSMAN AND ACTUALLY
THAT'S A BIG AREA OF FOCUS. NOT
JUST FOR DGSE BUT FOR KELLY P.
AS A WHOLE- SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE THINGS WE'RE DOING AND
THEN I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT FINANCIAL
ASSURANCE AGAIN THERE WERE
PROVISIONS IN NINE NINE FIVE.
THAT WERE WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION BUT THERE MAY BE
THINGS WE CAN GO BEYOND THAT
WE'RE REALITY CHECKING SOME OF
OUR FINANCIAL ASSURANCE BY
VALIDATING HOW MUCH IT REALLY
TAKES TO CLEAN P A FACILITY
VERSUS HOW MUCH WE HAD TO YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH HER CALCULATOR
SAYS IT SHOULD COST. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING GOOD
ESTIMATES I COULD GO WHICH YEAH
OKAY- OUR- SO IS THAT ALL THAT
GOOD I WOULD WHAT I WANT IT I
STILL TO GLAD I GUESS ON A
DRILLING ON ITS THIS WHOLE.
QUESTION OF LIABILITY- TO STATE
SO WE ARE SOME OF THE SO DO WE
KNOW. SITE CLEAN UP COSTS I
WILL NOT BE. BY THE SETTLEMENT
MONEY. A LOT. RIGHT CAN WE ONLY
HAVE TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. IN FINANCIAL ASSURANCE
AND THEN TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
FROM THE SETTLEMENT ITSELF. AND
YOU KNOW THE FACILITY COSTS
WILL BE UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED. A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SO
THAT'S- SO AGAIN. YEAH SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT- OVER SEVENTY
MILLION THAT THAT THE STATE IS
ON THE HOOK FOR BASICALLY. OKAY
SO I GUESS I GUESS. SO
EVERYTHING YOU TALKED ABOUT
THESE- CERTAINLY GONNA BE
HELPFUL- I IT DOES MAKE ME
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE MAY BE
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T GET HOSED IN ANY FUTURE
BANKRUPTCIES WON'T NEED ARE WE
LOOKING AT TRYING TO BE
CONSIDERED A SECURE CREDITOR SO
WE GET CLOSER TO THE FRONT LINE
FOR CLEANUP REIMBURSEMENT-
SECOND THING SO. I LEARNED A
LOT AND WE ALL LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT BANKRUPTCY THROUGH
THROUGH THIS PROCESS NUMBER ONE
HOW FAST IT MOVES AND NUMBER
TWO WHO GETS TO THE FRONT OF
THE LINE AND IT IS QUITE
FRANKLY IT'S ALARMING WHO IS
CONSIDERED A SECURED CREDITOR
AND HOW THEY GET THAT STATUS
AND ARE THERE IS A PRECEDENT
KNOWN AS MID ATLANTIC. WHICH
SHE DOES SAY THAT THEY'RE JUST
SO BAD OWNERS ARE ALLOWED TO
ABANDON THEIR PROPERTIES AND
THAT THAT PROVISION IN THIS
LAND OF PRECEDENT HAS BEEN USED
IN INTERPRETED BY THE COURTS TO
WELL IT TO YOU KNOW TO PUT A
VERY NARROW WINDOW FOR- STOOD
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION-
IN THE IN PLACE DURING THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING SO. I
THINK THE BANKRUPTCY IS IT IS
AN AREA OF OPPORTUNITY WILL
TAKE LEGAL STRATEGY IT WOULD
TAKE- ALL OF A LOT OF ANALYSIS
BUT I DO THINK THAT THERE WILL
CONTINUE ESPECIALLY COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC IT'S POSSIBLE
THERE ARE VULNERABILITIES.
AROUND BANKRUPTCY. ALL RIGHT
NOW WITH THAT SEVERAL LET ME
JUST REMIND YOU THAT WE HAVE TO
BE OUT OF THIS FOR BY TWO
THIRTY. SO NOW IF YOU HAVEN'T.
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW HOW.
THANK YOU MISS. THANK YOU
MATTER. MISTER CHAIRMAN HOW DO
YOU GET RECOGNIZED ON THIS
THING. MR VOEPEL THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. WE DO HAVE A NEW
PEOPLE BEEN TEXTING ME REMOTELY
IF MEMBERS WANT TO HAVE
QUESTIONS IF NOT YOU LET THE
SERGEANTS KNOWN SERGEANTS WILL
MAKE SURE WE GET YOU IN THE
QUEUE AS WELL- BUT SINCE WE
HAVE YOU ON THE LINE GOOD ASK
YOUR QUESTION MR VOEPEL. WELL
MY QUESTION IS I GOT THIS BRAND
NEW MACHINE SITTING HERE ON MY
DESK WHICH I DON'T REALLY KNOW
HOW TO OPERATE- WHAT WE'RE
DOING THESE COMMITTEE MEETINGS
THIS WAY. YES SPEAK UP. I DON'T
EVEN HAVE YOUR PHONE NUMBER
STAFF JUST GAVE ME THIS. SO I'M
NOT QUITE SURE FOR HOUSEKEEPING
PURPOSES. HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO DO THESE TYPES OF COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. K. THANK YOU MR
VOEPEL YEAH I BELIEVE-
EVERYBODY ON THE COMMITTEE WAS
PROVIDED NUMBERS FOR NOT ONLY
LOGGING IN REMOTELY BUT ALSO
CONTACTING SERGEANTS IF- YOU
NEED TO GET A HOLD OF US OR TO
GET IN THE QUEUE- BUT WITH THAT
LET ME ASK IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL MR
VOEPEL IF NOT WE'LL MOVE TO
SENATOR GONZALEZ I'M GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'LL GO BACK ON
MUTE AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
THIS. MACHINE THANK THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE TO SENATOR GONZALEZ THANK
YOU SALAS THIS CONVERSATION AND
THANK YOU DIRECT PARTNER- I.
ALSO WANT TO LET MY COMMENTS
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JUST ON
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL I KNOW
WHAT'S- ALL. REMEDIES POSSIBLE
I KNOW WE- GOT THROUGH IT THE
HUGE HURDLE WELL NOT. BUT
THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY- AND
ALSO WITH THE CONTRACTS WHICH I
FEEL VERY EASY ABOUT- YOU KNOW
I KNOW- WE ARE WORKING THROUGH
THAT MOVING FORWARD BUT IT JUST
SEEMS THAT- THE CONTRACTOR
SITUATION SEEM TO BE. YOU KNOW
VERY UNSETTLING FOR ME-
PARTICULARLY- THE ONE QUESTION
I DO HAVE IS ABOUT THE- NO
PERMISSION TO SAMPLE CLEAN
THERE'S ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTEEN UP PROPERTIES THAT HAVE
DEFINED CLEAN UP THREE OF WHICH
I BELIEVE ARE DAY CARES AND
SCHOOLS. I KNOW THAT WAS
TOUCHED ON A BIT CAN YOU GIVE
ME MORE INFORMATION ON- WHAT
THAT PROCESS WOULD LOOK. LIKE-
YEAH. SO I SAID WE DO. GOOD OF
FORTY TWO ABLE TO HELP UP AND
I'M GOING TO LET DEPUTY. CALL
SPEAK. TO I SAID I GONZALEZ. WE
ARE- IT OF LOS. POSITION RIGHT
NOW WITH PROPERTY OWNERS. WE
NEED- FORTY TO GO ONTO THEIR
PROPERTY NEXT TO SAMPLING. AND
WE NEED TO WORK WITH THEM TO DO
SCHEDULING WHEN WE WANTED TO
CLEAN HOUSE- YOU'RE ACTUALLY
RIGHT SOME PEOPLE THAT- DENIES
THE ABILITY TO GO UNDER THE
PROPERTY. YOU SAMPLING WORKS.
BUT THERE'S A PARTICULAR IF YOU
WANT TO WORK WITH THEM THEY'RE
NOT OF THE BUSINESS SO- WITH.
ASSEMBLY WERE TRYING WORK WITH
THEM WE'RE KIND OF BENDING OVER.
IF AT SOME POINT THEY CONTINUE
TO SAY NO. WE CAN ISSUE AN
ORDER. THAT SAYS WE'RE COMING
ON YOUR PROPERTY WORK OUT A
PLAN. AND THEN WE WILL ENFORCE
THAT PLAN ON YOUR PROPERTY YOU
WOULD STILL ENDEAVOR TO WORK
WITH THE PROPERTY OWNERS IN AND
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THE BUSINESS.
BECAUSE THAT IS OUR LIFE. BUT
WE WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
ALL THE WORK IS NEEDED ON THOSE
PROPERTIES IS COMPLETED. THANK
YOU AND I JUST HAVE ONE FOLLOW
UP- COMMENT- IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR IS. ASK FOR ABOUT THE
COUPLE CLEAN UP AND I. FOR
ADDRESSING THAT THERE WAS A
CLEAN UP I GUESS IN OMAHA BUT
IT A SEVENTEEN YEAR- I DON'T
KNOW THAT MESSAGING IS
SOMETHING THE PUBLIC WANTS TO
HEAR RIGHT IS THAT WORK FASTER
THAN SOMETHING THAT TOOK.
ANOTHER LOCATION THAT TOOK
SEVENTEEN YEARS- AND FOR THE
AUDIT IT ALSO MENTIONS THAT THE
DETAILS HE DID NOT QUITE
PROVIDE ANY EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
SEARCH METHODS HE DIED. SO A
MESSAGING VERY. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO THAT GREAT BUT I JUST I
THINK THAT THERE'S- A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF TALK TRACK WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC
YEAH. THE WAY THAT I DESCRIBE
THIS IS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
WE'VE CLEANED UP MORE
PROPERTIES MORE QUICK QUICKLY
THAN ANY OTHER RESIDENTIAL LET
CLEAN UP IN THE NATION. IT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING PERFECTLY WE LEARN
FROM MY MISTAKES THAT IS PART
OF WHY. WHAT WE WANNA DO IS USE
EVERY DOLLAR THAT'S PROVIDED TO
US AS EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE
TO CLEAN UP AS MANY PROPERTIES
AS POSSIBLE. AND WE WILL DO
THAT EVERY DAY THAT WE ARE. WE
ARE IN THIS POSITION. OKAY WITH
THAT THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ
FOR THOSE QUESTIONS- LET ME
ASK- THE DEPARTMENT- OF- TALK
SUBSTANCE CONTROL MISS WILLIAMS
IF YOU HAVE ANY CONCLUDING
REMARKS I KNOW WE ARE RUNNING
BEHIND SCHEDULE. IN WHICH CASE
WE'LL JUST SAY WE THANK YOU WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
QUESTIONS TODAY FOR THE
ATTENTIONS OF THE LATTER THANK
YOUNG. FOR GIVING US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE CAN DO BETTER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
UPDATE. THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT
OUR PROGRESS ON THIS IMPORTANT
CLEAN UP THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT AND I AM I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO REMAIN AVAILABLE
FOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AFTER
NEXT PANELS. AND PERHAPS SOME
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS WOULD
APPRECIATE- YOU STICKING AROUND
IN CASE SIR DISTILL QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE DIETS ARE
REMOTELY. BUT APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
SAID- DEAR TO A LOT OF. A LOT
OF MEMBERS AND CLEANING UP
THESE COMMUNITIES FOR. FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFFECTED SO
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS COMMON SENSE
PERSPECTIVE- WE HAVE- HILDA
SOLIS COUNTY SUPERVISOR FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE ANGRY
BROSTROM ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND I JEAN-WILLIAMS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES AGAINST
TOICS IT WAS GOOD TO GO IN A
GENDER ORDER WE CAN HAVE A
SUPERVISOR. SO LEASE- BEGIN
PLACE. WHO IS- TESTIFYING- VIA
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS. YES
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING- CHAIR
SALAS TO THE- JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIAL- COMMITTEE I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE GRATITUDE TO
MY FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE FOR
CONTINUING TO HOLD THESE VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEARINGS ON
THE EXIDE RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP
I ALSO WANT TO THANK IN
PARTICULAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR PRESSING HARD FOR
THE AUDIT. OF THE TNCS CLEANUP
OF THE RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
IMPACTED BY EXIDE INCLUDING ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE THAT SUPPORTED THAT
EFFORT I WANT I WENT UP TO
SACRAMENTO EARLIER THIS YEAR TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT
AND APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY IN ANSWERS
TO OUR COMMUNITIES WERE STILL
WAITING FOR THE COMPLETE
CLEANUP IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE THAT
THE STATE TAKE EVERY MEASURE
POSSIBLE AND USE EVERY TOOL AT
ITS DISPOSAL TO EXPEDITE THE
CLEANUP OF ALL PROPERTIES
CONTAMINATED BY EXIDE THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT HAS VALIDATED
THE CONCERNS MANY OF US HAVE
HAD ABOUT THE PACE OF THE
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP AND HOW
DTIC IS SPENDING THIS ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF PUBLIC RESOURCES
DEDICATED TO THE CLEAN UP. THE
PACE OF THE CLEAN UP OF THE
HOMES NEAR EXIDE IN MY OPINION
IS UNACCEPTABLE IS TAKING TOO
LONG AND I URGE THE STATE TO
IMPLEMENT THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS WITHOUT DELAY
AND I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AND
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR A FEW OF
THE KEY AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS
FIRST THE AUDIT REPORT
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFIES
MEASURES TO HELP CONTROL THE
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP COSTS. AND
AVOID CONTINUING FUTURE COST
OVERRUNS SOMETHING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE MEASURES
MUST BE IMPLEMENTED AND DTS C.
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO REPORT
BACK TO THE LEDGE OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON ITS PROGRESS
REGULARLY PREFER BILLY ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS SECOND THE PACE
OF THE CLEAN UP MUST BE
INCREASED WHILE I'M PLEASE IS
IT OVER TWO THOUSAND
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES. HAVE
BEEN CLEANED UP TO DATE THE
PACE IS ENTIRELY TOO SLOW. THE
LONGER THE CLEAN UP TAKES THE
LONGER COMMUNITIES WILL
CONTINUE TO BE EXPOSED TO THE
DAMAGING EFFECTS OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION. AND YES MORE
CONTRACTORS MORE CREWS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE NEEDED AND A
GREATER URGENCY MUST BE
DEMONSTRATED BY D. T. S. C. IN
FACT IMPROVING UPON THEIR
CONTRACTING CAPABILITIES. AND I
KNOW THAT SOON SO WE ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC THERE ARE
MANY MANY OF FOLKS IT REPRESENT
OUR CONSTRUCTION AND BUILDING
TRADES INDUSTRY THAT WOULD JUST
BE HAPPY TO HELP US IN THIS
ENDEAVOR. AS THE AUDITOR
SUGGESTED DTS CEBU'S BE
COMPELLED TO PICK UP THE PACE
OF ITS WORK CLEAN UP PUBLISH A
SCHEDULE OF WORK AND BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT SCHEDULE.
IN FACT I WOULD GO A STEP
FURTHER AND STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THAT THE GOVERNOR CREATE A
STRIKE TEAM TO OVERSEE THE
CLEANUP AND ADVISE THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ACTIONS. THAT
NEED TO BE TAKEN TO SPEED THIS
UP. I WANT TO ALSO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS PREVIOUS
SUPPORT OF A CENTRAL FUNDS TO
HELP US CLEAN UP THESE
RESIDENTIAL AREAS BUT THE TSC
HAS HAD PLENTY OF TIME TO GET
IT RIGHT. AND IF ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT IS NEEDED I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE STATE WOULD PUT
THAT. THOSE MECHANISMS IN PLACE
AND THIRD THE COMMUNITY
DESERVES A TIME LINE FOR
COMPLETING THE CLEANUP AND IT
MUST BE TRANSPARENT AND POSTED
IN PUBLIC VENUES FOR ALL TO
SEE. THECOMMUNITIES IMPACTED
BY EXCISE CONTAMINATION AS YOU
KNOW HAVE SUFFER FOR FAR TOO
LONG. AND THAT'S WHY I FULLY
SUPPORT THE AUDIT'S
RECOMMENDATION. THEY BY NO
LATER THAN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DTIC MUST IDENTIFY AND
PUBLICIZE THE DATE BY WHICH IT
EXPECTS TO COMPLETE ITS CLEANUP
OF ALL SEVEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES. FINALLY AND
IMPORTANTLY FUNDS MUST BE
IDENTIFIED FOR THE CLEANUP OF
ALL RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
CONTAMINATED BY EXCISE. IN
LIGHT OF X. SITE BANKRUPTCY AND
LIQUID. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
DTS C. AND THE STATE IDENTIFY
OTHER SUFFICIENT SOURCES OF
FUNDING TO COMPLETE THIS
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP. WHETHER
THOSE PROCEEDS FROM THE BATTERY
TAXACT LOANS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND OR OTHER MEANS THE STATE
NEEDS TO STEP IN TO COMPLETE
THE IMPORTANT WORK WITHOUT
FURTHER DELAY. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE OF CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE NEW
INCOMING BLIGHTED
ADMINISTRATION TO FURTHER
INVESTIGATE AND TO SUPPORT OUR
EFFORTS THROUGH EPA AND DOJ. ON
THIS POINT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADD A RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
STATE LOOK INTO ESTABLISHING A
FUN. FOR THE COMPLETE CLEANUP
OF SITES LIKE EXIDE PERHAPS
SIMILAR TO THE FEDERAL
SUPERFUND TRUST FUND WHICH
RECEIVES APPROPRIATION ANNUALLY
FROM THE CONGRESS A RELIABLE
FUNDING SOURCES NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT THE CLEANUP OF THE
SITES. CAN BE COMPLETED
ESPECIALLY WHEN THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CLEAN UP OR
NOT HELD FULLY ACCOUNTABLE AS
HAS BEEN THE CASE HERE WITH
EXCITED. AND ADDITIONALLY D.
TSC NEEDS TO PRESS FORWARD ON
THE STALLED CLEANUP IN THE
PARKWAY PROPERTIES ADJACENT TO
THE RESIDENCES SO THAT ALL
PARTS OF THE RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES. ARE THOROUGHLY
CLEANED CONCURRENTLY AND
EFFICIENTLY MOVING FORWARD.
DGSE HAS INDICATED IT DOES NOT
HAVE FUNDING FOR THE PARKWAY
CLEAN UP. AND TODAY I URGE THE
STATE TO FIND OUT FUNDING BY
CLEANING UP THE PARK WAYS WE
CAN ASSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND THIS CLEAN UP
ARE DONE THOROUGHLY AND
COMPLETE AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO RESPECTFULLY RECOMMEND THAT
THE STATE LEGISLATURE REVISIT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
IS BILL. AB NINE NINE FIVE.
WHICH WOULD HAVE PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT TO D. SC.
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR VETOED AB
NINE NINE FIVE I TRUST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL TRULY
SAFEGUARD. THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND ENSURE A- SITES ARE CLEANED
UP. IN CONCLUSION AND FINALLY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REMAINS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
T. S. C. TO HELP EXPEDITE THIS
CLEAN UP. COUNTY STAFF
INCLUDING MY OFFICE CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE IN MONTHLY
COORDINATION BECAUSE WITH THE
T. S. C. REGARDING THE X. I
CLEAN UP. BUT I THINK THIS HAS
TO BE DONE MORE REGULARLY AND I
WOULD ASK THAT. SOME OF OUR
DEPARTMENT ALL ALSO BE MOURNED
GAUGE SOME HAVE BUT I WOULD
THINK THE FOLLOW UP COULD HELP
FACILITATE EVEN MORE.
INFORMATION ABOUT CLEAN UP WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO HELP THAT AND
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. THE COUNTY
HAS WORKED TO EXPEDITE THE
PERMITTING. PROCESS RELATED TO
THE CLEANUP INCLUDING WAVING AT
EVEN REDUCING PERMIT FEES AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT. THE
COUNTY IS ALSO OBTAIN FUNDING
FOR LEAD PAINT HAZARD ABATEMENT
IN APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY HOMES NEAR EXIDE BUT
YOU AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH. WE HAVE HOSTED
NEARLY A HUNDRED COMMUNITY
OUTREACH EVENTS AND CONDUCTED
OVER SIX THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED.
BLOOD LEAD TESTS INCLUDING THE
TESTING OF ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED CHILDREN IN THE
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY EXIDE.
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY POLLUTION IN THEIR
FIGHT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. I WANT TO THANK THE
STATE AUDITOR FOR HER IMPORTANT
WORK I THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR CONTINUED
EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP THE LEAD
CONTAMINATION IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT WE KNOW THERE
ARE MANY MORE FACILITIES MUCH
LIKE EXCITED ANOTHER ONE THAT
IS BEING OVER OVER- BEING
MONITORED CURRENTLY. OF BY THE
DTIC IS QUITE MEDICAL IN THE
CITY OF INDUSTRY WHICH IS ALSO
PART OF THE FIRST DISTRICT.
TOGETHER WE CAN OVERCOME I
BELIEVE THESE CHALLENGES AND
DELIVER THE CLEAN UP THAT MANY
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE WAITING
FOR. ESPECIALLY THOSE HAD THAT
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES LOST
LOVED ONES OR WILL BE WILL BE
PLAGUED BY SERIOUS DISEASE AN
ILLNESS THE COMMUNITIES OF BELL
BOYLE HEIGHTS COMMERCE EAST LA
HUNTINGTON PARK. CUT HAY BURNIN
AND MAY WOULD ALL DESERVE TO BE
RESPECTED AND THEY NEED TO KNOW
WHEN A CLEANUP WILL BEGIN AND
WILL. END THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
LEE'S AND WE APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP OBVIOUSLY THIS
TAKES A LOT OF PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL STATE.
COUNTY AND LOCAL LEVELS SO
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY WITH THAT LET'S GOING TO
MOVE TO MISSILE BROSTROM.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH. IN GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AGAIN MY NAME IS IN THE
BROSTROM AND I AM ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR AT THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT. THE
LAST FOURTEEN YEARS I HAVE
WORKED WITH COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE SUFFERED AT THE HANDS OF
THE TSC. AND THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS. I HAVE ADVOCATED FOR
MEANINGFUL DGSE REFORM IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. OVER
THIS TIME I HAVE SEEN COUNTLESS
EXAMPLES OF HOW FAILURES AND
DGSE HURT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FAILURES AROUND EXIDE CANNOT BE
BOILED DOWN TO CONTRACTUAL
DISPUTES. INADEQUATE FINANCIAL
ASSURANCES OR AGENCY DELAYS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE PERMANENTLY
ALTERED LIVES OF CHILDREN
NEEDLESSLY EXPOSED TO LEAD.
LEAD POISONING IN CHILDREN
OCCURS AT VERY LOW LEVELS AND
THERE IS NO CURE FOR LEAD
POISONING ONCE A CHILD HAS BEEN
EXPOSED. IT IS PERMANENT AND AS
A LIFELONG CONSEQUENCES. TO
EXPOSE CHILD THIS AUDIT
REPRESENTS A LIFETIME OF
LEARNING DISABILITIES. A
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT AND A
DIMINISHED OPPORTUNITIES. AND
EXCITED IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
A GROWING CRISIS FACING THE
STATE. BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS
THERE ARE LIKELY MANY EXCITES
ACROSS THE STATE SPREADING
TOXICS AND POISONING OUR
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE WE
SHOULD BE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
CLINICAL THE STATE'S OTHER
BATTERY RECYCLER WHICH IS ALSO
LOCATED NEAR RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS. DDS IS ESTIMATE
OF THE NUMBER OF CONTAMINATED
SITES IN CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY THIS PAST YEAR.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN DGSE
ESTIMATED THAT THERE WEREN'T
NINE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
IDENTIFIED SITES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND NOW THE STATE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THERE ARE
LIKELY OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CONTAMINATED SITES
WAITING TO BE INVESTIGATED AND
CHARACTERIZED. A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CONTAMINATED
SITES. AND AT THE SAME TIME
FUNDING FOR CLEAN UPS HAS ALL
BUT DRIED UP. EXIDE WILL COST
THE STATE UPWARDS OF SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. DTCS ENTIRE BUDGET FOR
OTHER ORPHAN SITES IN
CALIFORNIA IS BETWEEN FOUR
FOURTEEN AND EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE STATE'S
OBLIGATIONS AT TWENTY TWO
FEDERAL SUPERFUND SITES AND
FIFTY TWO STATE OR FROM SITES
EIGHTEEN MILLION ANNUALLY TO
SPLIT AMONG SEVENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR SITES. THIS MEANS
THAT SOME SITES RECEIVE NO
CLEAN UP FUNDS. IT MEANS THAT
MANY SUSPECTED SITES DON'T GET
INVESTIGATED. IT MEANS THAT THE
SITES THAT DO RECEIVE FUNDING
HAVE TO SETTLE FOR THE CHEAPEST
CLEANUP OPTION. NOT THE BEST
OPTION. THIS PAST WEEK I
PARTICIPATED IN A PUBLIC
MEETING TO DISCUSS THE REMEDY
FOR A P. C. E. T. C. E. PLUME
IN THE MIDDLE OF DOWNTOWN
DELANO WE'RE OFFICE IS LOCATED.
DGSE CATEGORIZES THE DELANO
PLUME AS A PRIORITY ONE HEY.
DETAILS HIS TOP PRIORITY FOR
CLEAN UP DUE TO AND I QUOTE
IMMEDIATE AND ACUTE CONDITIONS
REQUIRING A TIME CRITICAL
RESPONSE. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
DGSE DISCOVER THE SITE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT OVER TWELVE
YEARS AGO. AND THEY ARE JAZZ
NOW SELECTING A REMEDY TO CLEAN
UP THE SITE. AGAIN DETAILS HIS
FAILURE TO ACT QUICKLY AND THIS
LACK OF RESOURCES HAS REAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR RESIDENTS WHO
PAY FOR THIS IN ACTION WITH
THEIR HEALTH. TO CONCLUDE DTS
IS MANDATE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE AND TO
THE PUBLIC. DGSE HAS NOT MET
THAT MANDATE AND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ARE PAYING A VERY
HIGH PRICE FOR ITS FAILURES. WE
NEED BETTER OVERSIGHT AT THE
AGENCY AND WE NEED T
SIGNIFICANTLY RAISE THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
INVESTIGATE CHARACTERIZE AND
REMEDIATE CONTAMINATED SITES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SOLUTION
REQUIRES THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND A FASHION
AND UP SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMMATIC
AND FEE REFORMS TO FIX THE TSC.
AND IF WE CAN'T DO THAT WE NEED
TO FIND DIFFERENT PATH AND A
DIFFERENT AGENCY TO MOVE US
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PRECIADO MOST ROSTRUM AND
OBVIOUSLY- MAKING SURE THAT
WERE HOLDING NOT ONLY
DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTABLE BUT
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO ASSIST COMMUNITIES ARE
AFFECTED. WITH THAT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO- JANE
WILLIAMS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
AGAINST TOXICS PLACE. OKAY
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN SALAS AND
GERMAN COURT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR FOR TO YOU
TESTIFIED TODAY- I AM JANE
WILLIAMS I ACTUALLY CHAIRED THE
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE OF THE
EXITE CAG. AND IT'S DIFFICULT
TO PUT INTO WORDS JUST HOW
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATED THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE AFFECTED
BY THIS LEAD CONTAMINATION ARE-
I THINK THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO IS DONE A GOOD JOB OF
TRYING TO PUT THAT INTO WORDS-
IT IS DIFFICULT TO UNDER
ESTIMATE EXACTLY WHAT'S AT
STAKE HERE- YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT THE POVERTY TO PRISON
PIPELINE WILL HERE WE'VE GOT
THE POISON TO PRISON PIPELINE.
IT TAKES ONLY A PEN HEAD OF
LEAD TO HAVE A CHILD EXCEED TO
SEE YOU SEE YOU BROTHER LOVERS
STANDARD AND WE HAVE CHILDREN
THAT BASICALLY HAVE A THOUSAND
PARTS PER MILLION IN THEIR
YARDS. WHICH IS BASICALLY
THEY'RE LIVING IN A HAZARDOUS
WASTE LANDFILL. WHAT HAPPENED
HERE WAS A CLASSIC
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROBLEM
WHERE- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REDLINED USE REDLINING POLICIES
TO CONCENTRATE LEAD SMELTERS IN
EAST LA. EXCITE IS NOT THE ONLY
LETS MALTER THERE'S ACTUALLY
SIX LEAD SMELTERS. IN EAST LA
AND WE HAVE DONE AN ANALYSIS
CALLED A CLEANING ANALYSIS
WHERE WE LOOK AT. OUR THE
LEVELS AS WE GO AWAY FROM
EXCITED DROPPING OFF AND THE
ANSWER IS NO THEY'RE NOT. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE EXCITED IS AT
THE CENTER AND THE OTHER OTHER
LEAD SMELTERS ARE LIKE IN A
RACE AROUND EACH- EXIDE IS TO
OUR KNOWLEDGE THE LONGEST
OPERATING THAT'S FILTER IN THE
COUNTRY. SO IT COULD BE. A
LARGE PROBLEM AND IT FRUSTRATES
ME TO NO END AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE- COMMITTEE TO NO END THAT.
THIS KEEPS THE DETAILS HE KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT THE ONE POINT
SEVEN MILES. NEAR THE THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED HOMES THE FORTY SIX
HUNDRED HOMES THE SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
IS A MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM THAN
THAT THIS IS A HUNDRED YEAR
HISTORY OF ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM
EAST LA THAT WILL MOST LIKELY
IMPACT A MILLION PEOPLE AND
SPREAD FOR SQUARE MILES. AND
THAT IS WHY WE WORKED WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISSY AND THE
SPEAKER TO PASS THE BATTERY FEE
BILL. WE HAD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING AT RESURRECTION CHURCH
ABOUT THIS TIME LAST YEAR AND
WE TALKED ABOUT THE TWO THINGS
THAT WE NEED FOR THE EXCITING
TECH TO COMMUNITIES WE NEED A
LONG TERM STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING. WHICH IS WHAT THE
BATTERY FEE BILL IS DESIGNED TO
DO. AND WE NEED A DIVORCE. WE
NEED A DIVORCE FROM DGSE. DGSE
WAS ORIGINALLY DESIGNED HIM IT
MAY INTEREST YOU AS A WASTE
MANAGEMENT AGENCY. THEY ARE NOT
A PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCY. IT
CANNOT BE MORE CLEAR. WHEN YOU
HEAR THE DIRECTOR SAID THAT
PARKING IS THE PROBLEM FOR WHY
WE CAN'T GET MORE PEOPLE INTO
DOING MORE CLEANUPS THAT THIS
AGENCY IT HAS NOT BEEN IN THE
PAST AND IT IS NOT NOW REALLY
DEDICATED ITSELF TO SOLVING
THIS PROBLEM- YOU KNOW FIRST.
THE AGENCY WE COMPLAIN THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE AUTHORITIES
WHILE YOU'RE TALKING TO THE
PERSON WHO IS IN THEIR
THIRTIETH YEAR NOW. MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN EVER INDUSTRY CAME IN
AND TRIED TO ATTACK THOSE WITH
ORTIZ. WE WERE THERE TO MEET
THAT THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY
AND THEY HAVE THE MONEY AND
THEY STILL CAN'T GET THIS DONE.
OKAY LET ME COMPARE AND
CONTRAST THIS PROBLEM WITH
ANOTHER HUGE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEM THE STATE HOUSE WHICH
IS GROUND WATER CONTAMINATION.
ESPECIALLY NOW WITH PERFORATED
COMPOUNDS- FOR OUTSIDERS STATE
WHO ARE WATCHING WHAT HE WAS
GOING ON WITH FOR NEED
COMPOUNDS IN CALIFORNIA SAY IT
WILL BE. NEXT TO CLIMATE CHANGE
THE GREATEST SINGLE
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT THE STATE
FACES WHY IS THAT BECAUSE THE
CONCENTRATIONS IN GROUNDWATER
ARE LARGE. THEY IMPACTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAY WE
USE WATER. LET'S SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING I GAVE TESTIMONY IN
MARCH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. SINCE THAT TIME THE
STATE HAS ENGAGE THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
AND REGIONAL BOARDS HAS ENGAGED
IN THE LARGEST GROUNDWATER
TESTING EFFORT IN THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY. THEY HAVE
TESTED THOUSANDS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SAMPLES HUNDREDS
OF WELLS NOW THEY'RE ISSUING
NEW ORDERS TO STEP OUT FROM
WHERE THEY FOUND CONTAMINATION
60% OF THE WORLD'S TESTED IN
THE STATE HAVE BEEN
CONTAMINATED. LET'S TALK ABOUT
JUST THE COST OF THIS PROBLEM
IN ORANGE COUNTY ALONE. IT'S
EXPECTED TO COST EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
RESTORE THE WELLS THEY HAD TO
SHUT DOWN A THIRD OF THEIR
WEALTH IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. OKAY THE WATER AGENCIES
OR THE ONE STEPPING UP TO THE
PLATE TO FUNDED FEASIBILITY
STUDIES TO FIND OF TECHNOLOGIES
TO CLEAN UP THE CONTAMINANTS
APPROPRIATELY. OKAY SO IN THE
ABSENCE OF A FEDERAL PLAN.
DURING THIS. TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF DTS SEES ACTION. THE
STATE WATER BOARD HAS ENGAGED
IN THIS INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE
PROCESS IT HAS ENGAGED WATER
AGENCIES IT IS ENGAGED AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. IT HAS A PLAN.
OKAY IT IS SEEKING FEDERAL
FUNDING IT WILL BE SEEKING
STATE FUNDING IT WILL BE
CHARGING ITS CONSUMERS FOR
WATER. NO ONE TALKS ABOUT WE'RE
GONNA LET THE COMMUNITIES KEEP
DRINKING THE CONTAMINATED WATER.
NO WE'RE SHUTTING DOWN THE
WELLS WERE ENDING THE EXPOSURE
THE CONVERSATION IN THE
EXCITING TECH TO COMMUNITIES
AND YOU STILL IN SOUTH CENTRAL
WITH THESE LET'S MELCHER'S. IS
REALLY ABOUT HOW LONG WILL WE
ALLOW THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE TO
SUFFER. AND SO. WHETHER IT'S
INCOMPETENCE WHETHER IT IS
CULTURAL WHETHER IT IS
NEGLIGENCE. LISTEN WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH FIXING THE FOUNDATIONS
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH LEAN SIX
SIGMA WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
CULTURAL TRAININGS WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH FOUR SEPARATE DIRECTORS
NOW THAT HAVE DONE SOMETHING TO
TRY TO FIX THE PROBLEMS THAT
YOU TNC. OKAY WE'RE THROWN IN
THE TOWEL. I WANT TO SHOW YOU
THAT. YOU CAN YOU SEE THIS YES
THIS IS A FILES IN MY OFFICE.
ON HERE IT SAYS YES. IN HERE IS
THE DECISION ON THE FIFTH- THIS
CASE. WHICH WAS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. IT HAPPENED ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AFTER EXCITED
SHUT DOWN. AND IT SAYS VERY
CLEARLY RECRUITERS VERSUS TECH
COMINCO METALS. IT HELD AT
DISPOSAL IN UNITED STATES UNDER
CERCLA AND REGRET DOES NOT
INCLUDE EMISSIONS TO THE AIR
THIS IS THE NINTH CIRCUIT CASE.
WE BROUGHT THIS TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE DIRECTOR AT
THE TIME AND THE AG TO TIME AND
WE SAID DOESN'T THIS REALLY
PRECLUDE US FROM EVERY GETTING
COST RECOVERY FROM EXCITE. AND
THE ANSWER WAS YES WE ARE CELEJ
COUNCIL YES. WE ASK UCLA WE ASK
UC BERKELEY. WE ASK COLUMBIA
SCHOOL LAW WE ALSO HARVARD
SCHOOL LAW AND THEY'RE LIKE YES
YOU'RE THE NIGHT CIRCUIT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA GET COST RECOVERY BUT
YET DGSE CONTINUES TO COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE. AND MISS
REPRESENT THE PROBLEM. IT'S
GOING TO COST OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S GOING TO TAKE
YEARS. AND WE NEED MONEY. AND
MORE THAN ANYTHING WE NEED
SOMEONE. AN AGENCY THAT CARES.
AND I CANNOT STRESS ENOUGH YOU
I HAVE EIGHTY MEMBERS THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED BY THE EXCITED
PROBLEM OURS A SMALL FRACTION
OF MY MEMBERS I HAVE A MEMBER
THIS ALL THE WAY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND HOW A PREFERRED
NEAR HUMBOLDT DEALING WITH AN
OLD PULP MILLS WITH DIOXIN
EVERYWHERE. THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ALONG WITH DGSE ON THAT CLEAN
UP WE HAVE LUIS OLMEDO WHO IS
FIGHTING OVER CHEVRON SITE IN
BRAWLEY. HE'S NOT GETTING ALONG
WITH THAT FROM THE VERY TOP OF
THE STATE FROM THE VERY BOTTOM
OF THE STATE THIS AGENCY CANNOT
GET. ITS CLEANUPS CORRECTLY CAN
I GET IT RIGHT. AND YOU KNOW
THIS YOU GUYS KNOW OKAY THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS YOU
KEEP DOING THE SAME THING BUT
EXPECT A DIFFERENT OUTCOME. I'M
ALL FOR YOU KNOW FIXING THE
AGENCY I'M ALL FOR REFORMING
THE AGENCY- YOU KNOW I DID
EDITORIAL ABOUT. THE GARCIA
BILL WE'VE GOT THE SERIOUS
PROBLEMS WITH LONG TERM
FINANCIAL ASSURANCES THE WHOLE
SCHEME IS ABOUT LEADING
EXAMINATION BEHIND AND THEN
MOVING THAT LIABILITY TO
TAXPAYERS THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN AT LOTS OF SITES. SO
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE YEAH I
MISS WILLIAMS PLEASE WRAP IT UP
DOING THE SAME THING. AND
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT OUTCOME.
WE NEED EITHER TO TAKE THE
EXCITED CLEAN UP OUT OF DGSE.
AND PUT IT INTO ITS OWN AGENCY
LIKE WE DIMAS SAN GABRIEL WATER
QUALITY CONTROL AUTHORITY- I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IMPRESSED
I'VE BEEN WITH ORANGE COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY AND THEY'RE-
JUMPING IN ON THE P. FAST ISSUE
THEY'RE DOING EVERYTHING THAT
THEY SHOULD BE DOING- MAYBE IT
NEEDS MAYBE X. I CLEAN IT NEEDS
TO GO TO A LOCAL AGENCY- MAYBE
THE GOVERNOR NEEDS TO CREATE.
YOU KNOW BLUE RIBBON PANEL THAT
WE CAN'T KEEP DOING THE SAME
THING WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND WHEN I HEAR THAT
PARKING IS THE PROBLEM. FOR
KIDS CLEANING UP KIDS. PARKS IN
KIDS DAY CARE CENTERS AND KIDS
HOMES WHERE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
WITH THE LEAD EVERYWHERE WHEN
IT TAKES EACH PINPRICK OF LEAD
TO POISON A CHILD I KNOW I'VE
GOT THE WRONG PEOPLE IN CHARGE
OF THE CLEAN UP SO I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS BUT- I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE TO YOU ENOUGH
ABSOLUTE FRUSTRATION. OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ON THE
GROUND TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS
AGENCY AND TRYING TO GET THEIR
THEIR HOMES CLEANED UP THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT TESTIMONY-
IN APPRECIATED I THINK THIS
PANEL IS DEFINITELY VOICING THE
FRUSTRATIONS AND CONCERNS- THAT
WE'RE HEARING NOT ONLY THE
COMMITTEE COMMUNITY BUT ALSO-
WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND NOW WITH THAT.
WE HAVE THREE MORE AGENDA ITEMS
TO GO THROUGH AN APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY MINUTES AND WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PUBLIC.
COMMENTS THAT ARE IN QUEUE
WAITING FOR US AT EACH OF THE
REMOTE- TESTIMONY STATION SO
WITH THAT LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
A ADDITIONAL IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS IF NOT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL.
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR.
ALLOWING US TO EXPEDITE SOME OF
THIS BECAUSE THE FIRST TWO
PANELS OF TAKEN SO LONG. NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WE'RE TRYING TO SQUEEZE IN
ANOTHER UPDATE. ON AUDIT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. I BELIEVE- MISS WE
HAVE MISALIGNED HOW WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR WE
HAVE A- GEORGE PURSUIT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR WITH
THE DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION I MISS HOW IF YOU
COULD JUST. LAID OUT FOR US
QUICKLY WE'D APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ARE VERY QUICKLY THIS
IS AN AUDIT WE ISSUED A YEAR
AGO. ON IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND IT WAS AN AUDIT OF
THE DEPARTMENT JUST RELATIONS
RELATED TO. QUALIFIED MEDICAL
EVALUATOR PROCESS FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION THREE KEY ISSUES
IN THE REPORT AND THEN I'LL
TALK OF A VERY QUICKLY ABOUT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
MADE REPORT. SO THREE KEY
FINDINGS- THE DEPARTMENT OF
DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT INDUSTRIALIZATION.
HAS FAILED TO ADDRESS AND
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
INADEQUATE NUMBER OF Q. AND
HE'S AVAILABLE- TO ASSESS
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
BEEN A SHORTAGE- AND IT'S BEEN
OCCURRING AND GETTING WORSE
OVER TIME SO THAT WAS THE FIRST
KEY ISSUE. SECOND ISSUE WAS-
DIVISION OF WORKER'S
COMPENSATIONS PRACTICES FOR
DISCIPLINING OCULAR MAYES
REALLY FOR US RAISED QUESTIONS
ABOUT DUE PROCESS AND- AND-
BRIEFLY WHAT THE ISSUE THERE IS
IT IF THERE ARE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST A FEW ANY. THERE SHOULD
BE A SEPARATE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS FOR THOSE ALLEGATIONS
TO BE INVESTIGATED WHAT WE
FOUND DURING THE COURSE OF THE
AUDIT IS THAT THE- DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION WOULD WAIT
UNTIL THAT QB WAS UP FOR
REAPPOINTMENT AND DENY THAT
REAPPOINTMENT SO YOU'RE LOSING
IT YOU AND ME FROM THE SYSTEM.
THAT'S ALREADY ARE SUFFERING
FROM A SHORTAGE OF GERMANY SO
WE REALLY HAD SOME ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO THAT AND THEN THE
THIRD KEY FINDING WAS RELATED
TO. DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION FAILING TO ENSURE
THAT THESE QUEUE NB REPORTS
THAT GO TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
JUDGES TO MAKE A DETERMINATION.
ARE AT WORK WERE WELL DONE OR
WERE MEETING THE EXPECTATIONS
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT THEIR
QUEUE NB IS SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING AND WHAT SHOULD BE
INCLUDED I WAS REPORTS OF THREE
KEY ISSUES. WE HAVE SEVEN G.
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE TO THE
DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION DEPARTMENT.
INVESTOR RELATIONS CLEARLY. A
TEAR. WAS REALLY TO THE KEY AND
A SHORTAGE WITH THAT THE-
NEEDED DO MORE- AND WHAT WE
RECOMMEND IS BY APRIL OF THIS
YEAR A FEW MONTHS AGO. DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT A PLAN TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF Q.
ANNE'S AVAILABLE. ARE
COMMENSURATE WITH DEMAND DEMAND
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
FOR. ALL THESE QUALIFIED
MEDICAL EVALUATIONS IT'S
INCREASED BY 37% OVER THE FIVE
YEARS WE LOOKED AT- THE SUPPLY
OF CUNY'S HAS DECREASED BY
ABOUT 12% SO THERE'S A HUGE.
HUGE NUMBER OF OUR- ARE THESE
EVALUATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
DONE BUT WE'RE LOOKED SUFFERING
FROM A SHORTAGE OF Q. AND ME SO
WE ENCOURAGE THE DEPARTMENT
THROUGH OUR RECOMMENDATION. TO
ACTIVELY RECRUIT AND INCREASE
THE POOL OF CUNY'S AVAILABLE TO
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
RESPONSE THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY- THE AS I SAID THE
AUDIT WAS ISSUED IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN WE ARE
EXPECTING OUR ONE YEAR RESPONSE
LATER THIS WEEK. REACHED OUT TO
THE DEPARTMENT TO TRY TO GET
THAT RESPONSE- A LITTLE BIT
EARLY SO THAT I COULD PROVIDE.
THE ONE YEAR STATUS PERHAPS
MISTER- THEY REPRESENT
REPRESENTATIVE FROM MINE. YOU
FOR A WORKERS COMP. OR DIVISION
WORKERS CAPTURES ME- CAN CAN
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF AN UPDATE
WE HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED A ONE
YEAR RESPONSE OTHER RESPONSES
I'M REFERRING TO. ARE THE SIX
MONTH RESPONSE THAT WE RECEIVED
IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR. SO AS OF
JUNE- WE FELT THAT THE STATUS
OF. BWC THIS RECOMMENDATION TO
REALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
Q. ANNE'S IS REALLY AS WE CALL
IT PENDING. SO BASICALLY WHAT
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS THEY
HAVE IDENTIFIED FOR A SEVERAL
DIFFERENT WAYS THEY INTEND TO
RECRUIT MORE Q. ANNE'S. BUT
REALLY HAVEN'T MOVED FORWARD
WITH THAT PROCESS. ONE
IMPORTANT ISSUE I KNOW MEMBERS
WHO WERE WORKING ON LAST YEAR
THERE WAS SOME LEGISLATION. WAS
RELATED TO THE FEES THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN CHARGE AS WE
INDICATED IN THE AUDIT REPORT
THOSE FEES HAD NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX. SO
THEY THEY NEED UPDATING OUR
SOON BECAUSE EVEN WITH JUST THE
CPI IF YOU USE JUST A AN
INFLATION INDICATOR. THOSE FEES
WOULD GO UP SIGNIFICANTLY
BECAUSE OF SUCH. SUCH A LONG
TIME. SO WE HAD ONE ONE KEY
RECOMMENDATION RELATED TO THE
SHORTAGE OF Q. AMIS REALLY GOT
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES ADDRESS THAT FEE
SCHEDULE. LOOK TO SEE WHERE
THAT THE SPECIALTIES ARE THAT
NEED. TO BE INCREASED BECAUSE
THEY ARE DOING ANY KIND OF
ANALYSIS BASED ON SPECIALTY.
ALSO WE FELT THAT THEY NEEDED
TO DO THAT. THE DUE PROCESS
ISSUE AS FAR AS SEPARATING
DISCIPLINE FROM REAPPOINTMENT
WE HAD TWO RECOMMENDATIONS
THERE ONE WE FEEL THAT THEY'VE
PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED WHAT WE
RECOMMEND IS THAT THEY DEVELOP
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
REALLY. DEFINE THEIR INTERNAL
PROCESSES FOR DISCIPLINE VERSUS
REAPPOINTMENT AND ESTABLISHING
TIMELINES FOR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION WHAT WE FOUND IS- SOME
Q. AND THESE WERE REQUESTING A
HEARING TO. PRESENT THEIR CASE
AND IT WAS TAKING DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMP- LONG TIME TO GET
THOSE HEARING SET UP THE CUNY
WOULD JUST AGREE TO SETTLE SO
THAT THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION AS A Q. AND ME. SO WE
FELT THAT THERE WERE SOME
SIGNIFICANT DUE PROCESS
CONCERNS THERE. OUR CONCLUSION
AT THE SIX MONTH RESPONSE AGAIN
BACK IN JUNE. IS THAT THEY HAVE
DEVELOPED A POLICY. BUT THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRING THEY'RE NOT
ENFORCING IT AND REQUIRING
THEIR STAFF TO FALL THAT POLICY
SO REALLY NOT A LOT OF PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE WITH RESPECT TO
THAT. THE OTHERRECOMMENDATION
WAS TO DEVELOP POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES WITH RESPECT TO RE
APPOINTMENT SO AS OPPOSED TO
DISCIPLINE WHAT KIND OF
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES SHOULD
THEY HAVE FOR. ASSURING THAT
THEY THEIR REAPPOINTMENT
PROCESS FOR CUNY'S IS FAIR AND
EQUITABLE AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY ACTION AT LEAST AS OF JUNE.
I KNOW ACTION BY THE
DEPARTMENT- TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
DEVELOP THEM. A TRAINED STAFF
ON THEM BUT CETERA SO
UNFORTUNATELY NOT NOT MUCH
PROGRESS THERE. WITH RESPECT TO
THE QUALITY OF REPORTS WE MADE
FOUR RECOMMENDATIONS. FIRST WE
WANTED THEM TO CREATE A PLAN TO
CONTINUOUS REVIEW- THE QUALITY
IN THE TIMELINESS OF THESE
REPORTS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
THESE REPORTS TO HAVE BE OF
HIGH QUALITY. SO THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES CAN USE
THOSE REPORTS. RATHER THAN
ASKING FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
INFORMATION THAT DELAYS A
WORKER A DETERMINATION SO THAT
THAT WORKERS CAN GET THE
APPROPRIATE CARE THAT. THE
WORKER NEEDS- WITH RESPECT TO
THAT. RECOMMENDATION WE FEEL
THE DEPARTMENT IS PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED IT IT PROVIDED US A
POLICY BUT IT HAS NOT PROVIDED
A PLAN. FOR IT'S REVIEW OF
REPORTS FOR QUALITY WE EXPECTED
TO SEE A METHODOLOGY WE
EXPECTED TO SEE. HOW MANY
REPORTS ARE WE GOING TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S THE FREQUENCY ETCETERA
SO THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
THERE. THE NEXT RECOMMENDATION
WAS RELATED TO- DEVELOPING A
PROCESS ONCE YOU REVIEW THOSE
REPORTS PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR. INDEED
HAVE YOU SEE SO THAT THERE CAN
BE CHANGES TO THE CURE ME
PROCESS TO IMPROVE. THE QUALITY
OF THOSE REPORTS THE TIMELINESS
OF THOSE REPORTED CETERA. THIS
ONE AS OF JUNE DELIVERY SHE
SAID IT WAS STILL DEVELOPING A
PROCESS FOR THAT ANNUAL
REPORTING TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
DIRECTOR. SO AGAIN MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE- THE NEXT
RECOMMENDATION WAS RELATED TO
THE APPEALS BOARD IT'S A- THE
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO. CREATE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
DEVELOP A PROCESS FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES TO NOTIFY.
DPW SEE THAT THEY WERE
REJECTING REPORTS DO YOU HAVE
YOU SEE REALLY HAVE NO IDEA HOW
MANY REPORTS WERE BEING
REJECTED BY WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES SO THEY
DIDN'T KNOW. WHAT TO DO AS FAR
AS MAKING SURE THAT CUNY'S WORK
OR CREATING REPORTS THAT WERE
SUFFICIENT FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES. IT ALSO
LIMITED- NEED OF UC'S ABILITY
TO TRAIN AND EVALUATE CUNY'S TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
MEETING THE STANDARDS. ARE THAT
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE WORKERS
COMP JUDGE JUDGES AGAIN TO BE
ABLE TO USE THESE REPORTS. ON
THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED
POLICIES AND AN EXAMPLE OF A-
REJECTED REPORT SO WE FELT THAT
THEY HAD. SKEWS ME I'M TRYING
TO RUSH- THEY HAD DEVELOPED
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND A
PROCESS FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES TO NOTIFY
DPW SEE THAT IS THE ONE
RECOMMENDATION THAT HAS BEEN
FULLY IMPLEMENTED WE SAW AN
EXAMPLE. OF A REJECTED REPORT
AND HOW THAT WAS REPORTED BACK
TO BE OF YOU SEE AND THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THAT NOTIFICATION. THAT THAT
REPORT HAD BEEN REJECTED. THE
FINAL. IS TIED TO THIS- AND IT
IT WAS TO CREATE POLICIES AND
TO IMPLEMENT A PROCESS TO
TRACK. OF THESE Q. ON THE
REPORTS THAT ARE REJECTED BY
WORKERS COMPENSATION JUDGES YOU
NEED TO KNOW HOW MANY ARE BEING
REJECTED. IS IT SPECIFIC YOU
ARE MAYES WHO ARE HAVING MANY
OF THEIR REPORTS REJECTED
WHAT'S THE NATURE AND REASON
WHY- THESE REPORTS ARE BEING
REJECTED IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE AS FAR AS-
THE QUALITY AND IT THE TRAINING
THAT YOU ARE MEANS RECEIVE SO
THAT THEY PUT TOGETHER A REPORT
THAT AGAIN IS SUFFICIENT. FOR
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION JUDGES
TO USE. THIS RECOMMENDATION WE
FEEL IS PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
AGAIN AS OF JUNE. ARE THEY
PROVIDED A POLICY FOR TRACKING
REJECTED REPORTS BUT DIDN'T
INCLUDE IN THAT. POLICY HOT
WHEN THEY WILL- REVIEW THOSE
REPORTS YOU KNOW THE REJECTED
REPORTS ARE THAT THE- THE
TRACKING OF THOSE TO DETERMINE
WHAT ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
ARE WHAT ARE THE REASONS- THAT
WORKERS COMPENSATION JUDGES ARE
CITING. FOR REJECTING THOSE
REPORTS BECAUSE THEY IF YOU
DON'T KNOW WHY THEY'RE BEING
REJECTED. ARE YOU NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
DEFICIENCY AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW I MEAN THESE. ARE ARE
PUTTING REPORTS TOGETHER THAT
ARE SUFFICIENT FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES TO MAKE
DECISIONS. SO THOSE WERE THE
SEVEN RECOMMENDATIONS- AGAIN
WE'RE EXPECTING OUR THE ONE
YEAR RESPONSE LATER THIS WEEK
WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE IT FOR THE
HEARING TODAY- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T GET IT TO US. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISSILE APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S THE THOROUGH
OVERVIEW IN THE LEGISLATION WAS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
MEDICAL LEAVE- MEDICAL LEGAL
FEES FOR OUR QUEUE AMIS ARE
QUALIFIED MEDICAL EVALUATORS. I
TO BE INTERESTED IN SEEING
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET SOME OF
THOSE RESPONSES TODAY KNOW
YOU'RE EXPECTING A FORMAL
RESPONSE LATER THIS WEEK. FROM
MISTER PURSUIT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR WITH
THE DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION ESPECIALLY NOW IN
THE TIME OF COLLUDED. AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
PANDEMIC. WE STILL NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A- ADDED
SUPPLY OF Q. IN ME IS OUR-
AVAILABLE FOR WORK I WITH A
WE'RE JUST GONNA GO TO MOVE
STRAIGHT INTO MR PRAYER SOTO AS
PRESENTATION I BELIEVE HE IS-
JOINING US AS WELL. MISTER SOTO
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE- PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR
ME. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION PROGRESS
ON THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
DIVISION'S QUALIFIED MEDICAL
EVALUATOR. FOR Q. M. B. PROCESS
IT MADE THE DIVISION SUBMITTED
A SIX MONTH STATUS REPORT WHICH
WAS PUBLISHED ON THE STATE
AUDITOR'S WEBSITE. I AM PROUD
TO REPORT THAT OVER THE LAST
SIX MONTHS SINCE THEN THE
DIVISION IS COMPLETED THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR'S TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
REPORT AND ARE IMPLEMENTING ALL
THE NECESSARY CHANGES. AS WITH
ALL STATE AGENCIES OF COURSE VW
THREE AND HAD TO QUICKLY ADAPT
TO THE CHALLENGES OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO ENSURE
THAT INJURED. OR SICK WORKERS
CAN ACCESS THE HEALTHCARE THEY
NEED. IN ADDITION TO
IMPLEMENTING ALL THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS THE
DIVISION HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
WITH. TRANSFORMING ITS MANNER
OF DOING BUSINESS IN ITS
HEADQUARTERS IN TWENTY FOUR
DISTRICT OFFICES. FROM 1100%
1100% TELEWORK. WE CONDUCTED
VIRTUAL HEARINGS IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND PER MONTH.
AND WE'RE NOW EDUCATING WORKERS
ON THE NEW CODE NINETEEN
PRESUMPTIONS PASSED UNDER
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY NINE.
I WOULD PERSONALLY LIKE TO
THANK THE DIVISION'S MANAGERS
JUDGES AND STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL WORK THEY PERFORMED
OVER THE PAST YEAR WE ARE
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING OUR
SYSTEM. AND IT'S ALL THE
OCCUPATIONAL INJURIES EQUITABLY
AND EFFICIENTLY. NOW WITHOUT I
WILL WALK YOU AND GIVE A BRIEF
STATUS. REPORT ON EACH
RECOMMENDATION. THE
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER D. W. HAS.
AND IS IMPLEMENTING A PLAN TO
RECRUIT PHYSICIANS IN INCREASE
THE POOL OF CUBA EASED. THE
RECRUITMENT INVOLVES
ENCOURAGING INCREASED
PARTICIPATION IN THE QUEUE IN
THE EXAM AND OUTREACH TO
MEDICAL COMMUNITIES. THE
DIVISION HEALTH POSTED ITS
FINAL PROPOSED REGULATIONS FOR
NEW MEDICAL LEGAL FEES SCHEDULE
WITH THE VIRTUAL PUBLIC HEARING
DATE SET FOR DECEMBER
FOURTEENTH. THIS POSTING
REPRESENT THE CULMINATION OF A
YEAR LONG EFFORT TO UPDATE THE
FEE SCHEDULE. AUTHOR INCLUDED
SOLICITATION OF PROPOSALS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THE POSTING OF AN
INTERIM SET OF REGULATIONS IN
THE FINAL CLOSING ON OCTOBER
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS NEW FEED GRADUAL IMPLEMENT
AFFECT THE BENEFACTOR OF 25%
INCREASE IN THE BATES FEES FOR
QB'S IT USHERS IN SCHEDULE
BASED ON WHAT THE SYSTEM TO
MINIMIZE FRICTIONAL COSTS IN
OUR SYSTEM. INITIAL COST
PROJECTIONS USING DATA ANALYSIS
FROM PASSED YOU'LL BE REPORTING
TRENDS SHOW THAT THE SCHEDULE
HOLDS THE POTENTIAL TO MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE INCOME FOR
PHYSICIANS PARTICIPATING IN OUR
SYSTEM. THIS UNDERSTAND
INCREASE IN REMUNERATION SHOULD
ATTRACT NEW POSITIONS TO BECOME
Q. ANNE'S. THE FINAL
REGULATIONS ARE TAKE OLD ARE
SCHEDULED TO TAKE EFFECT ON
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FOR OUR OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
Q. IN THE EXAMINATION D. WCPO
BY THE OPTION FOR THE
EXAMINATION TO BE TAKEN IN A
FIXED SITE AND ONLINE OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME TO ALLOW
FLEXIBILITY TO PETITIONS. FOR
POSITION TO TAKE THE EXAM AT
THEIR CONVENIENCE AND WITHOUT
TRAVEL. AS A RESULT TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR PHYSICIANS TOOK
THE TEST MORE THAN WHAT WE HAD
IN THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS WHEN
THE EXAM WAS OFFERED TWICE.
THIS OPTION WILL BE MAINTAINED
FOR FUTURE DURING THE
EXAMINATIONS WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT THE
CONVENIENCE WILL ATTRACT MORE
CANDIDATES. FURTHER DWP HAS
BEGUN THE PRACTICE OF REACHING
OUT TO POSITION TO PASSED
PREVIOUS EXAMS BUT NEVER
REGISTERED. AS A RESULT OF THIS
RECRUITMENT EFFORT OUT OF
TWENTY NINE POSITIONS JENNIFER
EIGHT FOURTEEN OF SINCE
REGISTERED HE REMAINS. THE W.
THREE OF ALSO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF REACHING OUT TO HEALTH
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
HELP HEALTHCARE INSTITUTIONS
WITH A LARGE NUMBER OF
PHYSICIANS ON STAFF.
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS IN THESE
AREAS WILL CONTINUE. ALSO BEGUN
I HAVE UNDERTAKEN AN EXTENSIVE
REVIEW OF OUR OWN INTERNAL DATA
FOR PANEL STATISTICS. UTILIZING
PANEL REPLACEMENT DATA FROM THE
YEARS TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THROUGH NINETEEN WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED SPECIFIC SPECIALTIES
THAT SHOULD RECEIVE INTENSIFIED
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS AND WE
WILL. WE WILL EMPHASIZE THOSE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS FOR OUR
APRIL EXAM IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
CORRECT RECOMMENDATION NUMBER
FOUR D. WCS OF ELEPHANT
IMPLEMENTED WRITTEN POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THAT DEFINE AND
SPECIFY ITS INTERNAL POLICIES
FOR DISAPPOINTING Q. AND THESE.
A. WW DID THE INVESTIGATION
DESK REFERENCE MANUAL AND
DRAFTED THE LEGAL UNIT Q. M. B.
DISCIPLINE LITIGATION AND ALL.
THESE TO MANUAL CONTAINS ALL OF
THE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
THAT DEFINE AND SPECIFY
INTERNAL PROCESSES FOR
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS AND
DISAPPOINTING Q. ANNE'S. WE
HAVE ALSO CORRESPONDINGLY HELD
TRAINING SESSIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THE QUEUE WILL BE
DISCIPLINED UNIT STAFF HAS BEEN
FAMILIARIZED WITH ALL OF THEIR
JOB FUNCTIONS AS DEFINED BY
LISTED AS REQUIREMENTS MANUAL.
THIS TRAINING WILL BE ONGOING.
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER FIVE D.
W. C. HAS DEVELOPED AND
IMPLEMENTED WRITTEN POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THAT DEFINE ITS
INTERNAL PROCESSES FOR
REAPPOINTING CURONIANS. D. W.
FIELD DRAFTED THE REAPPOINTMENT
PROTOCOL FOR POSITIONS UNDER
INVESTIGATION THIS PROTOCOL
GOVERNS THE HANDLING OF THE
REAPPOINTMENT PROCESS FOR QB
WHO'S UNDER INVESTIGATION AT
THE TIME OF REAPPOINTED AT. THE
CONTAINS SPECIFIC TIMELINES FOR
THE PROTECTION OF THE QB'S DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS IN THE
REAPPOINTMENT PROCESS.
RECOMMENDATION SIXTY WTO
CREATED AND IS IMPLEMENTING A
PLAN TO CONTINUOUSLY REVIEW THE
QUALITY AND TIMELINESS SECURITY
REPORTS. WE HAVE CREATED A
FORMAL WRITTEN POLICY
MEMORIALIZING THE QUEUE AND THE
REPORT QUALITY COMMITTEE REVIEW
PROCESS THE POLICY HAS BEEN
FORMALLY ADOPTED BY OUR
EXECUTIVE MEDICAL DIRECTOR.
THIS POLICY PROVIDE THE PWC
WILL CONVENE A COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW MEDICAL LEGAL REPORTS
FOR QUALITY. REPORT QUALITY
REPORT FOLLY REVIEW COMMITTEES
WILL INCLUDE WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES RETIRED
JUDGES APPLICANT AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS AND ACTED TO A MEANS.
PILOT PROGRAM OF THIS COMMITTEE
IS ALREADY TAKING PLACE FOR THE
FOURTH QUARTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. IT IS ON TRACK TO
PROVIDE A REPORT TO THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR BY DECEMBER FIFTEENTH
NEXT MONTH SO THAT A FINAL
REPORT CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED BY
THE END OF THE YEAR. WE HAVE
ALSO DRAFTED MEMBERS SECURING
REGULATIONS REQUIRING QB TO
PROVIDE TO SAMPLE MEDICAL LEGAL
REPORTS AT THE TIME OF THE
APPOINTMENT. THESE REPORTS WILL
ALSO BE USED IN THE PROCESS FOR
EVALUATING REPORT QUALITY. THE
RECOMMENDATION SEVENTY WTO
DEVELOPED INTO IMPLEMENTING A
PROCESS FOR ANNUALLY REPORTING
TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR
ITS FINDINGS ON THE QUALITY AND
TIMELINESS OF REPORTS. AND
pRECOMMENDED IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
QUEUE IN THE SYSTEM. WE HAVE
DROPPED TO THE PROTOCOL YOU
TITLED THE LATE REPORT PROCESS.
THIS PROCESS IS A PROTOCOL FOR
TRACKING ALL LATE REPORTS IN
THE QUEUE IN THE SYSTEM. IT
PROVIDES FOR QUANTIFYING THE
LATE REPORT AT THE END OF THE
YEAR SO THAT THIS INFORMATION
CAN BE INCLUDED IN THE REPORT
TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR
PREPARED BY THE EXECUTIVE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR. TRAINING IN
THE USE OF THE WHITE REPORT
PROCESS HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO
ALL MEMBERS OF THE QUEUE AND
THE DISCIPLINE UNIT. AFTER
RECOMMENDED RECOMMENDATION
NUMBER EIGHT OF THE AUDITOR
FOUND AFTER THE DIVISION SIX
MONTH RESPONSE EWC HAS CREATED
WRITTEN POLICIES AND
IMPLEMENTED A CONSISTENT
PROCESS FOR ENSURING. THAT
WORKERS COMPENSATION JUDGES
INFORM THE DIVISION OF QBE
REPORTS THEY REJECTED FOR NOT
MEETING MINIMUM STANDARDS. FOR
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER NINE DWTS
CREATED POLICIES IMPLEMENTED A
PROCESS FOR TRACKING QB REPORTS
REJECTED BY WORKERS
COMPENSATION JUDGES FOR NOT
MEETING MINIMUM STANDARDS. WE
HAVE DEVELOPED A TEMPLATE ORDER
FOR JUDGES TO USED TO REJECT HE
WILL BE REPORTS WHICH INCLUDES
SERVICE. ON EXECUTIVE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR. WE FURTHER DROP
WRITTEN. THE POLICY COULD
REJECTED REPORTS. WHICH IS A
PROTOCOL DEVELOPED FOR TRACKING
REPORTS THAT WE ARE REJECTED BY
JUDGES WHICH INCLUDE THE
PROCESS REVISING QB'S WHEN THEY
HAVE REACHED THE THRESHOLD FOR
DISCIPLINE BASED UPON THE
NUMBER OF REJECTED REPORTS. IN
THE PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATISTICS REGARDING REJECTED
REPORTS ARE INCLUDED IN THE
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR.
TRAINING IN USE OF THE POLICY
FOR TRACKING REJECTED REPORTS
HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE QUEUE IN THE
DISCIPLINE UNIT. SINCE THE
PUBLICATION OF THE AUDIT
RESULTS THE CURE ME DISCIPLINE
UNIT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATE
AUDITOR. DESPITE LIMITATION THE
STAFF TO THE ADVENT OF THE
PANDEMIC THE DIVISION'S
COMPLIED WITH THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO UTILIZE THE
IMPLEMENTED PROCESSES THE
PROTOCOLS IN THE FUTURE. THE
TARGET POSITION RCRUITMENT AND
IMPROVE THE QB PROGRAM FOR THE
BENEFIT OF INJURED WORKERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RISK
PERCENT APPRECIATE THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO READING SOME OF THE
DETAILS SPELLED OUT IN EACH OF
YOURRESPONSES TO THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING UP- THE
PANDEMIC IMPROVE IT AND WITH
THAT I JUST WANTED TO ASK A
SIMPLE QUESTION. KNOWING THAT A
LOT OF WORKERS OR OR AFFECTED.
I'M JUST WONDERING HOW MANY
QB'S ARE THERE IN THE SPECIALTY
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS ONE OF
SPECIALTY THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
MANY I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF
THERE IF THERE WAS ONE REALLY
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT HAS
COME UP. CLEARLY CLEARLY THAT
IS A SPECIALTY THAT NEEDS
BARGAINING THAT WE NEEDED TO DO
NEED TO BRING THOSE THOSE KEEP
THOSE DOCTORS INTO OUR SYSTEM.
YEAH I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THE-
THAT YOU WOULD I WANT TO
PRIORITIZE I GIVEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE PANDEMIC IN
WITH COVE IT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SPECIALIST DEALING
SPECIFICALLY NOT ONLY WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING THIS YEAR BUT
PART OF TENSELY IN THE FUTURE%
AS WELL- HAS DELIVERY SHE DONE
ANYTHING TO IMPLEMENT A PLAN TO
ADDRESS THESE TYPES OF.
SCENARIOS WELL WE'RE WE ARE
STILL LOOKING AT THE DATA. THAT
WE ARE RECEIVING IN A WE ARE
REACHING OUT TO AS I MENTIONED
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITIES- WE ARE
REACHING OUT TO LARGE HEALTH
PROVIDER GROUPS. AND WE
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WITH THE
ADOPTION OF THE NEW FEE
SCHEDULE A DOCTOR'S WILL FIND
IT BENEFICIAL TO BECOME HUMAN
NEEDS- WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
PASSING THE- CAN DEFINITELY BE
A CODE NINETEEN PRESUMPTION
BILLS. WE HOPE THE CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATORS YOU KNOW ARE
ACCEPTING THE CLAIMS OF INJURED
WORKERS WHO DO GET SICK ON THE
JOB. THANK YOU AND I KNOW WE'VE-
WE'VE PASSED THAT LEGISLATION
HERE THE LEGISLATURE BUT WE
ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATION AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
TO TRANSIT. TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THE MEDICAL LEAD. MEDICAL LEGAL
FEES SCHEDULE ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING ANY REIMBURSEMENT
CHANGES TO THE FEE SCHEDULE.
ARM TO OUR PROPOSED TO OUR
PROPOSED SCHEDULE YEAH- I DON'T
ANTICIPATE ANYTHING AT THIS
TIME WE ARE IN OUR RULE MAKING
PERIOD WE ARE GOING TO ACCEPT.
ALL PUBLIC COMMENTS REGARDING
MEN'S WE ARE HAVING A VIRTUAL
HEARING- WE WILL LIKE IT WE A
LOT UP. TAKE KERR WILL BE ABLE
TO THEM AND MALL HAVE A FINAL
COULD HAVE BUT I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS. GOOD BUT
ALSO FUTURE A FEW SLOW TWEAKS
THEY'RE GOT IT AND I KNOW WE
ARE OFTEN BEEN HEARING IN THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN HEARING-
FROM PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE FEE SCHEDULE BUT I WAS JUST
WONDERING IS THERE A MECHANISM
TO RESOLVE DISPUTES EITHER
THROUGH THE IBR OR THROUGH
COURT R. THROUGH THE COURT
PROCESS. WELL WE WILL HAVE A-
SET THE SCHEDULE FOR THIS. IF
THERE IS A DISPUTE REGARDING
THE AMOUNT OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD GO TO OUR INDEPENDENT
BILL REVIEW PROCESS- WHICH- IS
MANDATED BY STATUTE WHICH WOULD
GO TO A REVIEWER. AND
INDEPENDENT THE BILL REVIEW
ORGANIZATION RIGHT NOW THAT'S
MAXIMUS FEDERAL SERVICES WHO
WOULD RESOLVE THE DISPUTE. GOT
IT JUST A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS
ON FOLLOW UP ON THE FEE
SCHEDULE NOW I UNDERSTAND- THAT
INSTEAD OF SIMPLY INCREASING
THE EXISTING FEE SCHEDULE ONE
YEAR AGO AS A STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED. IDW SEES LATEST
PROPOSALS TO REVAMP THE ENTIRE
STRUCTURE OF THE FEE SCHEDULE
THE NEW PROPOSAL WOULD FORCE
CAN BE USED TO WORK AT A FLAT
RATE AND WOOD. AND- HINDER
THEIR ABILITY BE PAID ON AN
HOURLY BASIS IS DO I HAVE THAT
UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY. BUT WE
DO HAVE A FLAT RATE BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK TO HAVE
CONSISTENCY AND CONSISTENCY IN
OUR SYSTEM SO THAT PEOPLE-
DIRECTLY- OF CENTRAL YOU KNOW.
WHAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING GOOD QUALITY REPORT WE
DO HAVE A FLAT FEE- AND RIGHT
NOW- IT'S INCLUDED- IT'S THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN DOLLARS
WITH A TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS OF
RECORDS BUT IF THERE ARE MORE
RECORDS THAN THAT THEN THAT THE
RECORDS ARE PAID AT A HIGHER
PRICE. SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
AVERAGE REPORT RIGHT NOW IS
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED PAGES ABOUT
THE RESULT IN THE PAYMENT OF
ABOUT THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS- DIFFICULT THIS CAN GO
UP TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY PAGES ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDED TO THE
POSITION TO REVIEW- WE HAVE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS BOTH PRO
PROVIDERS WHO CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATOR THOUGHT THAT THIS
WAS THE WAY TO. THE WAY TO
PROGRESS IN DROUGHT WE THINK
THAT THIS WILL THIS WILL WORK
WELL I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE US
WE'D LIKE TO GET THE SCHEDULE-
ABOUT A YEAR OR SO TO SEE HOW
IT'S WORKING OUT OF THEM AND
THEN- YOU KNOW WE- CAN MOVE
FORWARD. GOT IT AND WHEN YOU.
THE PROPOSAL. FEES SCHEDULE TO
REACH OUT TO THE QUEUE MEAN
IT'S JUST KIND UNDER. WHY THIS
OVER WOULD HAVE. JUST IN TERMS
OF IN. ON THEIR ABILITY TO DEAL
CARE. WELL AS WE DID WE DID- AB
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS THAT. WERE
REPRESENTED BY GROUPS WE DID IN
JUNE POSTED PROPOSAL- OF THE
SPEED SCHEDULE AND WE DID GET
QUITE A BIT OF RESPONSE FROM
THE QUEUE IN THE COMMUNITY. YOU
KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE THEM ON THEIR
EFFORTS TO REVIEW TO REVIEW
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING AND BASED
ON THAT. WE PUT OUR FINAL
PROPOSAL OUT IN OCTOBER TO DID
HAVE SEVERAL UPTICKS IN THE
INLAND. REGENERATION ISSUE I
THINK REGARDING- PAID TRIBUTE.
AND SEVERAL MODIFIERS. GOT IN
JUST A FEW FINAL. BECAUSE I
KNOW NEED TO MOVE ON WE HAVE TO
BE OUT OF THIS ROOM BY TWELVE
THIRTY- JUST QUICKLY I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
YOU CAME OUT WITH FLAT FEE OF
THE SCHEDULE BUT WHAT ARE WE
DOING. WELL WE HAD A PREVIOUS
HEARING IN TERMS OF. MAKING
SURE THAT. NOT ONLY DO WE
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF Q. AND
HE'S- BUT ENSURING THAT THE
QUALITY IS THERE FOR. PATIENTS
AS WELL. WE ARE WE ARE GOING TO
BE CONDUCTING THE QUALITY
REVIEW REPORTS WE HAVE ARE SUB
COMMITTEE THEY'VE ALREADY MET
THEY ARE REVIEWING REPORTS
RIGHT NOW- WE WILL GET REPORT
WE'LL GET- REPORTS THEY WILL
REPORT TO OUR EXECUTIVE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR. WHO WILL BEGIN ISSUE
A FINAL REPORT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
END OF THE YEAR. WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS OF HOW WE AS TO
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE THE SYSTEM-
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
TO SEE WHAT STEPS WE CAN TAKE
IN THE PROCESS PART OF IT WE-
WE ARE DEFINITELY WORKING ON
THE PEACE IN THE QUALITY.
COMPONENTS BUT THEN WE HAVE TO
WORK ON PROP IN THE PROCESS
ISSUES. BECAUSE I THINK MOST
PEOPLE WOULD RECOGNIZE. THE
FRICTIONAL COSTS ARE REALLY
HAPPY IN OUR SYSTEM I THINK WE
PAY MORE IN FRICTIONAL COSTS
MANY OTHER STATES IN THE
COUNTRY AND- WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IS CREATE IS CREATE MORE
EFFICIENCIES LOOK HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM. I THINK
THIS'LL THIS'LL BE A GOOD STEP
FORWARD. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I KNOW THE AUDITOR HAD
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS IN TERMS
OF PROCESS AND THE- THE
HEARINGS AND HOW THOSE ARE
CONDUCTED TO ACTUALLYIMPROVE
EFFICIENCY- SO I DO. HOPE YOU
TAKE THOSE THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
HELP YOU. WITH THAT LET ME ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS-
MR MORLOCK FAIRLY QUICKLY
HOPEFULLY BECAUSE WE STILL GOT
IT WE WANT TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WILL TAKE LONGER THAN YOU'RE
TELLING ME HOW SHORTER TIME IS-
JUST WANT TO ASK THE QUESTION
MISTER PURCELL OO WHY DOES IT
TAKE AN AUDIT. WHY DID IT TAKE
AN AUDIT- I THINK WE- IN TERMS
IN TERMS IN TERMS OF IN TERMS
OF REVIEWING QUALITY WE WERE
TASKED TO PROVIDE QUALITY
REPORTS- I THINK OVER THE YEARS
VARIOUS MEASURES OF REFORM. WE
HAD STAFF THAT WERE DEDICATED
TO DOING CERTAIN TASKS BUT NOT
OTHERS- SO. I THINK I THINK IT
WAS JUST A QUESTION OF HAVING-
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR SYSTEM-
AND NOT HAVING ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
DEAL YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
ACTUAL ACTUAL ISSUES THAT WE
SAW BUT WE DIDN'T CHANGE THE
FEE SCHEDULE FOR QUITE A WHILE
IT WAS RIGHT IT HASN'T BEEN
UPDATED SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
R. BECAUSE OF COURSE- THERE IS
UP THERE IS THAT A BANDAGE OR
HERE IS THAT POSSIBLE THAT
THERE IS THE OPTION THERE TO GO
AND HOURLY BILLING PEOPLE WERE
TAKING ADVANTAGE REPORT WORK WE
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THOSE OPTIONS
AND ALSO WE HAVE. SEVERAL
REPORTS FROM OUTSIDE SOURCES
RAND CORPORATION TELLING US THE
FEE SCHEDULE WAS ACTUALLY
REASONABLE IN TERMS OF WHAT IT
WAS OFFERING AND SO WE KIND OF
BUT. WE KIND OF. WENT ON NOT.
IN TERMS OF THE AND THE SPECIAL.
IN THE- SB EIGHT. THREE INTO.
THIRTEEN TOOK AWAY VERY.
COMPONENT FROM CUBA REVIEW THE
RETREAT. THOSE ARE TREATED
ISSUE. TWENTY FIFTY REGARDING
THAT TO. PROVIDE IN WORKER. WAS
DECIDED BY A Q. A SB SIXTY TOOK
THE AWAY GIVE THAT THE END.
MEDICAL REVIEW- WE WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT AT THAT POINT THAT- THE
NUMBER OF Q. AND THE REQUESTED
WOULD HAVE GONE DOWN
SUBSTANTIALLY AT THAT POINT.
BUT WE FOUND OUT IN CASES IN
LITIGATED CASES WHERE WORKERS
ARE REPRESENTED WE HAVE MORE Q.
M. B. I REQUEST. PANEL
REQUESTED WE HAD BEFORE- SO I
THINK A LOT I THINK SOME OF IT
HAD TO DO WITH ONE. WE HAVE
STAFF DEDICATED TO. GOING AND
LOOKING QB DOESN'T PROCESS. AND
IN THE OTHER INSTANCE WE HAD
CERTAIN REFORMS PUT IN PLACE OF.
DIDN'T HAVE THE- OF THAT WE- WE
DIDN'T THAT UNTIL SEVERAL AFTER.
THANK YOU TAKE FROM ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
PERSONNEL WE ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. HEARING
AND SEEING THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR NEXT
AGENDA ITEM WHICH IS CHEN ITEM
NUMBER SIX OUR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
I DO BELIEVE- ASKED ME ASKED WE
HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. IF WE DO IF
YOU COULD HAVE YOU PLEASE LINE
UP AT THE MIKE AND IF YOU COULD
PLEASE A- BE MINDFUL OF THE
TIME BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO BE
OUT OF THE THIS ROOM BY TWELVE
THIRTY SO THAT THEY CAN TURN
AROUND FOR ANOTHER HEARING AND
SANITISE ROOM. YOU COULD MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS- REALLY BRIEF
MINUTES LESS THAN TWO MINUTES
WE APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE WE
KNOW WE HAVE. A NUMBER OF
PUBLIC COMMENT ALSO IN OUR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS YOU
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE
IDENTIFIER NAME AND PERHAPS- IF
YOU'RE WITH AN ORGANIZATION
LIST THE ORGANIZATION IF NOT.
THE COUNTY IN WHICH YOU RESIDE
WOULD BE HELPFUL AS WELL-
PLEASE STATE YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME NICOLE YEAH. THANK
AND I RESIDE IN PLASTER COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SAY THAT.
THE IN HAS NO CLOTHES ON. VIEW
ALL SAT HERE AND WAX POETIC
ABOUT YOUR CONCERN AND CARE FOR
THE POVERTY STRICKEN PEOPLE OF
THIS STATE YET. HOW MANY YEARS
HAS THIS LEAD POISONING THE
BAKUL GONE ON. AND INGRID BIRDS
FRIENDS WHO SPOKE OF DELANO
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS WHERE I AM
FROM IN KERN COUNTY. AND THERE
IS POVERTY THERE LIKE YOU HAVE
NEVER SEEN. AND MCFARLAND WHICH
IS RIGHT OUTSIDE OF DELANO WAS
KNOWN FOR GROWING UP AS A
CANCER CLUSTER OF AMERICA.
THERE WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF CANCER STRICKEN
CHILDREN IN MCFARLAND AND YET
WE ARE HEARING. OF SO MANY
PEOPLE WITH THEIR HANDS IN THE
POT WHERE THERE IS NOTHING
GOING ON BECAUSE OF PARKING
BECAUSE OF PERMIT ISSUES AND
YOU SPEAK OF SUFFERING. S.
ASSEMBLY MAN SANTIAGO AND YOU
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO DIE YET
WERE HUNG UP ON SEMANTICS AND
DOLLAR SIGN WELL I KNOW THIS IS
IMPORTANT I'VE WATCHED AS A
CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA THE STATE
HEMORRHAGE MONEY. INTO IT
UNNECESSARY. THINGS AND I'M
WATCHING IT TODAY WITH MONIES
STATE MONIES BEING POURED INTO.
A CO A MOBILE VACCINE UNIT FOR
A VACCINE THAT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY EXIST ON THIS PLANET.
I FEEL LIKE A CONCERNED CITIZEN
AND A MOTHER. WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSING ON MAKING THESE PARKS
DAYCARES AND HOMES SAFE FOR THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA. AND
LET'S PLEASE PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AND START
PROTECTING THE CHILDREN AND THE
PEOPLE IN THIS COMMUNITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS- WITH THAT LET ME
ALSO ANNOUNCE FOR THE RECORD-
THAT ALSO WANT TO GIVE A NOTICE
TO THE TELEPHONE OPERATOR THAT
AFTER WE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
IN THE ROOM WILL BE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE.
SO PLEASE START A QUEUE FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTERESTED IN MAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE NUMBER
AGAIN TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
VIA TELEPHONE IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
ZERO TWO AND IF YOU COULD-
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR MAKE
THEM TO SINK THAT WE'D
APPRECIATE THAT GIVEN OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS THIS TIME WE ASK IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL COMMENT FROM
MEMBERS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE ROOM PLEASE APPROACH-
PLEASE STATE YOUR FIRST LAST
NAME IF YOU'RE WITH REGULATION
OR THE COUNTY IN WHICH YOU
RESIDE. PLEASE THAT MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS THE STATE THANK YOU- I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I CAN BE
SEEN AND THAT I CAN BE HEARD.
AND COULD YOU GIVE ME A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY AROUND WHAT YOU
MEAN BY SUS SYNC. BECAUSE I
JUST LISTEN TO YOU FOR THE LAST
THREE HOURS. AND CALL ME CRAZY
BUT GOVERNMENT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE OF THE PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE
AND FOR THE PEOPLE. SO I'M A
LITTLE BIT PERPLEXED. CAN YOU
GIVE ME CLARITY ON WHAT YOU
MEAN BY SYNCING. IF YOU GET
STRAIGHT TO YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE'RE ALL HERE TO TRY TO HELP
EVERYONE THAT'S HERE WITH
TRYING TO HOLD THE DEPARTMENT
ACCOUNTABLE SO THAT WE CAN HELP
AS MANY COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE
AFFECTED- BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE FIRST
AGENDA ITEM OR THE SECOND I
THINK ABOUT ALL THE THAT AS MY
FRIEND INDICATED THE EMPEROR
HAS NO CLOTHES THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM IF YOU WILL. LET
HAPPENS TO BE OF PARTICULAR
INTEREST TO ME BECAUSE ALL
THREE OF MY CHILDREN WERE LEAD
POISONED WHEN WE LIVED IN THE
BAY AREA IN AN APARTMENT WHERE.
THE AVERAGE COST OF A TWO
BEDROOM WAS FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH. THAT WAS THE
ONLY HOUSING WE COULD FIND THAT
WAS BEFORE WE MOVED TO SONOMA
COUNTY AND GOT DISPLACED BY THE
TUBBS FIRE. WHICH IS WHY NOW WE
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN A
DOUBLE WIDE TRAILER. AS A
FAMILY OF SIX AND THAT'S BEEN
AN IMPROVEMENT. OVER THE DECADE
WE'VE DEALT WITH. IN THIS STATE.
AS I'VE WATCHED THE CORRUPTION
AND THE ANTICS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE MOST RECENTLY. DUE
TO A PANDEMIC THAT NOW HAS MY
CHILDREN ZOOM SCHOOLING SO SAYS
THINK ISN'T REALLY GOING TO
WORK FOR ME. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU IF YOU COULD- PLEASE
PROCEED WITH THAT HOW YOUR
COMMENTS ON TODAY'S HEARING- WE
ARE TRYING TO. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
TRYING TO ASSIST AS MUCH AS WE
CAN. SO WE WILL CONTINUE- THE
LEGISLATURE HAS APPROPRIATED
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS AS FAR FOR EXCITE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP HELPING
OR CANNOT PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT
OF D. W. W. D. W. C. BUT ALSO
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXICS AND
SUBSTANCE CONTROL. REVIEW
PLEASE PROCEED AND- ALLOW TIME
FOR THE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENTS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
REMOTE STATIONS AS WELL I'M
SURE THEY WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COME BACK IF THAT TIME WORKS.
PLEASE PROCEED. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT HEARING NO MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE RUTHLESS MOVE TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE THANK
YOU BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THANK YOU IF YOU
PLEASE STAY WITH FIRST AND LAST
NAME OF THE COUNTY WHICH YOU
RESIDE ORGANIZATION YOU BELONG
TO YES I AM ANNIKA WOODLAWN AND
I RESIDE HERE IN- SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THANK YOU AND I WONDER
IF YOU GUYS CAN HEAR ME YES
WELL IT OUT. OKAY LET ME. ARE
YOU ONE PHRASE. AUDI ALTARUM
PART THEM ANY OF YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT THAT MEANS. I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU. DOT
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
COMMENTS. SO THAT MEANS LISTEN
TO THE OTHER SIDE. THE ONLY
OTHER SIDE DIDN'T SPEAK TODAY%
IS THE PEOPLE NOT TO ONE OF ONE
FROM THOSE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WHETHER THE BEACH CHILDREN
ADULTS GRANDMA'S SISTERS
FATHERS STRUGGLING WITH CANCER
OR ANY OTHER DISEASE WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN FACING. AND LET'S GO
THERE TO JUST ONCE THAT. THIS
COMPANY IS DUMPING ILLEGAL LED.
FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AND
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN JUST WAKING
UP. NOW AND THE- STILL JUST
STRUGGLING THEY ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING THESE PEOPLE ARE
STILL LIVING WITH IN THIS
SITUATION. BUT YOU GUYS DON'T
CARE REALLY. BECAUSE YOU ARE
NOT AFFECTED YOU'RE NOT GOING
HOME. AND STRUGGLE DAY IN AND
DAY OUT I KNOW WHAT LEAD
POISONING IS NEITHER OF YOU DO
HOWEVER. SO DID ANYONE OF YOU
GO DOWN TO LA. AND TRIED TO
HELP OFFER A MEAL. OFFERED JUST
A WEEK OR TWO WEEKS IN A HOME
WHERE THEY ARE NOT GETTING
CONTINUALLY. POISON AND YOU
GUYS ARE THE ONES WHO DECIDE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THESE FOLKS.
I DON'T KNOW. IT'S INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTING AND AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW IF EXIDE CLOSED DOORS IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND THE BRANCH
OF THE BANKRUPTCY JUST WENT
THROUGH AND THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ALLOWED TO LEAVE WITHOUT ANY
CONSEQUENCES. WHY SHOULD THE
TAXPAYERS PAY FOR THE CLEANUP
WHY DON'T YOU GUYS GO AFTER THE
EXCITED PEOPLE. ONE OF. IN
ADDITION TO THAT. THESE
AGENCIES WHICH ARE SET UP AND
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THE BOGUS
CLAIMS WHY THE CLEANUP CANNOT
HAPPEN. I MEAN WE ARE IN TWENTY
TWENTY PARKING CANNOT BE AN
ISSUE. WHAT IT SHOULD BE GET
THE PEOPLE TOGETHER GET
EVERYONE IN L. A. COUNTY
TOGETHER TO SEND PEOPLE FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY YOU GET UP
AND GO YOU HAVE OUT TO. BECAUSE
TODAY'S WORK HERE FOR THE PAST
THREE HOURS. WAS A JOKE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MAY I ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM. IF NOT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO OUR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS AND
WITH THAT I DO. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND MOVE FORWARD PLEASE. PUBLIC
COMMENT PERHAPS WE WILL START-
FIRST IN I DON'T KNOW WHO WE
HAVE QUEUED UP ON THE SCREEN
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S OUR
OAKLAND STATION ARE LOS ANGELES
STATION OR SAN DIEGO STATION.
HI I'M JACOB ROSENBERG IN THE
PRESIDENT CCM SWITCHES THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
INDUSTRIAL MEDICINE AND SURGERY
AND FIRST I WANT TO THANK J.
LACK IN THE AUDITOR. FOR
CONTINUING TO MONITOR THE D. W.
C. ON THESE ISSUES AND WE'RE
GONNA NEED YOU TO CONTINUE
MONITORING YOUR CONTINUED
INVOLVEMENT- FOR QUITE AWHILE.
YOUR YOUR YEAR AFTER THE AUDIT
WAS RELEASED ON MONTHS AFTER
THE LAST STAKEHOLDER MEETING WE
MET FOR OVER TWENTY HOURS. AND
NOW WE JUST HAVE A PROPOSAL
MADE. NOW THE PROPOSED FEE
SCHEDULE WASN'T EXACTLY WHAT
WAS AGREED TO IN THE-
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS BUT NO FEE
SCHEDULES GOING TO SATISFY
EVERYONE. THIS SCHEDULE WILL
PROVIDE SOME REYES FOR MOST%
VALUATIONS MOST VALUATION IS
QUITE POSSIBLE THAT IT WILL
ATTRACT MORE ORTHOPEDIC
EVALUATORS SO IN THAT SENSE
IT'S ACCOMPLISHING ONE OF THE
GOALS. I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
EFFECT IS GOING TO BE ON THE
ENTIRE QUEUE ME POPULATION
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE
MONITORED VERY CLOSELY. I KNOW
THAT A NUMBER OF EVALUATOR
SPECIALTY EVALUATORS TELL ME
THAT THE FEE SCHEDULES NOT
ADEQUATE FOR THEM. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH THERE ARE A MINORITY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FOLLOW
CLOSELY AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE OVERALL. AVAILABILITY OF
CUNY'S. MY BIGGEST CONCERN
RIGHT NOW IS THAT. THE BE
FURTHER DELAYS IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SCHEDULE
IT'S ALREADY PUSHED OUT TO
APRIL FIRST I'M NOT SURE WHY
THAT IS. IT SEEMS LIKE IT COULD
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL
MONTHS BEFORE THAT. I'M AFRAID
IS GOING TO BE EVEN FURTHER
DELAYS BECAUSE OF. PRESSURE
FROM PAYERS. I KNOW THAT-
EVERYBODY REALIZES QB'S HAVEN'T
HAD A EVEN A COLDER REYES IN
FIFTEEN YEARS. I'M ALSO
CONCERNED THAT THEIR CERTAIN
PROVISIONS IN THE FEE SCHEDULE
THAT THAT REALLY NEED TO BE
CLARIFIED IF THEY'RE NOT
CLARIFY THERE'S GOING TO BE
GREATLY INCREASED FRICTIONAL
COSTS. NOT SURE THE WC THINKING
IS ON THESE- ON THESE PARTS OF
THE PROPOSAL. WE'VE DISCUSSED
THIS WITH THEM BEFORE AND
FRANKLY HAVEN'T GOTTEN A
SATISFACTORY ANSWER. SO
HOPEFULLY THE D. W. C. WILL
CHOOSE TO CLARIFY SOME OF THESE
PROVISIONS IT'S NOT A QUESTION
OF ELIMINATING THEM IS JUST A
QUESTION OF MAKING SURE THAT
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
SCHEDULE. OUR HOPE IS THAT THE
D. W. SEASON TO CONTINUE TO BE
COLLABORATIVE BUT AGAIN WE NEED
THE AUDITOR AND THE JAILER
COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO.
MONITOR THEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT AND WE'RE
HOPING TO GET SOME OF THAT
CLARITY FROM D. W. C. LATER ON
THIS WEEK AND FORMAL RESPONSE
TO THE AUDITORS-
RECOMMENDATIONS. BUT MORE THAN
HAPPY TO- HELP FOLLOW UP AS
WELL I KNOW MISTER PERSONA
STILL LISTENING IN. AND SO- WE
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENTS I
BELIEVE WE ARE IN THE OAKLAND
STATION IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL.
COMMENT IN OAKLAND. OKAY IF
THERE'S NO MORE ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THE OAKLAND
STATION WAS MOVED TO THE LOS
ANGELES REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION PLEASE.
ALL RIGHTS I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY AT THE LOS
ANGELES STATION LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE SAN DIEGO STATION OR ANY OF
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS.
AT THIS TIME.
OKAY ONCE MORE WE
ARE FLIPPING BETWEEN EACH OF
THE STATIONS TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. IF NOT THEN
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TOWARDS. CLOSING AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION WE ARE NOW ON
AGENDA ITEM. NUMBER SEVEN OR
CLOSING COMMENTS AND UP. NOW
LET ME ASK THERE'S PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE. WE HAVE
TO LOW PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM THE
PHONE AS A REMINDER FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE POINT FIVE FIVE
BILLING IS OPEN. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS KIM STONE
DON'T ADVOCATE THE OR BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS WHO ARE Q. ANNIE. WE
LIKE TO THINK THAT CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR DRESSING THIS
ISSUE I DON'T THINK THE
AUTHORED HER FOR HER TO REPORT.
ONE OF HER FINDINGS WAS THAT
THE NUMBER OF Q. IT MEANS IS
REDUCING AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THE REQUEST. FOR Q. ANNE'S IS
GOING UP. THE NUMBER OF
KILOMETERS INTO FISH. TO MEET
THE NEED OF INTER WORKERS. AND
ONE PARTIAL FOR THE SHORTAGE IS
DUE THAT IN A- COME. FOR Q. ME.
THIS AWAITING- THE DEPARTMENT
WORKER COMP WITH FOR. THE WORK.
TO UP THE MEDICAL LEGAL FEES.
THE WORK GROUP I THINK WE-
PROVIDERS PAYERS MEDICAL LEGAL
MANAGEMENT GROUP HELP INSURED
EMPLOYERS DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
APPLICANT ATTORNEYS- THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION AND OTHERS. THE COA
SUPPORT DEPENDING REGULATION
THAT THE DWP HAVE PROPERTY WE
ORDERED- THE COST OF LIVING
INCREASE. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
YEARS SINCE THE LAST UPDATE OR
INCREASE AND WE URGE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REGULATIONS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MR ON LET'S MOVE ON TO THE.
NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE. WE HAVE PUBLIC FOR
LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER. TWENTY
THREE. LAURIE CAMERON I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF PROFESSIONAL
PHOTOCOPIER- THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY AND
WE THANK THE STATE AUDITOR FOR
LOOKING AT THE QUEUE AT ME
ISSUE- WE HAD ALSO- SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO YOU FROM THE
COALITION OF PROFESSIONAL
PHOTOCOPIERS. KADING THAT WE TO
OUR INDUSTRY IS ALSO A WAITING
UPON SB- INCREASED AND
REGULATION OF REVISIONS. OF THE
PHOTOCOPY AT INDUSTRY PROVIDE
COPIES TO EMPLOYERS AND INJURED
WORKERS AS PART OF THE
DISCOVERY PROCESS. IN A
DISPUTED WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIM. D. COPY SERVICE BE
SCHEDULE HAS NOT RECEIVED AN
INCREASE SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
WHICH ACTUALLY THAT THE
INCREASE THEY RECEIVED BACK
THEN REDUCE THEIR FEES BY FORTY
PERCENT. AND IT WAS BASED ON A
FORMULA THAT AND METHODOLOGY
THAT THE D. W. C. USE. D.
COATED- YEAR THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED I WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S BEEN OVER FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND. WORKERS
COMPENSATION CODE RELATED
CLAIMS THIS IS PUTTING EXTRA
PRESSURE ON THE COPY SERVICE
INDUSTRY WHO PROVIDES. A COPIES
TO INJURED WORKERS AND ALSO TO
THE EMPLOYERS IN DISPUTED
CASES. SO WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO PUT PRESSURE ON THE WCT GET
THESE REGULATIONS ADOPTED. AND
TO DO IT THIS YEAR SO THAT THE-
INDUSTRY HAVE TIME TO COMPLY
WITH ANY NEW REGULATIONS COMING
IN THE NEW YEAR AND IT THE
DEMAND THAT WE SEE WITH. THE
CULT CLAIMS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THINK WHY NUMBER FIVE GO
AHEAD LINE FIVE. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE PROCEED.
OKAY HI MY NEW CIVIC CENTER I
AM FROM LOS ANGELES I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND READ WHAT I HAD
TEXTED MY FRIENDS THAT ARE
ALSO- LISTENING IN ON THE
MEETING AND IT'S GOING TO GO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS I REALLY
HATE THE NARRATIVE THAT DTS ES
SOMEHOW THE UNDERDOG HERE THEY
ALLOWED EXCITE TOP RATE FOR
DECADES THEY DIDN'T THEY WROTE
A CHECK THAT THEIR ACTS OF
QUICK CASH SHAKTI TFC. IN
ACTION BECAUSE OF THIS THIS
THEIR JOB AND THEY MADE A MESS
OF IT BIG BLUE WITH A **** BLEW
IT AND ASSEMBLY MAKAN YOU'RE
RIGHT AND I RARELY AGREE WITH
THE SENTIMENT BUT YOU'RE RIGHT
WE SHOULD BE ACTING LIKE THIS
IS A WRECKING BALL BUT AS A
WRECKING BALL KNOCKING OFF THE
COLD OUT OF THE WAY BECAUSE THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLE THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS GETTING US THE
FUNDING TO CLEAN UP THE HOME
THE STUDY ONE POINT FIVE MILES.
AND THE EXTENDED AND IT SHOULD
BE EXTENDED OUT TO THE FOUR
POINT SIX MILES WHICH. IS IN
YOUR DISTRICT OF WELL HIGH.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES WITH
THE HIGH. BLOOD LEVELS IN THE
CUT IN THIS CASE. MERCED COUNTY.
IS FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE SQUARE MILES. AND IN.
AREA RIGHT I EXPECT THAT'S
WHERE THE LARGEST BLOOD LEVEL
YOU SAID IT BEST WE'RE TRYING
TO THINK LIVES SHARE THE LOVE
CENTER GONZALEZ SHOULD ASK WHY.
EPA-EFE IT HAVE TROUBLE GET
RESIDENTS TO WATER WORK WITH
FOR THE LEAD CLEAN IT'S BECAUSE
WE DON'T. THEM YOU TO COMMUNITY
LED IN THE- FOR THE CLEAN UP
EACH YEAR. OR THIRTY YEAR COULD
DO FOR ABOUT EXPECT AND THE DO.
THE BILL MASON HOW YOU PULL.
CAN FIGHT MONEY TO FUND YOUR
ELECTION IN YOUR REAL CAMPAIGN
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO LEAD CLEAN
UP WHERE PEOPLE ARE DYING OR
GENERATION HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY THE LEAD. IN THIS WEEKEND.
THAT IS COVERED BY A TARP. WE
CALL B. PSE AND PULL THEM THAT
THERE THE IN THE CAR THAT
HOLDEN YOU CAN BLOW DUST. THAT
IS COVERED IN LEAD INTO THE
SURROUNDING ME. WE'RE TIRED OF
IN GOVERNMENT AGENCIES PTSD
WRECKING BALL THOSE **** THIS
IS YOUR JOB TO LOOK SERVICE
WE'RE NOT ASKING WORKS. YOU
BACK THE THIRD THE PEOPLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN ADVOCATE
REMIND THE TELEPHONE CALLERS TO
PLEASE MIND THEIR LANGUAGE-
WE'D APPRECIATE IT- PLEASE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU THAT IS MY NUMBER
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
SIX ONE. HI THIS IS A NETWORK.
AND I WONDER I AM AN ATTORNEY
HERE IN LOS ANGELES. AND I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR ALLOW ME
JUST TO PUT A LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE I REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED Q. AMIS AS WELL AS%
COMPANIES INVOLVED IN
STAKEHOLDERS. THERE'S A
QUESTION FROM ONE OF THE
MEMBERS. SAID WHY DID IT TAKE
AN AUDIT WELL THE AUDIT WAS THE
RESULT ACTUALLY IS THE
COMMITTEE MAY RECALL A LAWSUIT
CONCERNING UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS FOR THE PWC DID NOT
COOPERATE. R. UNTIL CRITICAL
DEPOSITIONS WERE TAKEN. AND ONE
OF THE COMMENTS ARE WRITTEN BY
MR PAYER SO TO WAS THAT THEY
HAD OTHER THINGS GOING ON AND
THAT WAS CORRECT- THEY WERE
UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS THAT
WERE BEING CARRIED OUT AND
ELAINE HOW ADDRESS LOS. NOW
SHERMAN SALAS YOU HAD ASSEMBLY
BILL CALLING FOR A 50% COLA
INCREASE WHICH WAS A TRUE COLA
INCREASE BUT NOT A RACIST. MR
PURCELL SAID FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS. THE CURE ME COMMUNITY
HOUSING OPERATE. I UNDERSTAND
FROM TELL STORIES OF THE
COALITION OF PROFESSIONAL
PHOTOCOPIERS THEY'VE HAD DELAYS
FOR FIVE YEARS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SO THERE IS A
PREVALENT THEME HERE. A COAL
REYES IS NOT A REYES IT IS JUST
PUTTING THE QB'S WHERE THEY ARE
IN THE BIG CONCERN FOR THE
QUEUE ME CRISIS IF THE INJURED
WORKERS. DOUBTS THE FRICTIONAL
COST THAT MOST OF US KNOW EXIST
FOR THE INJURED WORKERS. THE
FRICTIONAL COSTS FOR THE
KERRIER IS MINOR COMPARED TO
THE IMPACT ON THE INJURED
WORKERS. RECORD INDUSTRY
PROFITABILITY BEEN DOCUMENTED
ON WORKERS COMP. THE SMALL
THINGS THAT ARE HOLDING UP.
THIS SORT OF A PROPOSAL OR
THINGS LIKE THAT ISSUED AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD PAY
TWO DOLLARS OR THREE DOLLARS A
PAGE IF THEY'RE TOO MANY
DOCUMENTS. LET'S THINK ABOUT
THIS INDUSTRIES CONCERNED CAN
BE EASILY ADDRESSED THEY ARE
THE ONES SENDING Q. AMAZED THE
DOCUMENTS. IF THEY WANT TO PAY
LESS THEY DON'T NEED TO SEND TO
PROTECT. THE SEND ONLY WHAT IS
NEEDED THE BURDEN HAS TO BE ON
THE INDUSTRY NOT THIRD PARTY Q.
M. B. C. UNDER THIS FEAST
CATTLE AREN'T EVEN GETTING A
COLA INCREASE. UNDER THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE
CHAIRMAN'S HOUSE YOU ASKED
ABOUT DO WE EVEN HAVE
CATEGORIES. POSITIONS RIGHT NOW.
THE DATA IS BEING STUDIED. ON A
POSITIVE NOTE I WANT TO SHARE
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THAT. WHEN
WE GOT INVOLVED O THIS
TELEHEALTH REGULATIONS I HAVE
TO THREATEN A TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST THE
DWP FOR NOT ENACTING EMERGENCY
LEGISLATIONS. THE GREAT NEWS
WAS THAT THE NEW DIRECTOR KATIE
HAGEN HAS BEEN EXCEPTIONAL SHE
GOT INVOLVED. AND SHE MADE
LEGAL. SHE MADE LITIGATION
UNNECESSARY AND WE ENACTED
SOMETHING AND SHE ENACTED
SOMETHING AND I THINK TO THE
FUTURE THEIR ARREST SOMEBODY AT
THE HEAD OF THE DR WHO CAN GET
THINGS DONE- I WILL LEAVE THE
SPECIFICS TO OTHERS. WHO ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AS TO WHAT THE TRUE
FAIR RATE IS. BUT THE Q. MEET
NEED MORE MONEY IN ORDER TO
BRING THEM BACK INTO DISTRICT.
APPRECIATE BEING AVAILABLE. I
VIEWPOINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTRUST ROOM FREESHEET YOUR
COMMENTS WILL BE ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
GO TO MY NUMBER FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FIVE ONE
THE LINE IS OPEN. HOW DO FIND
APA CHAIRMAN SOLLICITATION
COURT- AND THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE I SHOULD SAY- HOW
HAVE I AM TO BE WITH YOU ONE
AND- EVEN PRIVILEGE. OUR
SUPPORT THE BOB SECOND BY SO.
THE POOR SURVIVE ALLEGE AND
THAT IF THEY IN THIS AND THE
NEW S. SENATE. AND- IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCED AND THEN
ALSO HAVE ABOUT THAT AND THEY
HAVE A DAY AFTER HUNDRED WITH
ME- TO THE COUNTER FOR SPACE
THANKS FOR THE- FOR THE- ELDER
ELDERLY PAY IN SOME TO ME I
THINK ENJOYED IT TOO. I AM I
WILL THINKING ABOUT LAST NIGHT
OF MUSLIMS I THANK GOD SO MUCH
FOR A THE PEOPLE IN NORTH AND
OUR- AND PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING
THE KINDS OF THE- FROM
INCIDENTS THATARE. THAT ARE
HELPFUL TO ME IN A VERY PAINS
FOR ME BUT I'M THANKFUL AND
EXCITED FOR EVERYBODY IN THIS
IN THIS. COUNTRY I'M SO
THANKFUL BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE A-
ANTI. OF US. REAL HIGHLIGHT
COMING FROM HER- I. SHORT WAVE.
AND SO THANKFUL REVENUES THANK
THE LITTLE BOY AND GIRLS OKAY
MY SONGS CALLS ON BOARD A SMALL
BY STATE SAID IN A THE EFFECT
ONE IS A- IN THIS LITTLE
PROGRAM KIANA THINK AB APPLE
DOLLARS. SO MUCH. HI THIS WHICH
ONLY NO. THAT I KNOW THERE'S
DIFFERENT. WHEN I GONNA IN A
STATEMENT I DON'T. I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT NANO TECHNOLOGY
AND I KNOW KNOW. WELL NOW. OF
THE STUFF LIKE THAT IT'S REALLY
PAYING FOR ME. IT PAINFUL FOR
ME UNTIL. BE KEPT UP ALL NIGHT
NO ALL AND ALL THEY HAVE. STAY
MY PRIVATE AND THAT'S A PRESS
PARTS. TURNING THE THEM TO HAVE
THE MESSING WITH ME MIND IN MY
HEAD YOU KNOW. THEY HAVE
ALREADY STUFF LIKE THAT I KNOW
IT'S TO BELIEVE. AND I'M BE
ABLE I'M AFRAID OF THING COULD
HAPPEN KIDS AND I DON'T WANT
ANY. LIKE ELEVEN OF TORTURE
LIKE SEVEN MINUTES SIX TO
TORTURE TWENTY FOURTH. I AM ME.
HAPPEN ANYWAY ELSE ESPECIALLY
NOT A CHILD ON THE FOR COULD BE
I. YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK WE DO
BUT I THINK IT MIGHT. IN THE-
AND I DID WANT TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW. WHAT KIND OF IS A FORMER
HE USED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
SOMETHING WHAT MAKES. AND HE-
WAS A REAL NINETEEN. IS THAT IF
THE MANAGED YES LIKE THAT TO
THOSE WHO SHOULD LOOK AT. THEM
THEY'RE YOUNGER FELLOW.
ATTEMPTED ARE. LOS ANGELES.
ALSO ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
INDUSTRIAL MANAGEMENT SURGERY.
AT FIRST LIKE TO THANK. YOU ALL
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO. SPEAK
IN FRONT OF J. LACK. ALSO JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO YOU- THE AUDITOR. AND THE
GREAT WORK THAT. SHE AND HER
TEAM HAVE DONE IN. SHAPING
WHITE ON SOME ONGOING
SYSTEMATIC ISSUES RELATED TO. A
DWTS MANAGEMENT THE QB PROGRAM-
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
THINGS THAT HAVE COME UP DURING
THIS HEARING- NUMBER ONE THE
COBIT ISSUE WHICH- CHAIRMAN
SALAS BROUGHT UP IS VERY
PERTINENT ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW
DURING THESE TRYING TIMES-
THERE BEEN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
KOBE CLAIMS FILED. IN
CALIFORNIA BY INJURED WORKERS.
MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN DENIED
AND- MISTER PARIS SO DOES YOUR
MIND THAT THERE MAY WELL BE
ZERO AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
DOCTORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SHE IS CORRECT
THERE ARE ZERO AND THERE HAVE
BEEN ZERO- FOR THE TEN YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
QUEUE IN THE INDUSTRY. THE D.
W. C. HAS NOT SUCCEEDED IN
ATTRACTING ONE PHYSICIAN TO
ASSESS THIS ISSUE AND NOW. THIS
IS A VERY VERY BIG ISSUE AS WE
CAN ALL HELP WITH THIS PANDEMIC.
DELAY LAST MONTH THE WCI ARE BE
ISSUED A STUDY CALLED COST
IMPACT OF MEDICAL CARE DELAYS
IN THE CALIFORNIA WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. THE STUDY
FOUND MANY INTERESTING THINGS
ONE OF THEM WAS THE CLAIMS OF
SOFT TISSUE INJURIES THAT HAVE
JUST ONE MONTH OF DELAY BEFORE
RECEIVING FIRST MEDICAL SERVICE
CARE HAD SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
INDEMNITY AND MEDICAL COSTS
THAN SIMILAR CLAIMS WITHOUT
MEDICAL CARE DELAYS. THERE'S A
LOT MORE DATA IN THE STUDY I
WON'T BORE YOU WITH THE DETAILS
BUT THE CONCLUSION IS THAT
DELAYS IN TREATMENT INCREASED
MEDICAL AND INDEMNITY COSTS.
SIMPLY PUT THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
TO LET ME IS THERE WEREN'T
ENOUGH Q. AND NEEDS A YEAR AGO
WHEN THE AUDITOR FOUND LESS
THEIR CONTINUE NOT TO BE ENOUGH
TODAY. AND THE LACK OF Q. AND
HE'S RESULT IN DELAYS WORSE
MEDICAL OUTCOMES FOR INJURED
WORKERS WORST FINANCIAL
OUTCOMES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYERS. MR PERRY SAID IT DID
CORRECTLY SPEAK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT A FRICTIONAL COSTS THAT
ARE PLAGUING WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE AND OTHER
PROVIDERS OF SHARED IS THIS
WHOLESALE REVISION OF THE KEY
SCHEDULE THAT TIME FRONT OF US.
WHILE THERE MAY BE AN INCREASE
FOR SOME PROVIDERS WE KNOW THAT
ANY SORT OF MASSIVE CHANGE IN
THE SYSTEM IS GOING TO RESULT
INSTRUCTIONAL ISSUES- MR
PERSONNEL SAID THE PROVIDERS
WANTED A FLAT FEE UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S JUST NOT THE CASE
PROVIDERS. FROM DAY ONE HAVE
BEEN ASKING TO BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT AS PROFESSIONALS WHO
CAN BE PAID BY THE HOUR- JUST
LIKE ATTORNEYS ACCOUNTANTS AT
CETERA BUT- WE WERE CLEARLY
TOLD BY D. W. C. AND BY PAYERS
THAT THEY DO NOT WANT US TO
WORK ON AN HOURLY BASIS THEY
ONLY WANT TO BE PAID ON A FLAT
FEE BASIS. AND ANYBODY THAT'S
HIRED WORKERS DO YOU WORK ON A
FLAT FEE BASIS- YOU KNOW THAT
INCENTIVIZES SPEED NOT QUALITY
INDIA- THE AUDITOR CORRECTLY
POINTED OUT THERE ARE SERIOUS
SERIOUS ISSUES. WITH REPORT
QUALITY SO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF THE SYSTEM AND
THE POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT MIGHT COME
WITH SUCH A CHANGE. THAT BEING
SAID WE ARE OVERDUE
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR SUCH A CHANGE
AFTER. DR ROSENBERG'S CONCERN
OF ABOUT WHY. WE ARE HERE A
YEAR LATER AFTER AUDIT ALL IT
WOULD HAVE TAKEN AS A STRONG OF
A PEN JUST THIS. AND OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT WORK ON APRIL FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY. LOADING I WANT
TO THANK J. LACKING AUDITOR FOR
ALL THEIR WORK I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO MISTER ROCKS. SENTIMENTS
IN TERMS OF- BUT A BIG THANK
YOU TO DR DIRECTOR KATIE HAGEN.
WHO HAS BEEN A VERY HELPFUL
ALLY IN FIXING SOME OF THE
ISSUES PLAGUING THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING
IN THIS IMPORTANT AUDIT TO HELP
PROTECT THE INJURED WORKERS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR INJURED.
WORKERS WITH THAT LET ME ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON THE TELEPHONE WE
HAVE NO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE. OKAY
GREAT- LET ME TURN IT BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE DYESS IF THERE'S
ANY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS IF NOT
WE WILL MOVE ON IN OUR AGENDA
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SEVEN-
WHICH IS CLOSING COMMENTS I
KNOW ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE A STATEMENT
PLACE YEAH I THINK I'LL BE
BRIEF I JUST WANT TO THANK THE-
WILL COMMITTEES J. LIKE ANY SEM
FOR THE CONTINUE TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THIS ISSUE
INTO THAT THE CLEAN UP IS GOING
TO BE GOING ON FOR MANY YEARS I
HAD AND JUST WANNA- WELL
THERE'S A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
AND IN THE COMMUNITY WE CAN'T
GET IT WRONG IT'S ARE LIVES AT
STAKE OUT THERE AND SO. I AM
COMMITTED AS LONG AS AS WELL AS
MY COLLEAGUES TO CONTINUE TO DO
THE WORK TO ENSURE ALL FAMILIES
ARE SAFE IN THIS COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SOMEONE
GARCIA. AND REMARKS AS WELL-
WITH THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE THAT WAS INVOLVED IN
NOT ONLY MAKING THIS HEARING
HAPPEN BUT REALLY ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF THIS HEARING AS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I LIKE TO THANK-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK CENTER
MORLOCK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN CENTER
GONZALEZ. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REBEKAH BEAR QUE HAN SENATOR
DRAWS ON SENATOR ALLEN FOR ALL
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING- I. THANK WOULD YOU
HEARD TODAY IS REALLY THE
FRUSTRATIONS ON THE REAL
CONCERNS ARE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT PEOPLE. ARE
FEELING AND LIVING THROUGH. AND
AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
HOLDING THE DEPARTMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S NOT ONLY ACCOUNTABILITY
BUT A REAL PLAN MOVING FORWARD
TO ADDRESSING AND MITIGATING-
THE REAL CONCERNS THAT ARE OUT
THERE NOT ONLY THE HEALTH
IMPACTS BUT EVEN THE IMPACTS
THAT ARE. OCCURRING IN THE
COMMUNITIES AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD- FOR THE Q. MEPS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ENOUGH QUALITY MEDICAL
EVALUATORS TO HELP OUR INJURED
WORKERS ESPECIALLY IN TIMES OF.
OF COUVENT- WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE. YOU KNOW AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. SPECIALIST
I CAN ACTUALLY HELP WORKERS I
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT'S
HAPPENED IN TWENTY TWENTY- WE
NEED THAT ACCOUNTABILITY OVER
AT D. I. R. AND THAT D. W. C.
AS WELL AND I'M VERY CURIOUS TO
SEE NOT ONLY THE RESPONSES. OF
THE ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR TO
THE AUDITOR BUT- HOW IT'S
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED AND WHAT
IT ACTUALLY MEANS FOR HELPING
INJURED WORKERS- GOING BACK TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND EXIDE- WE
EXPECT. WE EXPECT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE MONEY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY
APPROPRIATED. AND I DO WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
AND ASSEMBLYWOMAN GARCIA FOR
ALL OF THEIR WORK. THAT THEY'VE
DONE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
IN THEIR BACKYARDS THEY LIVE IN
AND THEY'RE THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THE
HEART AND THE PASSION TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THIS- ISSUE
MOVE FORWARD- AND ADDRESSING
ALL OF THIS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE SAFE
WE NEED TO MAKE. SURE THAT
THESE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED AND
MITIGATED. AND I ONE FINAL
NOTE- POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I DO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MORE LOCK. FOR YOUR
SERVICE ON THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR TIME HERE AND
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAD A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS I BELIEVE YOU'VE BEEN
AT EVERY SINGLE HEARING- THAT
WE'VE WE'VE HELD WHETHER IT'S
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING OR A
VOTE. HEARING- BUT DO
APPRECIATE. EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND WE APPRECIATE
AND- YOUR EXPERTISE AS WELL SO
THANK CENTER MORE LUCK WITH
THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
CONCLUDE THE HEARING ON THE
JOINT WAS A LOT OF COMMITTEE IN
THE- ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING.